I was trying to speedrun up in the stream started and the game.
This game crashes so heckin' easily and it literally just crashed there.
Praying it works.
But good morning, good evening, and good afternoon.
Wee today.
My screen is gone black so hopefully I'm still streaming.
Oh my god.
Right.
This game breaks.
Oh, I think it's about to break again.
No way.
Oh, this game breaks so easily.
Oh, don't break, don't break.
Oh, my screen's black again.
What?
Oh, this game breaks so easily.
I think this is like 2007 maybe, but goodness me.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Wee are playing yet again, surprise surprise, another childhood game.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's 2009.
It says James Cameron's Avatar the game 2009.
So I played this game as a little sheriff and is there a girl that's white with black
hair but, well, not blonde, I'm not, well, we just did that.
Right, we're blonde with green eyes today, yippee.
So this game.
Okay, now it's got enter first name, squiddles, squiddly, I'm feeling a bit squiddly diddly
the day but I bet you'd like that, wouldn't you?
I had no idea they even released the game back then.
Oh, this game is, I, right, I'll shush until the campaign part but they much to the campaign.
Let me, I got slapped together.
Let me tell you that much.
I got slapped together.
Welcome to Pandora.
So, I am a big enthusiast of Avatar.
I absolutely enjoy the movies to the highest of heavens.
Oh my god, I've not played this in years.
Oh, look at us.
Sigourney Weaver.
Big Sigourney Weaver, where'd you been?
We've missed you, Sigourney.
So I got three words for you.
Don't screw up.
Got it.
I like, this is not stood up to the test of time, graphics wise.
My neck be bending.
My armpit textures are warped.
Oh, AC and Snow Berries.
Hi.
How was your puzzle game, AC?
I watched you in the bath.
That's it.
Oh, this is really weird.
I was in the bath and I was like, I'm sure AC should be on right now.
And I opened up the game and you were like, this is a child's game.
How can I do this?
I thought I could do this because I think someone said,
why did you pick this game first?
Snow Berry Raid.
Yeah, there was like a big whale with loads of ropes all over it.
And I was like, I've never seen this game in my life.
I'm too dumb.
Did you not finish it?
Was it like a finished game?
Or was it like one of those ones where it's like, ah, you just played for fun?
Is Sheevee's fault?
Sheevee, what did you do?
She put the ropes in.
Oh, that's very good.
Oh, you finished it.
Let's go.
AC Smart.
Hell's gate.
Kendra.
Congrats to your names, Kendra.
Okay, so we are playing an RDA soldier.
Boots on the ground.
We are a signal specialist, okay?
We've just arrived at Hell's Gate,
which is where the humans have landed on the Navi's home planet, basically.
And the way that we humans survive is by sectioning off areas of Pandora,
because Pandora is so aggressive and dangerous.
Wendy, yes.
Shag the big blue ladies.
Soon, soon.
Hold on, hold on.
You've never seen the movie before?
Okay.
How do you even summarize Avatar?
This is a very old game, and it is not a fair, like, assessment of what this game's about.
However.
However, however, however.
Too long didn't read, um,
blow people good, humans bad, capitalism bad, being nice to the environment.
Good!
That's it.
That's all you have to know.
You have completely caught up to the Avatar franchise.
Are you squeezing me right now?
Ah!
Bojenga, I'm thinking.
Brian?
Not me getting Brian back on the HUD.
Thank you so much, Bojenga, for the 13, I appreciate it.
I'm looking forward to this stream of this game that literally no one has played.
I wish I could do a poll right now, but if I back out of this game, um, it crashes super easily.
So basically, I don't even know if I'm going for a toilet break today.
I'd like to open a set.
Apparently the campaign mode is eight hours, but I don't believe it.
Yes.
We're at signal specialist.
I didn't even know there was an avatar.
Well, there's a new avatar game now, but we're playing the OG.
Let me take a sip of my honey tea today.
Aloha.
Did you guys watch Mercy's ASMR?
Congrats to Mercy Modis being the only member viewer to not get her VOD taken down
and leave a warning on her channel for sexual misconduct.
Give it up for Mercy!
Oh my God.
Let's go, Mercy.
I am so nervous for my ASMR stream because I had planned something a bit special for it.
And YouTube are dancing with all of us right now.
Sorry, I'll get over the cutscenes first.
We get to experience being in a navi body for the first time.
If you haven't played, or don't know, you enter a booth which neural links you to a actual navi body.
Don't look too much into it.
It's pretty fantasy based and all that jazz, but yeah.
We are now in navi, we have access to a navi body, but we are still RDA.
RDA is the bad guys.
Boo, boo, RDA.
Navi, yay, navi, yay.
But RDA, boo.
Out you get.
Oh my God, that neck!
Oh, that's killing me.
She looks like a giraffe.
She's like, ooh, let me get over this bed real quick.
You're actually quite good at this.
With my fine tuning, you'll be zipping about with the best.
So we have just been introduced to our avatar body.
Navi body.
RDA mission complete.
So yes, this is a much older game.
You need to find Kensington and help him bring the side gates online.
They just shut down.
So we are about to...
He's ready for you.
He's eager to meet you.
He usually doesn't interact with the avatars.
Hate them.
Folks got a thing against avatars.
Like I said, there's more going on here than you know.
It's good for its age, honestly.
So the newest avatar, I haven't had an...
Oh, Brian!
I'm here to be neural linked with a reefling.
This should cover the copay.
Barrow, thank you for the 20.
Would you guys neural link with me?
Like if you could go to bed, like you see everything from AppioV.
Would that still be in control at that point?
Or would you want to control me?
Or would you want me to control you?
Do you really need to ask?
I don't know if you want to see my appeal with me.
You just like dine and be really disappointed that I don't have big boobs.
Does the nicotine patch interfere with the process?
Nah, you can leave it on.
If anything, it makes it better when you're in control.
I don't know.
Nah, you can leave it on.
If anything, it makes it better when you're in control.
So this is the reason
we are
in Pandora,
the world.
You see those purple things underneath?
Those are the resources
we mine from this planet
for capitalism back on Earth.
It is crazy, honestly.
I get to pray.
Hard to believe you're finally here.
Seems like a lifetime ago.
Reporting for duty, sir.
Drop the formality.
Atonement.
Someone in the avatar program is feeding
classified RDA info to the local
Navi squad.
We've got to have a full scale
made of uprising on our hands.
The resources be purple.
You'll see soon enough.
A big boat better than Big Bois.
Your skills as a towbreaker are highly
underrated on this planet.
We're here to get the blue oil.
Someone say oil.
Oh, they can't use
By the dawn
sparely
Did I tell you
in a voice chat
I sung that but I only know the first two lines
and then
freaking Sheevee and Azura
burst out into singing
the actual thing and I was like
oh my god this is really
I was getting
by the dawn
early
lay
I once
I don't know the words at all
and I don't know why it's so hard.
Why does it go high?
Did you guys see my Twitter post about
how much I got scammed on American sweets?
Hello.
So these are just basic transporters
but as you can see this is the whole map
of Pandora. We will unlock a few more locations soon
but there's not really much detail to it.
We're currently at Hell's Gate.
We are going to get flown to Blue Lagoon
but as you can see this earth
is healthy. There's lots of blues and greens
and all that.
It's a nice healthy earth.
Blue Lagoon.
Open the game, oh that's just a
information thing. I thought I was going to explain
what Blue Lagoon is.
Blue Lagoon is where a lot of the navi
that are controlled by the RDA side hangout
and a few of the tribes are tolerant
to our behaviors.
Our human activities.
You want to see the planet?
This is the safest place to do it.
Yes.
So this is tutorial island essentially.
I thought this game was a fever dream.
It's real.
Hi Stormy. I remember playing this game as a kid.
Congrats you're one of the two people
who have played this game.
That's watching right now.
A very very underground game.
I'll tell you a very fun factoid
about this game.
So obviously I was an Xbox kid.
If you were able to obtain a copy
of the
special
Oh
I
loved that little
animation.
This was probably before
motion capture was even a thing
because what the heck was that?
Our encounter
with Pandora's
wildlife. These are
viper wolves.
They're terrifying.
But their designs
are so good.
The animal designs are freaking amazing.
I am needing to
remember
to analyze.
We have freaking special abilities
for some reason.
I can go and visit and shit
but you can level up and progress
and make these abilities way stronger
and literally it's pretty insane.
The game's got loads of things going for it.
So right now we're just
defending the perimeter
from...
What's the way the game isn't too loud?
I cannot adjust the volume without breaking it.
We're just defending the perimeter from
almost a shot or one guy there.
Is it working?
Okay, there we go.
You do get XP.
There is a level up system in this game as well.
I am so bad at aiming. Holy crap.
It's hard with a child.
Child me is like so much
better gamer.
When it comes to this stuff honestly
Lollipop
model confirms
we're doing some rewards
because actually why am I so much better
at this game? I know they spawn over
there a lot.
Okay, objective complete.
Love to see you play the game
but I will be very happy for
every Navi I see die.
You're joking.
You picked the RDA?
Who are you?
Iron Reaper?
You picked the freaking...
Why would you prick?
I literally just had a Freudian slip and
called you a prick there.
Why would you pick?
Not the Navi.
Thank you for the 50. That's insane.
Thank you for the 50.
But you're wrong.
RDA supremacy.
Reflangs?
We're here for...
We're here for nature
and to be nice to wildlings.
I'm literally a cuttlefish.
Are you saying...
Oh is this Halo Controls?
No, kind of.
You can be attacked when you go out
but I will say one thing
the motion sickness. Merci.
If you're lurking do not watch this.
This motion sickness on the vehicles
is insane. Oh we're doing hit and runs.
Oh right, I missed that but whatever.
I can't remember much.
There is going to be...
This guy should...
There is like aim assist in this game
so if you're bad at video games
please don't worry if you ever
think you might want to
give this game a shot.
This game is giving
commands for keyboard but that's
because...
What?
Wait, wait, wait, four pounds!
Wait, where the heck did it go?
I'm fighting.
Oh, we're going to stick a match to go down.
Oh come on!
You can tell Peel as well which is really good in this game.
This game is definitely for people who
are not very...
I would say if you're new to gaming
the game is very friendly to you.
I say that as I literally am forgetting
all the spawn locations of the enemies right now.
These are...
Viper Wolves.
Um...
Literally waiting till this game
gets so beautiful. I wish...
I don't know what the new avatar game is like
genuinely about. I heard those growls.
I heard that!
I have gamer sense, okay?
Oh, there's another one.
Jeez!
My trigger just got stuck there.
Um...
Are you squidding me right now?
What?
No!
The Navi are the good guys!
Slice Saber?
How dare you?
Thank you for the tip.
But the Navi are the good guys!
We're supposed to protect humanity, okay?
Right, so we're currently saving
the current signal thing.
I don't know.
Tutorial...
We are doing tutorial, but I'm just spamming through it
because I want to be Navi.
Dogs.
Everyone's literally so beefed up
in this game for no reason.
Wait, you say Navi's good guys
protect humanity.
The Navi are the big blue ones.
The big blue ones protect
nature. We protect nature, okay?
We...
Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on, you ready for this?
We protect nature, little reform.
You want to be a good boy for humanity.
You want to recycle
where physically possible.
But we understand...
Oh wait.
If the RDA are the bad guys,
then why are their mechs so cool?
Checkmate, tree huggers.
Uh...
Well, I'm going to show you
me absolutely wrecking and fricking decking
those mechs.
There's no way you guys are genuinely
picking the human side.
Doomsday, Dan.
You're getting a spank, but thanks for the tip.
And Beijing got again.
No!
You're wrong. You have to be nice.
If I have to hit me...
Tree huggers!
If that makes me a tree hugger, then guess what?
I'll proudly identify myself as a tree humper.
Oh, I just got her. Oh, I'm getting...
I'm getting... I'm getting ganged up on.
I'm getting ganged up on.
Well, literally, the bark is peeling off
from how hard I'm humping the wildlife
right now, okay?
Because...
I'm not...
This is so much easier as a child.
Hello, child, me. Can you just, like,
I don't know, possess my body right now?
Because why am I getting wrecked and decked?
Glory to the hypno, toad.
Protect the navi and the sea stuff.
Oh, for goodness sake!
I'm getting wrecked! I'm getting wrecked!
I'm getting me right now.
Only simp for cuttlefish.
Human supremacy.
Down with the blues freaks.
Would you get...
Tim... What the heck? Tim Shuttle?
Tim Shuttle?
Your name is literally cuttlefish, a little Shuttlefish.
Glory to the hypno, toad.
Protect the navi and the sea stuff.
See, Tim knows exactly what he's on about.
Thank you, Tim! At least some of us have sent...
Are you squidding me right now?
Sorry, Strone, but I'll never trust a species
whose idea of taming animals
is to penetrate them with weird tentacles.
Right, you've got me there.
You've got me a wee bit there. Hold on, hold on.
But give them a chance, give them a chance.
Thank you, Otter Von Biscuit.
Damn right you only simp for cuttlefish.
We the best out here.
Oh wait, I just realized,
I think I'm supposed to drive the car in here.
Oh, I think I'm about to get attacked.
Or maybe those guys are protecting me.
I'm not sure.
There we go.
Run now, the logist!
Oh!
See, you have level up system.
I have terrible news for you.
If you want to do survival of the fittest,
no weapons.
Absolutely. Goodness.
Is this...?
Take this!
Fort Bomb.
Thank you very much.
Uh...
Tharja IBW.
What a unique...
Thank you, thank you very much for the tip.
Sorry, Strony, but I'll never trust a species at...
Look.
All I'm seeing is give tentacles a chance.
I might be getting a little tentacle edition here and there, you know?
Am I going the wrong way?
It looks like I'm going the wrong way on the map.
I've not been here before.
Oh my goodness, the camera angle.
Look, the game aged all right.
I'm not going to say it aged well.
Wait, is there a little path back here?
It's a lie.
Oh my goodness, this camera angle is horrific.
I'm getting sick myself.
Let me in.
I'm human. What are you doing?
Okay, I actually have to go backwards.
Thank you, not Alessandro as well.
Rules of nature, survival pit.
Oh my god, lady driver moment.
Please, camera angle.
Please, jeez, Louise.
Let me work here.
My goodness, this is awful.
Why is the camera dead?
Oh my god.
This is horrific.
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh, thank god I don't get emotional things in the video game.
Do not expect the message to work this time long.
Anyways, have fun, strongy, and rejoice.
Brian's back.
So when you tip, you can actually, like,
I can hear it and you can hear it.
Thank you again for the another tip, Alessandro.
Bitches, when you tip, you will never be read out.
Oh my god.
That camera angle is horrific.
Please, do not ever make me drive one of those again.
Thank you.
Oh, goodness me.
Right, what is the heck is this?
I've forgotten.
Oh, it's a teleport pod.
Okay, you can teleport between the different regions.
So this is all the Blue Lagoon area.
As you can see, there's one, two, three, four, five.
Why are the teleport points all at the bottom
and only one at the top?
I'll see how it is.
Make a mirror walk everywhere.
Okay, a little sip of my tea.
Have you played it?
Are you sure you've played this before?
The accusations?
I'm not beating the accusations.
Right, I'm going to finish my tea before it gets too cold.
I'm delicious.
I like the reverb effect on the burp.
I mean, I don't want to ruin anything,
but that definitely may or may not happen
in a certain ASMR stream.
I like freakin' changed the title of the ASMR stream
because I don't know what is going on.
Everyone's getting warnings left, right, and center.
Now, don't get me wrong.
Any jumping up and doing on the bed,
it's quite humorous, okay?
And I don't know, did she be actually doing
anything that was that wrong?
Azura, now, the only reason I will say
Azura had received that warning
was on the pure basis.
Her voice is just like honey.
Her voice is
the sun embracing you
after a few days of rain.
Her voice is like honey.
Her voice is like
that hug you have needed for a
years, and you just
let it all out, and you
like, her...
However,
the other side of the coin for
Azura's voice is
it won't go down.
It can't stay down.
There's no such thing as a refractory
period to her when you listen
to her voice. Maybe you'll get 10 minutes
of peace at max, you know what I'm saying?
So, I can't
get why she got a warning. I don't think
she got a warning because she was
wise enough to private it.
I don't know, I don't know if she did delete that.
Did she do ear licking?
Goodness me, can't even do it with ear licking.
I don't know what's going on, because people
that show their face are still uploading
all fine and dandy, so I think
there might be a H-E-N
update to the tie.
Possibly
pop stealth policy. Oh god, not the camera
angle again.
I'm currently driving with one hand, so this
is going to go absolutely awful.
But look how big Pandora is, it's fantastic.
One hand steering whilst I
drink my tea.
I'm like a real contractor, honestly.
Look, I'm just here to do the contract work.
I'm not here to do anything special.
I get paid on the day.
Okay,
driving isn't actually that bad, right?
Let's speed up, let's go.
Let's see if two handed, I'm even worse,
probably.
Oh, I'm hitting, I'm hitting the land.
I'm doing the Titanic.
Titanic momentum.
Yes, thank you.
Thank you for the tip, Kitsune.
Literally,
I don't think I've really
met anyone that's
heard about this heckin' game.
But I'm glad that a few of you actually have played it.
Okay, I'm just on the walking teleport stations
when I do that.
Hi, hi everyone joining.
We're playing Avatar, James Cameron's
Avatar. Some people thought
it was Avatar
the last airbender related.
No, no, no, no, no.
Not at all. Although, I think
we might be doing a watch along with that.
If you're into watch-alongs, please do
think about supporting your local neighborhood
little sister, because she may be
doing a watch along with that already.
I'm going to take a little sipping tune of my cola.
I need to hydrate.
Now I get to ramble about
all the work I did yesterday.
Okay, so the update is
Are you squidding me right now?
Unless.
Brian!
Honestly though,
thank you for the tip.
Tarja.
I feel like that's not how you're supposed to pronounce it.
Or are you Swedish and it's
Tarja?
A little bit of a Swedish
moment.
Look, it's that guy we saved
in that cave only a few minutes
ago.
Viper Wolves.
What kind of cola?
Just cola cola.
Is it called Coke Zero
when it's got the no sugar?
I finally went no sugar on the cola.
Aspartame.
I can finally tolerate aspartame.
It is that thing that is in the drinks
to make it sugar free.
But I was like, I don't mind having
a big badonk-a-donk, but I don't want
it to get too big, so I'm now
drinking aspartame, which apparently
gives rats cancer.
So it's not looking good for us mammals.
But hey, oh, you gotta die something
and, you know, I'm not going out
without enjoying myself.
That's all I'm saying on them.
There are Viper Wolves here, so please excuse
the combat.
Boom.
Now, you can just kind of do this.
But it does bring
you out of fricking invisibility.
Get in the boat! Get in the boat! Drive away!
Drive away!
Yeah, see, they get scared of my little
fart bomb.
Actually, I think it's called a supersonic wave
and they don't like the noise, which makes
sense. You know, nature doesn't like loud
noises. Can relate
on a
physiological...physiological?
No, not physiological.
Now, you can just skip quite a bit of combat
if you're cheeky, but only
if you're smart enough to do the things
in the correct timing. I'm going to heal up.
You can heal up naturally and it just
means gentle for time. As I said, this game
is super forgiving to new gamers.
If you are into
that fantasy element,
am I to walk from here?
I can walk from here.
Nature doesn't like loud noises.
Literally, the loudest of nature.
The sea bomb or a big badonka,
those are the two choices.
I don't mind getting too big.
No, sorry, I do mind getting too big.
You gotta keep that pear-shaped bone.
You know, like when I do that
hand cam stream, everyone's
going to know the real size of my
chest.
Yes, I
will teach you all the strats of this game.
And for those
who are wondering, is this
an adjourned stream? This is roughly
a
seven-hour
strom.
So do feel free to strum yourself
for the full seven hours, if not,
then the seven-hour stream.
Roughly.
I believe we will actually successfully
catch Mercy for a redirect
if my humble Mercy
is streaming today, which I believe she is.
As always, if any
of my gen mates come online, please
remind me and I will
tell those who would
much prefer to watch a game that isn't
archaic, or whatever they're
doing on stream.
We're supposed to
for seven hours. I feel
like that would
hurt.
But anyway, because
I cannot tell you how strange
it was to go offline after
two hours, it
literally felt like, what do we
do now? Oh, now we play the game.
Because I was like, wait, I have
so much time.
So
I've got three more
ASMR collabs on the way. I did a little
bit of socializing. We are now Navi.
We're about to do some Navi quest lines.
But please remember, we are
RDA Navi.
To use teleportations, we use
the Tree of Vision. It's very
important to get those because my goodness, it makes
travel so much easier.
Look how tall we are.
And the camera angle has changed and
is much more favorable.
I prefer when
video games have a really pulled
out third perspective camera.
If the camera is two centimeters
away from my face, I do not like it.
I find it very hard to look at.
I don't know if that's because
I need
glasses and I still
haven't trained myself to wear
glasses.
Very bad girl, bad girl, very
naughty.
But I think that my preference
in video games is a zoom out angle.
It might be related to that because
yeah.
But hey,
does anyone know the full
name of the game and it's on
Steam? I
don't even know if it's on
Steam.
It is called
James Cameron's Avatar.
Okay, the Navi can go through
these doors. Nope.
Only when they're green. Okay, sure, sure.
We are about
to encounter the wildlife. They will still
attack us even if we are Navi
and RDA.
Does not matter. Where the heck
am I going? I'm going the wrong way.
That's why I'm getting turned around.
Now again, we do have superpowers.
We have sprint. We have invincibility.
We have health. And we have
ground smash, which is
very good. In order
to get healing
if you look
on when that health bar
comes up again, you'll notice the number
zero at the bottom left, on the right
side of the health bar that appears
bottom left. The more cell
samples we pick up, the more
second chances we have.
Now it's very common to
run out of health in this game.
It's just the thing that happens.
It's not a big deal. Again, the game
is very forgiving. You can literally do
this all the way through the game, and
anything can hardly hit you.
But the later sections of the game
I don't know if there weren't
many playtesters, because it was
very rough in the later sections
of the game. I've done that game pretty rough.
We are going to unlock this Tree of Vision
so now we can teleport to this region
when we come back to 100%
of the region.
How many games do you have
lined up? Do you mean
to play in general?
If you mean
games overall
like daily
streaming games for a year?
Question mark!
Next week in
endurance is Skyrim.
It's another childhood game of mine.
I used to
do 100% achievements in Skyrim
every year, because I really appreciate
the game and its vanilla form. I do apologize
if you like mullets, but...
I don't know what to say.
I'm very...
We aren't friends?
Would you guys
really
appreciate a bit more?
What?
100?
Also humans number one baby.
No!
Anonymous!
No! Bad boy!
Bad boy!
Thank you for the 100.
That's a lot of money though. Please make sure
you're looking after yourself and treating yourself.
100 is a lot. Jesus!
Bad and on! Bad boy!
Come get spankings right now. Bad!
Let me take a sipping then.
Are you squidding me right now?
Good just me.
Exactly, Nero!
Exactly!
We stand nature in this house.
We will look after nature.
As you can literally hear me dancing about
in my chair right now.
So we are...
What the heck is that zone?
And why is it so big? Oh, we're plant sampling.
Okay, this is tutorial section.
When I explained...
Thank you for the tip again, Nero.
Anonymous, my goodness, that was a lot of money.
Please...
Is something attacking me? No.
When you pick up cell samples, there's that little
white bar on the left side.
I didn't... And you thought there was enemies
because I was like, why am I getting...
Playing as an avatar. As an avatar,
Pondora's flora
which means
flowers
and fauna
means
animals.
Yes.
It's less aggressive towards you.
Therefore, killing an offensive creatures
and plants will not yield
experience points.
All the reeflings siding with humans
want to be the guy from Stronny's law video.
Oh, I'm so bad.
Hope a siren doesn't drown me.
Thank you!
Thank you, Anonymous, for the tip.
Oh, you guys
don't want me to, you know,
take you down in the waters with me.
That's not...
Honestly, my lore is so evil.
I promise. I don't want to...
I don't want to hurt...
Why do I suck so bad at this?
Wait, what was that?
No way! They have a slow motion kill cam!
I did not
recall that whatsoever.
That's amazing.
Don't threaten us with a good time.
That sounds very yandere-esque.
But, yeah, in terms of evilness
and lore, why?
What was that? I heard that.
Oh, I can hear it!
I actually got scared there.
I heard it, but I couldn't turn
the analog stick in time.
So, if I am human...
Why are there so many?
Oh, no, I heard the plant.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry, Mr. Plant.
I'm actually getting a bit scared.
Why is there so many?
Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on. Pause.
Pause! I hear more!
Oh, my God, they're literally biting my ankles!
They're biting my ankles!
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop.
Okay, relax.
Relax.
We're just collecting cell samples
in this area. I think I've hurt every...
All the enemies are gone.
Yeah, so these
type animals don't attack.
They can't bite my ankles, man.
If you are human and come across
this plant, it is very
poisonous. It spits a
bale at you, which is actually really cool.
But
the design elements that went
into this game is just
beautifully...
Or...
But, yeah, like, the development,
you can actually...
Yeah, you can, like, scan...
Who goes there? Who goes there?
You can, like, scan stuff
and add it to a database and that.
I've never 100% of that. Maybe we could do that?
Oh, no, we can't
because I would have to play the RDA side.
But I'm not playing the bad boy side.
But, yeah, like, if you're into, like, 100%
completion, absolutely can do that kind of thing.
Oh.
But it is...
A very beautiful game.
I am very much into, like, alternative, like...
Oh.
Oh. Oh.
I saw that.
It popped up my little thingies. I knew it.
Right, where are we going? We're just heading next.
We can do this
and just kind of try and bypass
all the enemies on the way.
Enemies.
Did you watch the second movie?
I absolutely did.
I thoroughly enjoyed the first movie
with Jake Sully.
Absolutely.
Congrats, if your name's Jake, by the way.
Absolutely
fantastic movies.
Completely captured me in that kind of fantasy
different world.
Especially the nighttime scenes
when everything is lighten up.
Oh, speaking of lighten up, hold on.
Reactive model.
You ready? Reactive model?
Do you want this? Or do you want my normal model?
I can turn it over.
The bioluminescent scenes.
Yes, bioluminescent scenes.
Pushing boots to destroyed
Avatar 2 in the box office.
Woo! Our first meet with a navi.
Like an actual navi.
Not an RDA navi.
Are you ready? Hello, Tanjala.
Oh, I'm stuck on
this corpse of a themobobber.
Hello.
Hello, I'm a kaya.
This is good.
Oh, Renee Harper is
Sigourney Weaver.
She's been poused with a navi.
She overflicks them. Tanjala wants
you to kill the
sick strumb beasts.
Anyone else identify themselves as a
strumb beast? Cause
that's ridiculous.
We're really starting to dig hard
for these words.
Avatar 2 had no story at all.
Perfect how not to make a sequel.
I disagree. Brian!
Don't worry, Stronny. I played
navi 2 when I was younger.
I liked having all the animals be
my friends. Exactly, Grimbo.
Thank you for the tip.
We do, Brian. The first movie was just
a crossover between Pocahontas and
Ferngully. I have not seen Ferngully.
Bejinga, thank you
for the tip. What's Ferngully? Have you
guys seen Ferngully?
Are you doing your way to eat?
You like
Sigourney Weaver a lot.
Sigourney Weaver
the first thing I've seen her in
were just to destroy these by the way.
Sigourney Weaver Avatar
was the first thing I ever saw her in.
And I just adored her.
I adored her character. Her voice
is so lovely as well.
It's such a...
If you ever struggle at this
point, just jump up on this rock right here.
They can't hurt you
if you go on the rock.
They can't do a thing. If you're on the
floor, these guys will knock you over
and take a big chunk of your health.
Is something else attacking me?
No.
But we're good to go.
Robin Williams plays a bat in this.
Ferngully is basically the
Barbie Pixie...
The Barbie Pixie movie
in 2D, but human...
It depends on that guy.
It was a good movie.
The direct to VHS
was okay.
Tim Curry sings.
Oh my god, Rocky Horror Picture
Show. You put your hands on
your leg. No, that's not right.
You put your hands on your hips.
That's it.
We should watch that.
My mum
really likes that movie.
I've watched it from a young age.
Yeah, it's absolutely bizarre
to conceptualize what on earth happens
in that movie at a young age.
But hey ho, that's just life.
That's just how it is.
Oh, I heard.
Butta Dog.
I heard that.
And mama.
What are you doing here?
I'm so tiny.
Oh no, I'm so big.
V, you're Azura.
You're talking to Azura right now.
This is the height difference between you and Azura.
I'm shutting down the knob.
It's Emmy and Azura.
Oh, it's Emmy.
A giant woman.
Now, don't lie.
Don't lie right now
and say to me, I didn't cook
with making Azura a giant test.
I will not take...
If that's not going to hurt me,
I'm laying it boys.
We're doing it, we're doing it, we're doing it.
We're just going to stealth through this section.
There's a lot of dire wolves.
Viper wolves.
However, we're no interested
in fighting.
We're just going to zoom past
because this entire section
is optional honestly.
We're just going to zoom ahead again.
Cooked, you did indeed cook.
No, I knew I wanted
some sort of thick Vtuber model.
I'm sorry, I'm going to say it.
There's really not that much variety
for the thick
and for the chocolate.
So, it was just
absolutely no questions asked.
Probably going to do the same in Gen 2
where, you know, something's going to be lovely.
Brian!
Awwww.
Is she the main...
Is she the main alien?
Because I remember reading a really...
Oh, we're on a horse by the way.
Check it out. Look at my horse.
My horse is amazing.
Oh my god, his face is all...
That's a really unfortunate face.
But everything else, yeah, it's alright.
Look, I'm riding a pony. I'm such a girl.
Oh my god, this is the girls game as well.
Oh, there's actually a really... This is really boring.
But when we come back to this section later,
an enemy always spawns on this rock
and he's infinite stuck
and you can never, like, hurt him.
Well...
Okay.
It's time. We need to make a decision.
Are we Navi?
Thank you very much, Iron Reaper, for the tip.
I think I actually forgot to say that.
But thank you for the tip.
Are you squidding me right now?
Nero!
Thank you, Nero, for the tip.
So we are a signal specialist
and we've set those signals up
but we were told that they weren't gonna...
It wasn't gonna be used for destroying Navi.
Nory, Nory.
Great work, Ryder.
I smell promotion in the air.
Do you realize what you're doing?
Think about what you're doing.
Any of this look familiar?
Wait, that's...
So we're learning we just destroyed all the Navi's home?
I didn't do this.
Everyone's hearing about it.
The new SIG spec locked the target.
What the hell did you think you were doing?
They told me it was...
Are we the baddies?
They used you, Ryder.
Ryder? Hardly even nor.
Oh wait, sorry, sorry.
Hold on, do that again.
Ryder? Hardly even nor.
Hardly even nor.
Come on, how goofy is that?
I wanted to see...
Ray, are you ready? Are you ready? We're gonna do it again.
Okay, hold on.
Let's do this bit and then when we're mucking about I'll do it again, okay?
That was amazing.
Right, so this is where you decide.
Do you want to be Navi or do you want to be RDA?
If I shoot him, we become RDA.
If I shoot him...
WE BECOME NAVI!
And defend this Pandora
in the name of being a foreigner.
We need to kill it. We guys first go.
Destroy him!
Just... Oh, I'm low health.
Oh my god, I'm farting about too much.
Oh, why is he so strong?
Right, go...
Wait, I'm actually gonna get...
I'm gonna perish.
He's like actually wrecking and decking me.
What's going on?
Why is his health not going down?
Why is my aim bot so bad?
Right, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, let me aim bot.
He healed up! No, no!
Only I'm allowed to heal up.
The enemies shouldn't be allowed to heal up.
It should be illegal in video games.
Development team, you have failed.
It should be...
He's shooting me as well.
Can you like shoot the other guy?
Right, hold on. Let me readjust this aim bot.
No, he healed up!
Only I'm supposed to have him healed up!
Right, that's it.
Grimped!
Didn't even work. Did it work?
I don't know.
I'm gonna be honest, this is a few too many bullets
are going through you.
I spoke too many bullets.
He survived all those bullets.
He grabbed your dire horse.
Dire horse?
Banshee!
Iknu-i-ma-ya
No idea who I'm supposed to see.
Sounds like I'm trying to say something in the dark.
I...
Iqalvanyu?
It's not Iqalvanyu.
Got anything better than bows and arrows?
Those are the only weapons they need.
Great. Good choice, Ryder.
Iknu-i-ma-ya.
Couldn't humans kill the main guys?
Human body in the machines?
Yes.
That's very true, but...
It was arranged that the...
Oh, look at her! We stunning on them!
Look at this, got a little outfit of the day moment check.
Oh, come on!
Look at my dual-wield blades!
Come on, that's so cool!
Oh, how did I hit?
Oh, that's so cool!
Come on, that's so cool.
I'm sorry, but look how cool that...
Oh my god, that's terrifying!
Imagine that running at you.
Oh, I just crap myself right there.
Your avatar isn't blonde
because blonde doesn't exist in Navi, I don't think.
Maybe it does, I don't know.
I don't think I recall seeing a blonde Navi.
Oh no, I do!
In the different regions of...
But we are jungle Navi.
This is jungle Navi.
There aren't, like, types of Navi
or jungle Navi.
Sadly, not closer to your level plus.
We need to win his approval.
Oh my god, she's so real for that.
Okay, we need to try and get the approval
of this guy.
Why?
I've already forgotten the plot,
but we're gonna do it anyway.
But basically, we are full Navi right now
and I'm gonna tell you some...
Okay, this really is a girls game
because every time we go to our next location
we unlock new outfits as we level up
and I get to, like, play a little wardrobe simulator.
Oh, such a girls game.
Yeah, he ain't happy at all to see me in.
Oh, I need to be able to ride a Banshee
or an Ekran, that's what they're called.
Traitor.
Oh my god.
Hold on, I need to be able to lay feet
because I'm hurting my legs against the table.
Did I just skip dialogue in that?
New outfits, let's go to the next area.
Oh my god, fashion simulator.
We played Landlord Simulator on Brotherhood.
Now we're playing fashion simulator on Avatar.
Right, we are about to learn
a motherfucking bow and arrow.
Oh, did not mean to do that one.
Let's try that again.
Pardon me, excuse me, that was very daft.
I just absolutely threw myself off the mat there.
How do I zoom in on the bow and arrow again?
Not that one.
Oh wow, it's just hold and release.
Okay, who would've thunk?
Who would've thunk, it's just hold and release.
The Navi's drip is indeed real true.
This game seems surprisingly competent, actually.
I was doubting, I get game.
Honestly, I get game.
Wait, what am I doing?
Oh, we're doing our first human kill.
Oh.
We are.
Yeah, the aim is very forgiving.
If you want an easy game,
definitely recommend this game.
The bow and arrow is very satisfactory.
But I'll tell you one thing though.
Oh look at this camera,
look how terrible this camera,
it like pings off of different,
like you can see the markers
of where they put the tracking to do that.
Like it's not smooth.
Oh my god, who goes there?
Identify yourself.
First human after killing two low level,
so actually true, I just recalled that.
Really willy-nilly killing over here.
Any willy killers?
No, don't.
This is another armor we can't get to unlock
about later on, it's not quite the same.
But here, we speak to Bower
a word for it.
Yeah.
The scale of the arrows are massive, they are.
Like Navi are so big.
So there wasn't a big tree in the game?
Oh, we aren't at the end of the game yet,
you just hold on to that though.
You're a couple of missions ahead,
but I like doing two things.
They don't disconnect us for treason, honestly.
She wants the braid tail?
What happens if we braid tails with each other?
Is that like a marriage proposal with Navi?
Oh, that's his wife? Oops.
What do you say?
To K?
Will you help us?
These boxes are explosives.
TNT?
Yes, we have word for this.
Kangangang.
Oh, that's so satisfying to say.
Kangangang!
I messed with that.
You can flip into the waterfall to get down here a bit faster
I will heal, but I shouldn't have done that.
I thought you could slip down without too much.
Oh, you have 50 bow and every time you get a sample,
you replenish your bow and arrow ammunition.
So all those green is more bows.
Genghis Khan? Okay, you're done.
Excuse me, pardon me, coming through,
you guys can't aim, oh I can't aim either, it's fine.
Okay, I think because my keyboard is registering,
hello?
Hello?
Okay, I think because my keyboard is registering,
the aim assist isn't being as active as it is normally
on Xbox, because I could have sworn I didn't even have to aim.
Oh, jeez, they just disappear.
Okay, we seem to get either 5 or 10 arrows from samples,
which is pretty good, I would say that's pretty good.
Kangangang.
Tanzu Simulator, actually.
I prefer the bow and arrows myself,
but I'll tell you something that's really sad about this game.
As we level up, our equipment also becomes stronger in nature, okay?
However, if you did not purchase the special edition,
which they made about 1000 copies of for some unknown reason,
if they didn't do the special, if you didn't buy it,
your bow does not one-shot the enemies as you level up,
it is complete nonsense, they made only so few copies.
I was like, oh do you see how that flower attack is attacking them,
and they're taking poison damage.
So unfortunately, our bow and arrow, I can't even see them through the...
Braw, why are you missing?
Braw.
You do heal over time naturally when there's no fight,
so you don't always have to spam heals, what's this?
What's that?
Ammo, I thought my ammo...
Whoa, wait, what do I have access to?
So dual wield, one big ass swing,
a gun and a bow, right?
I normally just stick the bow.
Very good.
Very good, very nice.
But overall, game is very forgiving.
If you're ever interested, we should do that, but that comes later.
We'll always come...
Oh, the acran just said bye to that,
I'm pretty sure they would have got mowed over,
but look, as long as they're happy, I'm happy.
So right now, we're picking up our boom, boom, gang of con.
Do you mind?
Where did you come from?
You weren't even there, you're such a liar.
You're lying to me.
Where are they?
I hear them.
Snape, and not Snape, I am low health, that's okay.
We're gonna heal up like that, she can heal up,
and then we're just gonna move...
Oh, we're not gonna move on to the next section,
we're gonna go invisible.
Oh, no we're not, why?
Can you still...
I don't know if you saw that, this Trippid,
those flies were attacking him,
like literally Pandora is so nice to you when you're napping.
I love it.
Oh, I hear them.
I...
Oh, so these are bombs that fly into you.
I'm pretty sure I heard a guy's voice though.
I'm like 99% sure I heard a guy saying they're out there,
but I didn't see it.
I love the way you say jaw wield.
Oh, no.
Wait, does it say differently?
Jew...
Jewel wield?
Jewel wield.
Jewel.
Pandora thinks humans are an infection.
They are, they're terrible.
When you play RDF, it's just as truly similar.
Oh, that's hilarious, honestly.
It's such a good game.
I love this game so much.
The only complaint I have about this game,
it was made when games like to do...
Why?
It's like I have to aim a little to the right.
I do.
I've aimed a little to the right.
We can go down or up.
My memory says up, question mark.
Jewel wield.
Well, my memory was correct.
Oh, he got a little ambitious with trying to hurt me there.
Where is this?
It's up there?
Oh, it might be up there.
Whoa, I just spotted you in the corner of my eye.
Yeah, these are literally, you know,
I don't know what they're called.
Those bombs that are for submarines under the water.
I don't know what their name is,
but that's what those are, but in the air.
Oh, I missed.
Yeah, the aim ball in this game, aim working.
Aim ball, please.
Wait, he didn't perish?
Jeez.
It looks like they're...
Oh, we need to shoot that.
Hold on.
Wait, do we actually?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't remember this part of the game.
What's the rocks for?
Am I to destroy these?
No way.
Yeah, so I'm using bullets too.
Aim ball, aim mort.
More like sense ball, aim mort.
Why?
The aim assist is not like me.
I'm not actually going to claim that tree of nature.
That's what...
Tree of nature.
Travel point because...
Holy crap.
Oh, no, I don't have unlimited ammo.
I thought I had unlimited ammo.
Jeez.
What did that do as a child that made...
It really must just be the aim assist.
Because I think if you all one-shot everything,
there's like no way this stuff is even hurting me.
Half as much.
Oh, I missed.
I shot, and I missed again.
And then I shot.
And then I missed again.
And again.
I don't know how to unshoot.
I can't pick up ammo from that.
I can only pick up ammo shells.
Honestly, let's see if we can get away with this.
Because we just need to pick up the package and then go.
Oh, wow.
Okay, cutscene time.
Cutscene time.
Whoa.
Gang gang gang.
Gang is gone.
Okay, let's get the heck out of here
because I don't want to get hurt
any more than we need to.
I heard that belief and I was going to go for it.
I think we're about to get an early crown.
Long story short, I missed.
Yeah, I missed a lot.
And then I shot.
And then I missed again.
Thumb a right.
Oh.
Okay, we're about to climb.
Climb, climb, climb, climb.
Yeah, I think the campaign mode is roughly seven hours.
We could probably come back in 100% the sectors.
And we can also play this mini conquest game,
which actually I really enjoyed as a kid.
But you have to do it at the end of the game
for like 100% success rate.
There are Viper Wolves ahead,
but we're just going to be cheeky and do this.
And then we completely negate
even having to fight a lot of them.
Unfortunately, invisibility.
Invincibility is when they can't hurt you.
Invisibility is when they can't sneak.
It doesn't last forever,
but as we level up,
like, oh, actually, we're really close to leveling up.
I don't know if I should.
I don't want to hurt the wolves.
I don't want to hurt the wolves,
but I'll kill the humans.
No problem.
Yeah, no, that's fine.
That's fine.
Yeah, that thing, that thing.
It's friendly fire on.
No, you cannot hurt other navi.
Now that you're a navi side,
I assume it's the same if you pick RDA.
Oh, good snipe.
Okay, if I can take my time to, like, properly even.
No, I think I was out of range.
There is a range to your attacks.
Like, you can't...
No, no, I just suck.
There we go.
There is a range distance to your attacks.
I cannot for the life of the human.
Am I to go this way?
No, classic dead end.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Mom, get the camera.
Play of the game, honestly.
Did you guys see that Marvel superhero, like, 5v5?
I hear a bomb.
I see a bomb.
Um, um, um, um, um.
I really don't want the bomb to get me.
Oh, I'm already out of invista.
And the bomb is chasing me.
Okay, we're doing it.
We're just going for it.
We're committing.
Did anyone play it?
Marvel rivals.
Yeah.
It looks so good.
Everyone was, like, dogging on it,
but I'm like, oh, I actually really enjoyed the look of it.
I'm installing the game now just to kill the Navi.
You know what?
You're done.
I'm definitely going to play Marvel Overwatch when it comes out.
Yeah, and then wasn't there not another company
that came out with another Overwatch-style game?
I think development teams literally watched,
like, the mess up in real time.
I don't know if that thing's still chasing me, but...
There is another one.
Yeah, like Scarlet Witch's Moira and all that.
Yeah.
I used to play a lot of Overwatch.
I actually really enjoyed the game,
but I just don't play it anymore.
Like, I don't find it rewarding or...
Which is such a shame,
because I've poured a lot of hours into that game.
But I would absolutely love if we could do Marvel rivals together.
It's like a stream snag game, like...
I don't know how the accounts work,
but I'm like 99% sure I can make a dummy account
and then, like, add user's friends
and then make note of who's, like, played
and then just rotate between, like, kind of what we...
Oh, here we go.
Level up.
What did I unlock?
Let's see.
Bam knee pack.
We have a club weapon with fricking spears on it
or another type of RDA gun.
Oh, and a shot and a missed.
Oh, and a missed again.
I can hear an enemy.
I don't see him.
Oh, there he is.
That wasn't him that said that.
Oh well, whatever, whatever.
Blizzard is horrible with their IPs yet.
Time to go back to Team Fortress 2, honestly.
But I could have sworn I saw another development team
come out with something that was similar
out to the format as well.
So I think literally everyone watched,
Overwatch 2 come out
and as soon as Jeff Kaplan left the development team,
I think everyone behind the scenes
knew what on Earth was up
and knew it was, like, essentially going to flop
due to the change in gameplay.
But when Marvel Rivals does come out,
because I think it's in beta right now,
or I may be wrong,
but I'm happy to make a dummy account.
We'll make it a multiplayer game
and we'll just kind of add...
I think it's 5v5, so it means four reeflings
and myself can play at the same time
against just randomers.
We'll, like, play actual public match games
unless you guys really wanted to go against each other.
I'm not sure having me and your team
will be a good idea, though,
because I'm not very strong at the game
and I can't play it.
But if that's something you guys are down for,
I'm heking down for it as well.
Obviously, we'll remove everyone
at the end of the gaming session
and restart fresh.
As I said, it'll be...
I saw that...
I don't know if I'm going to get...
Right, I'm backing off, I'm backing off.
I don't think...
We don't take that down yet.
No, that part comes later on.
I didn't...
No, I'm going to pick this up.
There we go.
Team Landers, Johnny.
Should I tell everyone what to do?
Protect me! Heal me! Heal me!
I used to play Zarya,
which is an offensive tank
in...
Overwatch.
Oh my god, they're so beautiful!
I love...
The music's changed.
Oh, they're so beautiful.
The Ikran.
Look at them all judging me.
That's okay, you can judge me.
Look at them, they're so pretty!
Hello, please don't attack me.
They're so beautiful.
Please understand, this game's a little old,
which is why they're all the same color.
Please forgive, please forgive.
But I assume the new avatar is really beautiful.
My Ikran literally almost made me perish
and then said, yeah, alright, I'll pick you up.
I got pranked by it.
I literally done a little pranky on me.
A little pranky-wanky.
No, no.
It's not a good look, honestly.
I mean, you would really choose
match over...
Pickle over the big birdie?
Exactly.
Why don't you pick?
Oh, look at us, we're soaring.
We're soaring.
Wee!
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Sorry, your wing, your wing.
My apologies, sorry.
I didn't mean to hurt your wing, little Banshee.
But thank you for being so forgiving.
We're just flying through the map now.
Banshee's have an insane HP.
We will be shot at as we go around.
I don't know if you read that really quickly.
It said lifting the fog, 50%.
Don't worry.
Oh, we really need to get some height.
Oh, I'm going to do a little cheeky 360
to get that height there.
We are about to reach the ceiling in this game.
Alright, climb, climb.
Jeez, this map has a lot of verticality.
Definitely did not remember that.
But yes, there was a sector challenge
that says lifting the fog.
There's a few sector challenges.
Depending on how long the campaign takes,
we might actually just 100%
all the sections.
Excuse me, game.
I know for a fact I flew over that.
Would you like to register me flying through this?
No? Oh, okay.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Woman moment.
Okay, there we go.
There we go, you got it in the end.
Whee! I'm sure this is
really beautiful cinematic.
Oh, we got it. Okay, but we're hitting that rock.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Look, the camera angle isn't...
It's not that easy to freaking dive, dive!
Alright, then go up, go up, go up.
There we go.
But yes, Banshee
are a really good way to get around these maps.
Whoa, whoa, easy, easy, easy.
And we are back to the start
where we started.
Look at us going.
Isn't that beautiful?
Okay, I am going to say
before we start this next quest
there is a
voice line that repeats consistently
through this mission. I will try to get through as fast
as possible. It is so annoying.
It is so annoying.
Genuinely so annoying.
Horrifically annoying.
Unless this isn't
the mission.
Don't say that.
Maybe this isn't the mission I thought it was.
Audio bug is the worst.
Is that Ubisoft game? It has to be.
The animals slowly regretting letting you
drive them, honestly. Okay, no, it's after
this mission. They are really annoying when it pops up.
What did we unlock?
A crossbow
and some sort of ability.
Hold on.
How do I open that?
Skills?
Kinetic Dash, Ewa's Breath
Titan Bash I don't really use.
We could maybe replace it
with
Calls of Hyperwolf to your side.
It will fight for you for a short time.
That is pretty cool.
Death by Bees.
What the heck am I supposed to do?
I completely forgot.
We are going to raid Ikran.
Can I go on you?
Okay.
Oh, he is going forward.
I never really...
Breath!
I see you after work.
Thank you, Tiny Spiny.
I appreciate the tip.
I did look it up.
I said the game takes around 7 hours
to complete. If we come back and do section stuff...
Wait, where am I?
I'll land.
I think I'll land up here.
It looks like I'm definitely to land to keep
Ikran safe up here.
You stay there, buddy.
You be nice and safe.
Have a good day at work. Thanks for hanging.
I appreciate it. I appreciate the tip.
Support it.
I'm not to say donations because it's not a donation.
Actually, I don't know
if I'm supposed to update the girls
as things to be like...
You know how you're supposed to put
a disclaimer on the freaking thing
in case someone does a charge back?
Right.
I'm 99% sure these guys
just keep respawning.
So I'm actually not
to fuss...
Do you mind? Thank you.
I'm not to fuss
for completely clearing up this section.
Uh...
Am I to beat it up?
Oh, it's a bomb!
It's a bomb!
Okay, there we go. Let's go up.
Is that about to blow up right next to me?
Oh, I didn't...
Kill guys don't look at explosions.
You know the drill, okay?
Wait, you mean stream elements
is intact?
If someone does
a disclaimer for charge back
I'll probably edit the motor then.
Or when a girl...
I don't know, I get tired.
Oh, I have a fantastic
update for
scripts. Oh my goodness.
So the script manager
now has access
and is taking over
and look
so everyone has
a four-part series coming out
like a story that kind of progresses.
Um...
Shebe's four-part series
is currently being written right now.
I'm not trying to say anything
but good luck trying to hold it together
when she performs that script
because
wow, I was blown away.
I'm like, there's definitely
something to be said about
a guy writing a script versus what I could write
because I just...
I like challenging myself
and in general I know what
overall you'd like us
to say type thing
but I have to admit, I was like
oh my god, there's not gonna be
any...anyone left in the
sack after that one.
And that was part one I read. I didn't even read
the finalized series of it.
Azur's one is being
worked on next.
Um...Oh my god!
Sorry!
I wasn't paying attention to how many
bad guys are there. Right, we're gonna watch the
explosion this time because we can.
What's the explosion look like?
Okay, it was just kind of out of control.
Oh no, the terror does go down! Okay, I like it.
I wonder if we can get some
XP for destroying this.
Ow! Okay, we can
get XP for doing that.
I think? Why did...
Uh, Azur's
story...
I don't know if I should ruin what the story is.
Like, I don't want to like
tell stuff that's kind of like exciting for
girls.
But, like, I like
the four-part series ideas. Like,
Emmys one, I really like.
No, don't spoil it. Okay, I won't spoil it.
Um...Oh, there's a home
tree right there, actually. I don't know if I should
grab it then. Actually, no, I have
access to the Ikran to fly
around the map so it's not gonna be that big of
a deal of us coming back.
Newbie would begin
a work is a lot, so I
was good job as well. Yes, I like...So
now that, like, the scripts are no longer my problem,
I get to
focus on making the girl short,
so Mercy came out with a short and she
was like, do you...Do you think
I should have been blonde senpai and showed, like, behind the scenes artwork?
I'm gonna get everyone
to do that to show their concept art.
Like, me as well, actually, I need to write the
scripts. And, like, I get
to work on that kind of fun stuff
instead of kind of, like,
being stretched too far.
Like...
It's too easy. It's too easy.
I'm not even gonna say it's that easy.
Um...
You can go as well, because you were shooting
my Ikran. You're not supposed to
shoot my Ikran.
Um...
I'm literally...Spoilershine is always the beginning for...
Literally, I...
I get so excited about everything that's planned
behind the scenes, that I'm like, oh,
I don't want to ruin it for the girls.
Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow,
wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow,
sorry, sorry. I'm too busy rambling.
I'm not even actually focusing on the dang game play.
Stop!
Okay, legit.
Wait! Oh, no!
We don't one-shot them anymore. They've gotten too
strong now. That's the problem.
If you don't, like, um...
Farm XP,
you will fall behind.
Concept art was great to see.
Yes, so I get to, like, kind of do that fun
behind-the-scenes script stuff, like,
shorts for the girls.
Um...
Also,
super gracious thank you
to everyone who
is using YouTube clip
feature for the girls.
If you didn't know,
if I go on their stream, I can see
who and what has been clipped.
I just want to say,
there's actually quite a few people
who are clipping my burps at the moment.
I might unironically make a
15-minute burp compilation, just for the heck
of it, and call it, like, strong burps for
14 minutes and 53 seconds.
Just for the heck of it,
because it seems to be
something a few
gentlemen seem to enjoy, and, you know, I'm not
here to ruin anyone's day.
But yes, please do consider
clipping. We have a really funny
short of Icy
coming soon.
Our second clipper
we're kind of testing them out.
I don't have a problem, because they've already had
extensive clip history, but
they're busy at the moment, so the clips are
a wee bit slow to be produced.
But we're getting there, we're getting there, so
thank you to anyone who uses YouTube clip feature
to help out.
A short of Icy doing what?
So it's already happened, so it's not a
spoiler.
But Icy, basically, when
in her adorable voice,
I'm not very smart,
and then she went, thank you so
much, Mike, honey
for donating to me
in her adorable frickin accent.
And I'm like, Icy,
Icicle, should I
have taught you that? Should I have said to
you
what that means?
So we're going to, we're going to get
turned into a clip, and I'll be sure on her
thing.
But her accent is so frickin adorable. Okay, I'm
going to bed. Rest well, see you in the
morning when you wake up.
I love seeing that. I love seeing that
whenever you guys are like, okay, I need to go
to work or I need to go to sleep. I'll see you
in the morning, see you in the morning. Oh yeah,
I'll see you after work, yeah, yeah. Oh, you
need to go out and do some errands, I'll see
you after that, I'll still be on. Right, this
is the scene.
The quote is, Raider, you have got to
get to higher ground. It will be repeated
a ridiculous amount
of times.
Yep, I remember the quote, I've not even
played this game in many a year, Raider,
you have got to get to higher grounds, it
will repeat, and I'm like, did no one play
test this? Did no one
see what an issue this is?
Because I've gone the wrong way.
I've gone the wrong way.
I'm gonna part myself.
Right, let's hurry this up
through this section.
Ah! Oh my god, imagine
that coming out, yeah, I would actually
be so terrified. Shawnee,
you've got to get to higher ground, honestly!
Get that
done. Get that
done.
Right, we destroy one
way.
Oh, I love it. Love it.
Special, what's right? Oh no,
what's my special?
I don't know what button the special
is though. Yes, we spawn at checkpoint.
It's putting, it's giving me keyboard
input, but I'm playing mouse in control,
like I don't know if you can hear my analog stick.
Let's give that another try.
That was a bit daft.
I do apologize
for that MLG game. I'm going the wrong way
again.
I can't all be good
at video games.
Literally, wherever
nine-year-old me is inside my head right
now, can you come
and help us out here? Because this is getting
very good. This is getting embarrassing.
Right, I'm going
to click the analog sticks this time
to see if that's what the special
is instead.
Right, special, analog,
nope, that's,
nope, that's scan.
What would
R be?
You know what, I'm just going to hit R on my keyboard.
No!
Don't throw me, it's so...
Wait, why is this not breaking?
Is there a health bar? Oh, there is!
Is it glitched
out?
I can see that health bar, that little green.
What's going on?
Thank you for the tip, analog.
Wait, I think it's glitched out.
This is an old game, hold on.
Let me do this.
I'll do it with a bigger one.
Uh...
Game?
Game, you're showing your time.
I've never actually had it glitched out
here before.
Right.
I had to press F on the keyboard.
I don't know what button I was supposed to press
on the freaking...
I'm sorry, oh, it keeps saying it.
Literally, right where you've got to get to
higher ground.
I literally F in the chat, that's...
Oh!
Oh, you're getting worked, mate.
Oh, then you fall now.
Oh, he's hiding in the freaking bushes.
Right, healing up, healing up, healing up.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Actually, I think these are much faster.
Yeah, these are one shot.
The dual wield is one shot,
but the long stick isn't one shot.
What does that mean?
Right, okay,
we're just going to press the keyboard.
We're literally just switching between the keyboard
and the ticket thing. I don't know what I'm supposed to press.
Get worked for free, must be nice.
Steady on, are you?
Should we watch her by any chance?
Right, down we go.
I don't know.
Are you squinting me right now?
Beijingle!
Stop!
No, I'm getting trolled.
Thank you for the tip.
He repeats it so much,
but he's not doing it right now.
I wonder because...
I don't know why he's not repeating it.
But I kid you not,
he constantly repeats,
you have got to get to higher ground.
You have got to get to higher ground.
Over and over and over and over.
But, I think we're actually
being given...
Oh, objective control.
The classic three
and done in video games.
If aint broke, don't fix it.
Do this thing three times
and you win.
Delicious.
Delicious, delicious, delicious.
Love it.
I love it when game devs get the memory.
Oh my god, I'm inside that!
I'm inside it! Leave a load!
No!
Oh no.
I'm a...
Oh, that's not good.
I'm having a seizure.
Home tree!
Wait a minute.
I think I might have died
and now I'm at home tree
and I'm about to be spiritually be a Navi.
I'm physically about to be
100% Navi
if I remember correctly.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Oh, I can feel myself connecting
with nature.
Ah, she...
Oh...
I find this so cool.
Are you kidding me right now?
Heck yeah, speak for the trees.
Thank you, Tim Show.
For the tip. I can never say that right.
Shuttle.
Eywa just resurrected me
and Eywa's word is truth.
So I will not be taking any
contesting points that I'm no
a Navi anymore.
Actually, I really
enjoyed the second Avatar movie
because what's her name?
The one that is
Sigourney Weaver as a child?
I really like her plot line.
Eywa, that she's like
she can commune with Eywa.
I really like her.
Avatar Stoney has
an arrow under her hair.
There's a second Avatar movie?
Yeah, it's called We of the Water.
Did you not get advertised
on anything?
There's a second Avatar movie.
It's out right now.
I may have just spoiled it for you.
I apologize.
Eat.
If I was home tree,
I would tell Stoney to
If I was the home tree,
I don't know what he want.
What are you on about?
This is a spiritual location.
You can't
loot the home tree.
Okay, I say that as if
there is an agenda concept right now
that may or may not have
have some non-influenced playing.
You cannot
do any activated mission things.
Oh, it's the guy.
Nothing but more than pure
agenda.
My new abandoned name.
Advertising for the second movie was
a booze ball.
It still did really well, did it not?
If I'm not mistaken.
Are you underestimating the power?
You acting like the tree?
Well, it's the Holy Spirit
of Navi.
Okay, we are going to
Swatulu.
Anyone else
visited Swatulu?
Maybe on spring break you went to Swatulu?
Yeah, they are absolutely wrecking
this place.
This is not
this area
is definitely getting absolutely wrecked.
I just remembered what happens
in this area. I'm like night and impotenture.
Very good location because something very
cool happens.
Storm and Scythe.
No, actually I think it's a later level.
You know that?
Anyway, let's go.
The first movie itself
was already advertised enough for the second
that's probably what they said.
That was
really outrageous
writer. I'm going to be honest.
Say no hablo
to a Navi.
I don't know, that felt a bit weird
to me. I don't think we should let that one slide.
That was
that was motivated.
That was bizarre.
And if you're
literally fully Navi, you're not going to put
that on the screen.
And if you're
literally fully Navi, you're not going to put
effort into speaking Navi.
We're going to unlock the home vision tree.
What the heck is that?
Oh, it's a tree of vision. Oh, it's a sector
challenge. Okay.
Am I crazy
or was there a horse I could ride back
here?
Thank you, Child Me,
for remembering.
Oh my god, I'm actually so smart.
You're just menacingly
guarding this horse. Can I just take it?
Thanks mate. Appreciate it.
Hey,
hablo espaol
s, seorita.
Te amo.
Qu pasa?
Dnde
est la biblioteca?
There are
RDA, but the beautiful thing
about these parts of the map
you can ignore it.
You can just zoom ahead.
This is one of those games where
if you want to take your time and explore it
you most certainly can, but if you just
want to be like, right, I want to do the objective
meee, I don't want to leave the horse
in the middle here. What am I doing here?
Oh no, I don't want my horse to
wait, investigate. Oh, I'm only to do a
drive-by? Oh, I can do a drive-by
shooting alright, don't mind me.
Oh, let's go.
Right, I don't think you can shoot
well on horseback. Sorry,
dire horse, it's called dire horse.
But yes, I don't mind
doing a drive-by.
Right, left or right,
both are terrible.
This one's a dead end, so do the
dead end first and then come back for the open one
because it's likely
that the open will be like the next
progression.
Oh, my wee horse is getting
injured.
Shattered village, yeah,
looks absolutely desolate.
Okay, I think the game's
putting horses around the map in case
we do end up losing.
Can you feel like Sample's on horseback? You cannot.
Flexing them,
rolling arse.
What do you mean you cannot roll your arse?
Can you not
iterate what you wish to
rock on?
I just started shoving arse and words that
don't even have it. Oh, my poor horse.
Oh, it's a mech, it's a mech, it's a mech,
oh, the horse is going to perish.
Oh, no, the horse is perishing this game.
I don't like it here.
Let's get out of this place.
Is this the first
game? It is. This is not the new game
that came out. This is the
Archaic 2009
game.
Lunguri is not here.
Where is Lunguri?
Lunguri, where are you, mate?
I need to find Lunguri.
Any Lunguri fans?
I'm a Lunguri fan.
Oh, the horse is getting
in a loop.
With Unipee.
That's right, Riflin.
Unipee.
Oh, Unipee is a person.
Oh, what did we unlock?
Let's see.
The Onato Pack.
What is that?
That looks like shards from the sky.
That looked cool.
I've not actually summoned a horse.
What was that, birds from the sky?
Call on Pandora to help strike.
Oh, my god.
Hold on, what does it look like?
Okay, okay, okay, little baby.
Little baby clangs.
Okay, great.
We can go through here.
Oh!
I'm getting shot at.
Or is he shooting at an NPC?
I don't know. Hello, do you need assistance?
She just expired.
I don't know. I don't even speak Navi.
I don't even know what her last words were.
Oh, my god.
Her family is going to be like, what were her last words?
And I'm like, I'm so sorry, mate.
Sky people.
You're going to have to forgive me,
but is there an enemy there?
No, that's a boss.
Where's the enemy?
That's actually really embarrassing.
Yeah, we don't know her last words
because I'm a dumb dumb.
We're playing that. Hello, are you okay?
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Brian!
True!
Okay, Iron Reaper, thank you for the tip.
I'll admit, true.
However, I present to you
Sigourney Weaver
Second Storyline.
And that's fine with me.
I like that she's connected to Pandora
and control Pandora, okay?
To Awa, and Awa grants her those abilities.
I don't think she's doing well.
Are you going to expire after we finish
talking because
I can't translate
your last words
to tell your
to tell your family.
Oh!
Maybe you should expire
because that's actually really sweet.
That's really rude. Please don't do that.
Please don't do that.
Sorry one.
Please don't.
I need to
claim
Please bearish.
Oh, my bow and arrow is not
strong anymore whatsoever.
I used to one-shot these guys.
It's now costing
to ammo.
Right.
So what we have to do
is just climb up these and then jump aboard
when it comes background
and then we destroy its receiving
signal thing, which completely
Okay, yeah.
Do you remember when we played Elden Ring
and there was that chariot thing
and you had to drop down on top of it?
Basically that.
We just need to
slowly wait for it to turn.
Yep. Okay.
And then
when we get close enough
we just jump down.
Wait, can I not just
can I not shoot that with bow and arrow?
I feel like
with their height difference I could probably
bow and arrow that. Hmm.
Nope.
I believe Elden Ring stole that idea.
Literally.
Right.
I think that's just showing
I need to go up on this one.
I can see it on the minimap that I'm covering up
with my big hair but the minimap
I wish I could put the minimap in the other corner.
You know what?
I'm always covering up the minimap when I play games.
Hopefully it doesn't bother you guys.
I assume it's coming around this corner
very slowly.
Let's try to shoot out.
Are you coming?
Hello?
Is it stuck?
Am I out of its distance to move?
Right, you. I can hear you shooting.
Knock it off.
Stop moving.
Oh look the picture plant.
Look it's sending flies out to hurt him.
Death by flies.
Death by flies. Oh he's in.
Did he come? I didn't know they could use.
Come back. You need to perish by flies
or by bow and arrow. Pick.
Fine. Okay, I'm out of the distance.
Right, is this not?
Is it stuck?
Why am I going to be stuck?
Ugh, fine.
I think we're maybe too early.
Watch it start moving
when I come around this corner.
Yeah, I was kind of
joking. I was actually
joking. But it seriously
did it. I knew that. Where's the
freaking vein? Where's the vein?
Please
from the vine
falling so slowly
like tight.
Are you not moving again
because I'm out of your render distance?
I am being pranked.
Wait, did it move?
Wait, that is it there.
That's it right there.
The render distance is broke.
Bro, it's going to start moving.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me get up the dang thing.
Oh, that's literally the only song
I know of by heart.
It's actually really sad.
There is
an enemy called Avatar the Last
Airbender
and Uncle Iroh is an absolute
beloved character
and he sang a really moving
song. It's literally the only
song I know off the top of my head.
But it's like beautiful
sad, not like
hopefully not too sad, sad, you know?
I need to not bring that song up
anywhere close to what I'm making here.
We can not allow it for spoilers.
Has enemy not seen it?
Please stop it. I'm going to cry.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I didn't realize it was bad guys here.
Take this
and this. Why am I taking
so much damage?
I don't know.
Have I unlocked a new outfit?
No, I haven't.
Wait, do you see that stat increase though?
So as we unlock new outfits, it's going to go up so much.
You mean you don't...
I don't know Secret Tunnel off my heart.
Secret Tunnel, what am I supposed to do?
I'm supposed to do something. Hold on.
I see the blossoms.
Two lovers
forbidden from one another.
There's a mountain
in the way.
And I kind of forget
how this next part goes.
Secret Tunnel
Brian, I'm singing.
Amy's planning on doing it.
So she should definitely support Emure's
when she does that. Definitely.
Thank you for the tip, Nero.
I kind of forgot how this next part goes.
Can you guys put the lyrics
in chat and then I'll sing it to you?
Shawnee, why have all the Scottish people
met? Also nice.
Why are Scottish people nice?
I don't know.
We're just vibing.
Glasgow's been rated one of the nicest.
Oh, we've got to level up.
We've got to level up in our healing and our sprint.
So are we eating faster?
Oh, wow.
Okay, that was a pretty decent distance.
Are you actually a blue guy in this game?
Or are you a skin walker like the movie?
We have...
Our human body has died.
It got annihilated
via missiles.
So yeah, we're like...
We're Navi now. We're just trying to get
accepted by the Navi and to reverse
the horrific effects
that I'm actually
not
very skilled at this bit.
Oh, jeez, Louise!
Oh my God, they like ate my health up
so quickly. So this is what I mean
by you get a second chance.
I now have four second chances.
Oh my goodness.
Get... Right.
He's perished.
Oh my gosh, that was...
Right, he's off of it.
I don't know if I need to like
unironically XP grind
or something.
I feel like I die.
I think I'm...
Okay, we're...
We're out of...
We're out of... Oh my gosh.
I don't remember...
I don't remember the game being so hard.
You know that?
I'm just getting out of here like,
bro, I'm out. You don't need to
worry about me. I'm gone. I'm in and out
like a flash.
Call me Usain Bolt. I'm gone.
Ten seconds for that.
I'm like, you know...
No, not leaves from the vine. The other one.
The happier one. The two lovers one.
Not leaves from the vine. There we go.
That's a sad one.
Scots are nice until you...
Oh, Tia's off, honestly.
Oh my bad. Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying not to be too...
We don't want to be sad up in here.
Good times. Good vibes.
I have no idea what it is.
Strawny, you just channeled some
intense Dark Souls energy by spam-rolling away
from the attackers, honestly, though.
I should probably pick up cell samples
because I ended up using two revives
for that.
I definitely need an armor upgrade
to Sumtium because...
Oof.
Okay, ready?
And a burn
and devades them
apart.
The build
of paths to be
together.
And I kind of forgot how the rest
of it goes, but
Secret Tunnel!
It's such a good song.
There we go.
It's such a good song for you.
A little karaoke
before the actual karaoke stream is planned.
Have a look at that.
I've got to stop.
That'll get stuck
in my head for months.
Oh, do you want the Scottish version of it?
So it's extra cursed?
Wait, someone refit the lyrics in again
and I'll do the Scottish version for you
because I'm just so kind like that.
Wah! Okay.
So the close combat is the insta...
I said the insta die.
Thank you.
Right, Scottish version.
If someone puts the lyrics in chat for me
just so I can...
My brain's a little slow.
Two lovers
forbidden from one another
award
devades their people
for people
Brian!
You interrupted my singing, Brian.
I'm getting absolutely...
Alright. Oh, sugar.
Thank you for the tip, Rick.
Okay, I'm getting too distracted.
Thank you for tipping that.
You didn't have to tip that.
But thank you, I do appreciate it anyway.
Scottish version.
Wait, should I do really easily, Scots?
Two lovers
forbidden from one another
award
devades their people
and a mountain
devades them apart
and built a path
a be
together
Yeah, and I forget who the next couple of lines go.
But then it goes
secret tunnel
through the mountain
secret secret secret secret tunnel
I think I need to go and visit for this next section.
Anyway, that's the Scots rendition.
You're welcome for that on the house.
Didn't even have to pick. Why?
Bone arrow, why?
I'll go invisible
if I'm going to end up perishing
I think.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, these turrets on the wall
are my biggest enemies.
Got a lot of enemies and it's the turrets on the wall.
Not the actual things.
Strona, just had any idea for your outfit.
What about a version
with all of your modesty
plasters are replaced by nicotine patches?
Honestly?
What is going on?
I don't
Sorry, I really don't remember this section
so I don't know what I'm up against
but I'm just going to take it slow
and I'm not wrong with taking it a bit slow
I'm just a bit
I can see something over there
Oh, he's destroying the car.
See empty mechas
What's that up there?
Can I destroy these for XP?
Hold on.
Oh, wow.
Oh, I'm doing a task sector
destroying empty mech.
Oh, wow, they explode as well.
That's actually really good to know that they explode.
Okay, there we go. I press X to do that.
Ultimate.
Strona, just smoke.
No, I just talked too long and my voice is fried.
Do you need help with this?
You want to gang violence this car?
You're taking your sweet time.
That's going to blow up, bro.
That's going to blow up.
Oh, it didn't hurt him though.
Oh, I get a lot of XP for doing that.
I don't know if we need to farm yet.
If we get too weak, we'll farm.
But at the moment, we are above the
thingy.
Watch out. I know.
Watch out. She's destroying something.
This looks very battle dome-esque
but I don't recall.
I just heard an Ikram.
I think that was an Ikram.
Is this the person we need to find?
Because I don't think he's looking too good.
Are you okay?
Oh, he needs some milk.
Right, I'm sorry. It was too obvious.
That's how you get wrecked.
Don't want to get hit that much,
but this is literally the best I can do.
Okay, that special attack knocks him over.
That's really good to know.
Okay, that bought me time.
That didn't damage me.
That explosion didn't damage me.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, that wasn't that bad.
I thought that was going to be like
insane battle dome-esque type stuff,
but we're safe.
Stronny's Inc's Milky.
Hold on a minute.
Someone described my homemade
yogurt as glippy.
I have not forgiven you for such descriptions.
Is there an enemy over here?
Whoa!
The frickin...
Wait, how much do I have to redo?
Because I was deep in that. Okay, I don't have to redo much.
The plane took me away with it.
Bumped away, man.
Bumped away.
As far as I'm aware, this game has infinite lives.
I probably would never have finished it if I didn't,
because, you know...
Glippy!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That is so cheating.
They had pre-spondent.
Go away.
Go through that, because I can't shoot you.
I'm going to have to be in viz to claim up this.
Oh, my gosh.
Where did... where did they go?
Right, I need to...
Oh, lovely.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, I'm not one-shotting nothing.
Yeah, I'm going to go up.
Just so the screen isn't too red.
There, jeez, Louise.
Oh, I almost didn't make that.
Can I destroy this? Oh, I can.
Take that.
I didn't get any XP for that, so...
That's quite something, honestly.
Oh, my Icaran's here!
I thought my Icaran was going to come and get me.
Okay, it's because it's exploding.
My Icaran is coming to get me.
Um...
Right, okay, let's...
See what we're working...
We're still not...
Whoa, I don't like that.
Oh!
I messed up!
I'm sorry, I even brought attention to my existence.
Please, please, please!
I'm just a Navi!
I'm just a... I'm just a sweet innocent Navi.
I'm just a Navi.
I'm just a sweet innocent Navi.
I'm sorry I tried to pick on you, Mr. Car.
I'm sorry.
My goodness, that Warthog is powerful.
Oh, my goodness!
It was just a little arrow.
My gosh!
And let me up!
Literally, light them up!
I want that thing out blasted out of the sky!
Oh, my goodness.
That was not good.
You're standing up now, so you feel a bit better.
Good.
Oh, a great warrior.
Oh, you were hating on me about 20 minutes ago.
Don't think I... I didn't forget.
You're a little hater.
Okay, goodbye!
Oh, I'm called Dreamwalker now.
I'm no longer a sky people.
I'm a dreamer.
Let me shoot an arrow at this armed vehicle.
Look, I have some good ideas
and I have some bad ideas.
That was a bad idea.
Oh, there's...
What the heck is this?
What did I do with that?
Oh, we got an unlock.
What did we get?
A lookup hack.
Invis for longer.
Oh, we've got a bow and arrow upgrade
and a weapon upgrade.
Oh, look, her bow's changed.
Look, it's a different design now.
What am I supposed to do with these crystals?
Excuse me.
Am I supposed...
Here we go.
I guess I'm to follow the crystals
because it's doing the little lights.
Okay, it's to follow it.
Oh, good job!
I'm freaking...
Okay, we're safe.
My goodness.
I don't know what I need in order to survive
other than an armor upgrade,
but warthogs are so unforgiving.
I was a mecha as I've unlocked now.
See, we're starting to get out of the tutorial
where the game does not forgive.
Like, the game will annihilate you
if you don't, like, level up and stuff.
Oh, my horse is getting really shot out there.
I didn't like that.
I didn't enjoy that.
More enemies?
It's impassable.
Oh, for...
No, Mr. Horsey!
Please do not...
Wait!
Gang violence!
Oh, my horse just perished
but I saw him attack on the leaf.
That's two games where the horse actually helps you.
Okay, we're just going to have to take the risk
on foot, sadly.
Did they attack me if I'm Navi?
I feel like...
Oh, it's so beautiful!
Oh!
Yeah, I really don't want them to attack me.
I'm definitely picking up the...
Uh-huh.
I was hoping they didn't attack.
Oh, I've gone the wrong way.
I'm getting too distracted.
Oh, I don't want to hurt the whale blade.
It just sucks.
Wait a minute! What did she call me?
Raider!
I hardly even know her!
Oh, you didn't like that one?
I guess... Yeah, I guess I repeated it.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, okay, I won't recycle jokes.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I can't see.
Okay, I'm sorry, but you guys are going to have to go.
I really wish they wouldn't attack.
Oh, hello! Are you the person I need?
Man who is not man.
And Navi who is not Navi.
You are a puzzle.
Piece of Ewa's puzzle.
Oh!
Okay, I'm dreamwalking.
Have we got an upgrade?
Uh, hi.
Yes, hi.
Why is it you walk my dream?
I thought no scrawny stream today?
Are you sure about that?
Shibi Reminder!
Okay, for those of you who are listening in
and are part of the Hair M,
Shibi Cottonbomb
is going live
in T-minus.
Four minutes.
She may actually be on the loading screen.
Eh, but yes.
If there's any new YouTube mods lurking,
you are welcome to speak!
But then I remove your speaking privileges
instantly.
Class of 09.
What is Class of 09?
Have you guys played that?
Scrawny Streams never end.
The Return of Herald Endurance Cuttlefish.
As I play the Navi part,
I did it later as a human.
Wrong.
I've literally never done the RDA save.
Right, we will take...
Oh, look how beautiful this is.
Literally glowing in the dark
is just stunning.
Oh, could you imagine it
with graphics that are updated?
Like, ugh.
I have no idea what's in the new avatar game.
Maybe we should play it for the first time together,
but I think it is as beautiful as this.
Right, why am I here?
Oh, to get these crystals.
Okay.
We're just gonna ignore.
Um...
Because if we can just run
in and out of these sections,
if you hang around and kill anything,
yes, you will get faster XP!
Faster XP!
Oh, I don't want my horse to die.
I'm so sorry, Mr. Horsey.
Please don't die.
Oh, no. Oh, no.
Come on. We need to get out of here.
Like, right now, I don't want you to pass away.
I want you to have a happy life
and retire at your old age.
Okay.
And, wait, this horse here
is getting attacked as well?
Oh, it's beating up that mech.
I was gonna actually take it so this one can live
and out, but...
Oh, I don't know if we're gonna make it
if they've got flippin' flamethrowers
and I've got the wrong way because again,
it all turned around.
Oh, please, live, little horsey.
Oh, no! The horsey's not gonna...
Right, that's it. We're clearing this out.
We're clearing this out. Leave my horse alone.
Everything is so strong!
Who, who, who?
You, perish.
Gosh.
I don't have anyone to take out my special one.
Right, I'm healing because we're going...
Oh!
Wait, I actually came out in your avatar.
Yeah, there's a new one.
Didn't check it out yet.
I'm gonna take more samples because I've actually only got three.
Wait, how far away?
It's a wee bit away.
Alright, we are gonna pick up cell samples.
Just...
No! My horse was still going to retirement!
You're so mean!
Ow!
Did that plant just smack me back?
Bang!
The horse has already passed away.
Man, he had a pension fund
and everything.
Imagine working your whole life.
Actually, I read a story about like that.
Where someone worked their whole life
and they got one week of retirement and passed away.
And it was like, I would be so mad.
I would be so mad.
I would explain to Death himself
like, look mate,
I've kind of sweat my whole life.
Direct Brian!
I...
I remember the game couldn't be played by streamers
on the basis of...
Like, it's super easy to get like your IP going.
Um...
But if they fixed it, honestly,
black ops with the boys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Have a little drink, have a sipping tin.
Thank you very much for the tip.
Tarja, I appreciate that.
Yeah.
Shawnee, the horses only live for three days anyway.
What? And Pandora?
I'm gonna hang with Sheep now.
She's live with classable name
which I actually don't know what the good is about.
But...
I imagine. Had rails, it was that basically how to...
Oh, I'm sorry.
But yeah.
We must draw Harmonic from tree.
Shawnee, think with tree.
Help find Harmonic.
Oh no.
Harmonics, help find sleeping well of swords.
I think I know where this is gonna go.
Oh!
Okay, that line delivery
was a bit...
No!
Lungori.
No, refling.
Don't die.
I will say one thing.
For the VAs of this game,
especially for older games in the past,
odds are they had no idea
what the scene actually had
and they were just given a script
and just said
they don't know the depth of the script or what occurred.
It was only until recent stuff
where actors can see live what they're performing.
So...
Follow the sound of vibrations
and find tuning points.
Huh?
Oh!
Okay, if there's three,
it's probably gonna be identical.
Yeah, okay.
Wait, hold on.
Yeah, okay, and then the last one's gonna be like right here.
Because of the way triangles work.
Yeah, I love triangles.
What's your...
Yeah, you know what, favorite shape?
I'ma give it in our rectangle.
Triangle or rectangle for favorite shape.
Oh, it's singing to me. Hold on.
I feel like something mystical is about to happen.
I'm actually getting a bit scared.
Hydration check.
Oh, no.
So it was the same as the Sonic Adventure show.
It's a wooden delivery, get it?
Because of the trees?
It was a wooden delivery.
Oh, shucks.
I came up with that myself.
Came up with that comment myself.
I'm so wetty as a streamer, aren't I?
I'm just gonna start stealing your guys's
like witty comments.
And then doing that over.
Oh, I have a new armor.
New armor.
Oh my god, girl game, girl game.
Oh, yeah, like the protection.
What is vitality?
What does that mean?
More health?
They have more health overall because of the armor?
Yeah, well, you can see where they added more armor on to me.
You have solved content creation.
Okay, well, what am I?
Looks like...
Oh, that's proper harmonized.
Yeah, good luck hitting them.
Nope, that's long time.
Armor barely covers anything.
And honestly, like,
they are using...
Right, we're going to home tree.
Wait, we're going back to home tree?
Oh, what?
I'm about to report to them that, oh, by the way,
Longody's dead.
I'm going to cry from that joke literally.
What, cry of pain?
Or just like, just like how ridiculous it was?
Okay, we are going to be polite
to Ewa and respect the home tree
by not doing backflips all the way up
the trunk of the tree.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's tree balls.
We love tree balls.
This is getting very bright in here.
I'm not gonna lie.
Do I need to recalibrate? Hold on.
Professional streamer, I think I need to recalibrate my muscles.
Okay, there we go.
Recalibrating.
Oh, we did actually report Longody's passing.
Okay.
Not the thumbs up!
Not the thumbs up.
So human of you, please don't do that again.
Thumbs up.
Can I just hum a few bars?
A little tap on the shoulder.
Sing!
What am I saying?
Am I actually just like...
Is this like a minigame or any like...
What on earth is this freaky stuff going on here?
Uh...
I don't even remember that at all.
Thumbs up!
Let's just try to come through.
Okay.
Alright.
So this is campaign mode getting explained to us.
I totally know the plot inside out from this game.
Yeah.
Assassin's Creed, I know the plot of this.
All I know is that we're doing good for the planet.
No, please, even if not directed at me, they hurt anyway.
What if the trees wanted to see a sick backflip?
I don't know.
Mission complete.
Oh, I'm not to jump around.
Jump up.
Can I put my weapons away?
I feel like having weapons out in this location isn't very pleasant.
No, put the RDA gun on me.
Why is this so bright?
I don't ever... Oh my god!
I don't ever recall that issue.
Oh, hello again.
I would like to talk to you for my next mission.
Doroknaring.
Yeah, he's probably a bit mad at me for, you know,
spending five years in cryo.
Yeah.
Never on the enemy side.
But we're the goodies, so they're the enemies.
We're healing nature.
Mother nature always reclaims all.
Mother, mother, mother, mother nature.
This looks like a darker map.
Beautiful.
Toph ASMR will play?
I can't really do later voices like Toph.
Oh, Katana.
Look, there's the castle.
That's what I would say if I could see
something.
If I wasn't blind.
I can't really hear a voice at all.
Is it a castle?
There's something in the sand.
Or the library? There's the library.
Katana.
Oh, sorry. It's not Katana.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
It's upside down.
Isn't it?
Katana? Close enough. I know. I know.
Katana wins.
Good luck, Tanjala.
Oh, who's this? Hello. How do you do?
Oh, I need a pause.
Pause on the shards. Pause champ on the shards.
A little cheeky hydration check.
There's the library.
That's what it would sound like
if one of us would bother you.
Okay, I'm going to say something controversial.
You know when maps are straight ahead like this?
Yeah?
I like that.
I appreciate when games don't make you go back and forth
and you just keep going forward.
When a game makes you turn around
to go do something on the map
that you were previously at that area...
However,
when a game makes it nice and linear...
I'm not going to lie, I almost fell off there.
Oh, and I can't actually see where I'm supposed to go.
Thanks to the sleeve.
Oh, there we go.
Backtrack hate.
Yeah, backtracking a bit.
Okay.
Let's see how it goes.
Okay, so if you take the high ground...
Wait, look! That's why they attack me.
They've got backpacks on the wolves
and that's why they attack me.
I'm just thinking.
The RDA put like main control devices
on the wolves
and now they want to attack me even though I'm Navi.
I'm Navi and I'm navigating.
What the heck am I doing here?
Am I destroying stuff?
Don't have to ask me twice!
Challenge complete.
I'm going to do it from up here.
Oh, I see.
So I'm releasing the native
Navi
and destroying the...
Jesus.
Why?
We're literally so low level
we're not even one-shotting.
Can I break you?
Oh, I can.
I like how he just don't.
Oh, he like dives over.
I mean, honestly, if an arrow struck me
I'd probably...
Oh, we did it!
Like, Ori and the Blame Force.
I tru...
Wait, wait, wait.
What am I supposed to do with that?
Destroy it?
I'm just going to pump...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Let me pump all the ammo into it.
Where's my gun?
I can't...
Your hate, you're teasing me.
I'm not even hitting you.
Bro.
You're literally right under the tree.
I'm going to have to go...
No, stop shooting me.
I need to destroy this.
Hello?
Oh, wait, oh, wait.
Oh.
No?
Game?
Do I need...
To hit the other side of it, I guess?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, my God.
Jeez, Louise.
They are killing us here.
That was very strange.
But we did it. That's the main thing.
Uh, maybe we should not.
Are you trying to shoot that guy?
And you're missing, like, horribly? Oh, you are.
Oh, and I'm missing horribly too. You know that both of us are as bad as each other
He healed as I bruh come on
Hello, would you like to talk to me? Oh
Oh for sure
Does he know I'm coming no that check and works if the map is good. Yes, I would argue yeah, I
Did try and play Ori in the blind forest
But I was just to pay to pay go. It's definitely not a stream game for me, but one of the other girls
Likely would play it. I feel like it's a and I definitely chill stream chill stream. Yeah
This is actually a really beautiful map because you get to run along the little tree roots
Which I really like yay nature nature wins again
Right I can see and we're maybe fighting here or are we
Are we just running through this oh, wow, we actually did pretty decent damage
Yeah, wow, I'll take that
I think
They keep I can only I'm okay hold on I
It doesn't seem like an objective area because of that reason. I'm just gonna do this
I know I shouldn't I know I should probably like level up a bit
But I am very happy just to keep walking on the tree trunks
You want a non chill stream place a list? I've seen a lot of streamers place a list like it's interesting to see what like
Oh, I'm in trouble. Oh, I'm in trouble. Oh, I'm in trouble. Oh
My god, I did not remember being in so much trouble playing this game
What's the way? I think it's maybe I used to farm areas to level up and I was just so OP
Because I think this map. We're actually supposed to be unlocking a green
Armor right now
But I ain't doing it
I'm just doing some back foot literally backflip dodge and bullets right we're getting ready to attack these guys
But I need to actually activate the quest by talking to this guy before we attack and release more of Pandora's
me
How can I help?
You would not like my answer
Listen like it or not. You've got my help on this one
string
The top two loader sky machines with weapons
Was it I think for anyone who did actually watch the first avatar movie
I think scound means like idiot or something like that like
You have to go like scum or else. You're not saying it, right?
Yeah, I feel like I replayed and leveled up a lot more as a child and right now
We're just like speedrunning through this although when you do complete a mission you do get like a nice chunk of XP so
Oh
Speaking of leveling up. I have a six-minute timer at the top of the screen
That looks like a protection spell that I am putting on I didn't realize I unlocked some sort of protection thing
I definitely want to put whatever that is greatly reduces. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, we'll definitely be utilizing that right woman to do
Right, let's test this out. Oh
I'm not to destroy the ship jump up here
Hello, oh
Wait, I can just yeah, is this what I'm supposed to destroy. Oh
Yeah, okay is yeah, take that you like that. Yeah, you like a big adult
Oh, I'm gonna get a blurt raid cuz it's face a minute. I'm getting I'm getting shaky. I'm getting scared
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. Like honestly smooth sailing. Okay, the NPCs aren't really locking on to me too well because of the distance
But we're making it. We're making it
They're getting a bit closer. So I might have to start shooting them a wee bit
Well, that was a good shot there one more and then that's three of four
You're telling me that quad aero thing can stay up with three. I don't believe it
One more two more. I'm not hitting that. Oh, it's not registering
It's gonna spam it down. Am I supposed to
Of course the thing I want is like not facing me
Okay, they were
I
Human iron
Literally that the steel a crann is no match for me. I'm gonna look this stuff. I've got three revives. Oh
My gosh, oh
The poor babies they're not even attacking us
Out you come baby. Wait, so okay looks like regular ones don't attack me anymore. Hello
Yes, they were cruel to him if we can heal his wounds, you will fight
I think we're gonna raid him every palulu. Whatever I've ever meant was to eat me alive
He is still our brother. We will heal him with a was medicine. Oh, that's so cute. We're helping the little forest prayers
Bring them to me
What do you need? I'm sorry medication for the guy
I'll just basic flowers. That's fine. I can get that. That's that's the problem. Hold on. Hold that thought little guy
I'm coming back
And then I think we get to ride him into battle like a horse, but it's not a horse
I think it's called a fanator if I remember correctly. Oh
My goodness. I remember that time I said in this map, you don't have to backtrack
Honestly, it's not that bad though because it's to help an animal and you know, we
Shadow wizard money gang. We love healing nature from these parts
I'm going in
Oh, I mean sprayed and prayed but they can't get me I'm too good
Gather plants from the banshee's nest. Oh, that's what
Suppose we'd be comfortable
Pandora is Ohio, but more natural
You're not allowed to speak for the next 20 seconds, do you understand me
Don't say that again
I'm so excited for your ace mushroom. I just want new earbuds for oh, you're making a good. I hope it is not a disappointment
I
Most likely will not do ear licking. I'm just gonna say that now before anyone gets thingy
I have no idea what an earth is going on with YouTube and ear licking at the moment
Something there's either a policy update being pushed or something
But for some reason anime earlicks bad
in real life human person
earlicks fine, so I
Don't want you be disappointed. I have put a lot of thought and effort into it
So hopefully the smart is good. I don't know how long I'm gonna stream for and the problem is I get really distracted when like I
Like I constantly read your guys's stuff because you guys make me laugh all the time
So I'm not really sure how official and ASMR. It's gonna be so do apologize
It's probably I'll probably try hard for like 15 minutes, and then it's just gonna
Oh, that's so cool
rides a sacred beast
Has a will go mad. No
Whiskers honestly though we whiskers
It's impossible because YouTube can't tell the difference I that's my theory at the moment is that anime is getting
Because YouTube are saying it's implied else
Whereas we all know like what actual ear licking sounds like because it's literally a 3d microphone
So it's really putting a bit of a hindrance on my plans
My
Yard is this not the coolest ride you've ever seen. Oh my god. It's so cool. Oh, he leaves
Can you go faster? Oh?
He attacks. Oh
That's okay. Can you jump? Oh, no, that's not jump. Oh
Wait, wait, did I move as it moves? Oh, can you jump?
Oh
He's so slick looking like genuinely so slick
Not a hero. No, how do you keep warm?
Like almost laughing with the highlight you'll be fine
Come on buddy. Come on whiskers. Let's get them
Wait
Oh, I'm just going back to talk
It's just like it literally looks like he's been dropped in tower the first thing but it's just heavy is a little hairless thing
I don't like you
Okay
Why do not speak like you understand why is she so informal when talking to this guy
You have to pick your battles be this guy speaking a second language
But at least try and speak clear English, you know, so it's easier for him Danny go back before it's okay
You're ready whiskers. Oh, I did not mean to do that, but I was absolutely horrifying
Right, come on whiskers. Let's get them
Hopefully you have a lot of help with yours because I'm not doing any combat
Whiskers
Can you go across this stuff? Oh
You can oh, you're actually such a smart kitty. Honestly, you're smart
Okay, I auto jump if it's quite others
To please don't attack quest mark. I don't think they attack me anymore
Speaking of contact the enemy's got a lot of enemies
Okay, we're all good whiskers made it into a happy retire. There's another whiz. How many whiskers are there?
bingus some
What is going on in the background
Cutscene moment
I can't see moment. Hello cut scene moment. Hello. I think I'm stuck in it
Just absolutely chaos in the background by the way
In
Game oh, and we got a level up as well, right we need to help out that
Right, hold on leave with
Stop it
Right, I'm just gonna do melee for the fix
I
What no health why no health?
I'm doing my spell. Am I supposed to be on whiskers. I think I'm supposed to be on whiskers
Tear them up whiskers tear them up
That's right. Who's a good kitty. You're gonna get some treaties after this
Mr.. Whiskers going crazy in the background
Just a reminder that she can't bomb is a lie if you'd care to watch class of
Oh
No, my kitty's losing health. I can't heal on
Oh, baby, I don't want you to perish. I want you to have happy retirement
And
Oh, there's no way kitty's gonna deal with these max without being perished
Unless I put them away right you stay there
Oh my goodness and I don't have my protection spell yet
Um
I don't have protection spell I'm much late. Oh
Kitty I might need you back kitty. I might need you back
Kitty, where are you kitty? You're saving me kitty
Yes, knock them over. Yes. Yes. Oh, you're so smart. You're so smart. You're so smart
Oh, you're such a good smarty party
Yeah, I do need to heal in a moment
But I think we're doing all right. What's going on here?
You you've glitched out and you're not even fighting alongside me. So that's fine
All the kitty. Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, heal heal heal heal heal
Oh, I've casted protection. I've casted protection
I did crash protection, but I was too late because I healed first I should have
Okay, okay, we can do that. This is super easy to get them
Where are it? Where's all the ones?
Where are they?
Two more
Oh, there you are
Okay, we're done. Oh, there's three more. Are you telling me stickers?
Uh, hopefully the cat didn't die then
Okay, actually I'm gonna oh wait, no
Hmm
I cast skill issue
Yes, we can do that one more shard and then we do a song a little song and dance
She knows
Oh, that is really rough
That was a rough landing with the animation on the uh navi there. I have to admit
Bending with the uh
Right, let's unlock the home tree. No, not home tree tree of vision, which lets us teleport around the map
Yeah, it was crunchy. That was crunchy. That was 2009 showing
I never know how long these like bigger games take to develop. I still think it's like three years development two years development
This smallest development game time crunch I ever heard was followed new vegas. That was like big like that
I think they said it was 11 months development. Um, which was crazy all things considered
Uh
I think we just walk the rest of the writer come in kendrick. Tell me some good news
Raider hardly even nor great anything else to brighten my day. Yeah, okay, so I'll start making my job. I'm sorry
It's a ticking time bomb. We can't let falcon anywhere near the well
She's can't keep getting away with it
Hey, am I supposed to find
My born you are you feel health kitty? Oh, you're not even readable actually. I'm not supposed to read them anymore
Yeah, I know. I know right. I wouldn't do anymore
Go give it some good
A 15 year old game. Look look
They didn't actually come up with something pretty decent games like back then
Are you squidding me right now? Oh, brian last one for today. I got to go night night
Good night. Uh, thank you for the tip, but jenga good night, and I'll see you in the morning. Hey, how long
We're already two hours in so statistically we have like four. Oh, no, no one's sleeping in four hours
I've taken
Abomination must die. Do you wish to help us or not? Yes, I'll help you my goodness
Honestly, yeah, you actually do deserve a bit sass. Uh, right. We're okay. Yeah, just go ahead
Whoa, what am I supposed what animal am I supposed to eliminate?
Oh actual cutscene
Yeah, we do not get actual cutscenes like this often
Oh
Sorry, I'm petting my hair right now that the my my hair is up in a bun
I've done it all that sounded rather odd
Two and a half
You get one more of those jokes for all your jokes will come on funny. I don't have any more sound effects to do it with
I don't have any more sound effects
That's them all so I can't make the joke again. I've only got crickets now
Oh
I really don't like hurting these guys, but if they're baddies, there's nothing I can really be
I give you I send you back to awa
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, there's a lot more of you in this plane this pen than I thought jeez
What am I supposed to destroy in here?
that
Uh, I hope this works
Uh, I cast protection I cast protect I read
I'm stuck in the corner. I cast protection
Okay, thank god this game is so buggy. Oh, I didn't mean to do that. I didn't mean to heal I wasted that heal
Oh, this is making me nervous. Haha. You can't come on the rock. You can't come on the rock
Most games for older games elevation really bugs out the ai's that they have
So don't be afraid to use elevation to your advantage because then you get moments like this
Where you can just have a good time because they can't get on the elevation. Okay
For you, glad that's over because that is really not an easy enemy to defeat in the rail
My gasman buck rug. Shona, you seem to have upgraded
Upgrades available top left. Wait actually
No, I don't I don't unless it's that greatly improved damage for a short amount of time
Can I yeah like for some reason if you don't like tab over these it will constantly tell you you have like weapon upgrades and stuff
What else have I got?
Yeah, so like things get more like stronger as we progress
I could do a club honestly. Let's see the club. What does it look like?
Oh, that's a meaty swing
Oh, that's a load up though to get that that's quite a load up
Oh, yeah that uh, it doesn't okay. No, this is for these guys. It's the double
It's the double for me that you're wield
Oh, why would you guys even be in a broken facility? Be honest right now
Oh, why how are you even getting me through a fence?
Oh
Well, I need to aim you need to reload so which one of us is going to go down first
The yeah the club's too slow
All right, I'm just gonna go for it
Okay. Yeah one shot with the things I'll take that. Is there anyone else here? I hear him
I hear him. I can't see him. Oh, he's so tiny
Oh, you're so tiny. I can't even see it
Ha ha ha you're welcome
Gank up on gank up on that's what I get for making a joke
Spank spank spank
Hello, scrawny there was no notification for your shuman discord
Discord hates me. I can't believe it. I'm not just I'm not discord's little kitten or whatever. I said anything that thing
Uh, she be is live right now with class of 09 if that game is more of an interest to you because I'm literally playing the most like
Unknown game ever
I don't know if this game out on
PlayStation
In that as well. I don't remember it being. Oh, there's a Thanator in here
Where is it?
Oh, I hear it. Where is it? Oh, it's literally right there
Uh, we'll just spray it down
Oh, I'm already out of ammo
I thought I was gonna be like
Oh, okay. Now he's not coded to go any further. I was gonna say I'm like
I didn't I think it was coded to go any further. This is another thing about older games
You can like just absolutely smurf them because
There's only so much game memory and game storage that they can allocate for areas
Which means coding wise they will just stop enemies from doing stuff like that. I just I just love it
I appreciate it so much like it just makes everything nice and easy peasy lemon squeezy
What you got to complain about? Huh? What you got to complain about?
I know the game did come out on PlayStation 3. Okay. Okay. So it wasn't I didn't think it was an xbox exclusive
I but I don't think ever got released on steam. Whoa
Hi
Hydration check, I mean
I'm gaming I'm not doing this for me. There's a lot more to cheese. I'm cheese and it's not smurfing it cheese
You think I enjoy this
How much do I need to play for that RDA? I've never done it. I've genuinely never done it. I don't think
So you don't need to pay anything at all. I've got to an RDA
I assume the RDA is just like congrats. You've destroyed the planet. Thanks. And then the game then the credits just roll
That's how I imagine the RDA side ends
The are you afraid of are you afraid of yourself for beating a helpless NPC? Hold on. I'm getting rolled
Oh my armor. I've just noticed that my armor. Oh my god girl moment. I'm a good fashion show fashion
I've got a passion. Whoa. Look at that protection. What are you squidding me right now?
Today I learned that if you click on the hashtag smuttlefish hashtag in the stream description
One of the first videos shown is the puffer fish gagging on a carrot video
Actually, thank you for the tip. Sorry y'all or sorry y'all
Uh, oh that poor that poor little guy
But yeah fashion show momento so human
Basic armor a little bit of an upgrade and then we've got like location based armor. I knew it
So hopefully we can take a wall open now
Because uh, are we faster as well?
Oh
Who's here? Oh, why are you here? This is navi
Um destroying pandora just trying to aim for these guys. Let me put my glycs on
Can I see none?
Wow
I am invisible you shouldn't be shitting me anymore. I'm literally invisible
I'm not gonna heal naturally or don't need to pop her heal. I need to pop
Take this
Oh, I see the tnt thing. I'm going to grab the crystal before it gets me outside. I'm going to craft. I just
Do get me out here get me out here get me out here. Oh
Oh, oh that sprint is so good. Oh my I just came out of nowhere. He blinked and he was gone
Oh, let me pick up more samples
Oh, get me out here. There's too much
If they start having like knockback, that's when it gets dangerous like being in the middle of the enemies
So do forgive me if I literally just blow past all these sections
Oh
I can do that. That's fine
That's fine
Okay, okay, we're we're getting oh
So
Ah see when they do that they stall you that's when you get
Literally tnt in the sky
Okay, we made it. We made it
Let me just unlock this little tree of
You can't see me. No
Now able rider knee win the vitality and protection boost. Yeah
Did you find out why they're pulling out?
The daughter gather in force mental birds field of sky. You don't want to pull her there any humans
A storm is coming the other song. We must return to home. Okay. We've got our second song
So does that mean we need to do a third song and then we're
Who am I to talk to the banshee?
I
It's on to happen
It says yellow on the map. Am I supposed to read the ikran?
No
I'm sorry. I wasn't paying attention. The willow tree knee win fast. We have the advantage
The willow tree
I'm about to use this to teleport to here
To get to home tree
What
Wait, was there a thing back? No, not conquest. No, not conquest. No, no, no, no
We don't want to do conquest. You must do at the end of the game. No, no, no, no
I already know how to play. Thank you. No
Conquest
Not no was there something I was supposed to pick up back there. I feel like
Child support scary
Is there a crystal? Oh dumb
Dumb dumb dumb dumb gee
I wonder if it's supposed to go here on this conveniently playful island thing. Okay. I was good. I knew him
Now what was the third one here?
Yeah, okay. Okay. Don't make it too. Don't make it too obvious video game devs. Don't even need yellow paint in this game
Hmm
Okay, we have the song my apologies does rather confuse there
A human spirit lives within you
If you achieve I'm becoming na vi na vi na vi na vi
You bring hope coming na vi
Give our call. We bring this song before taii the battle moves swiftly
I fear humans are a step ahead of us. We must return song to home
Mercy's just de-embed me
Strongly my alt twitter's growing really fast. You are right. I'm scared
But under the tweet I'm getting nervous should I post this?
Yeah, you can post what you want
Mary I'm going to reply mercy. You can
You can
Post what you like my darling whatever whatever makes you happy
Yeah, I have replied to mercy
For a yandere she sure does uh love being like unironical
This is going to sound really weird when I say this out loud. She sure does love being a good girl and getting permission for everything
for a yandere
Like literally all of the girls are so fantastic
Yeah, we're we're slowly getting past the stage of do I need do I need permission to do this?
Do I need um because the answer is always no you do not need my permission. You are in control
So I was the same
The best kind of yandere
You know
Jesus
Yeah, damn need some sunglasses to get up this tree. Um
Um
But yes, the girls are definitely easing into the concept that because
I assume, you know, they've consumed enough kind of like
Oh most future brave agencies like have this long list of rules that you have to abide by and it's like my rules are like literally
You know be be cool with lollipop stuff and um
Uh, no no male collabs
And you know that's a
It gets really simple. You do everything yourself. I'm not going to tell you what to do. I'm not going to dictate your content
So brian
Yes, you can post whatever you want my dear mercy leaks classified military documents war thunder style
I know about that if you didn't know
military documents keep getting leaked in a video game because people are like
They're like so like wanting everything to be correct, which is hilarious. Thank you for this hip tharya
um
But that's like true
real and true
Because what what i'm sure one of them was like they were arguing over a helicopter detailed design
Either in the cockpit or something to do with a helicopter
And then someone was like so tismo. They were like no, you're wrong and here's why and then they just like flop down these like
Documents that shouldn't be publicly accessible
Um, and it's happened multiple that law
Okay, we're singing a second song i'm going to assume by the third song we will progress to the next story for element because
good
Let me try a ramung nan will soon be found
Okay, that's a little weird
able rider
Daily so many stuff
challenger tank
Manlet armor
I break codes in a Eurocopter shells, etc
It's happened 15 to 17 times
Bro bro was like slams on desk. See I told you so
This gen is blessed truly
Like it wasn't even one country leaking the info it was all of them together just so that the the
Equipment and tanks and all that were accurate in game the next song. There's literally a joke zero days since last military league
She sees what you may become. They don't like to be wrong exactly
I'm just someone who gave me a song back home. We call that a deejay. She just stroked his chest
Then you worry mate. I just collect the songs beyond the cup that is already full
Look beyond the cup that's already full
Oji san says as he drinks Emmys
Uh, they are a ramu
A certain dominance honestly actually elites really five and seven but other times they were export
Uh, restricted but it could be found online
I'm really proud to belong to the war thunder community for their dastardly arcs
The forest birds are warriors flee before the humans. These are drinking what? Hmm
The RDA must be gunning at me. I see actually all of them. You know what well matter all of them
We can't escape the the p-corp jokes. Now is the time to counter their attack or must be risked in times of need
Just all of them are at it honestly
I mean if you think about it as there is milk heels
So what would the other liquids do?
I don't know
I don't know. We didn't lure that that wasn't concepted
but
Up to you what you think the other ones do uh, what is this area? I seem to have forgotten this map. I actually don't remember it
The warriors here know the land
Okay, please be the last song because no more song missions, please
See if they can find big b. We could use this big b. All right. Just marry big b this much at this point
I feel love him so much
He enjoys crushing skulls of many totu
Totu for humans
When you have all I want to have squid ink spaghetti. Is that because of me? Be honest time to find out. Hey
Stroney, you didn't have she be you didn't hear she be the discussion about
No, actually this is one thing that I'm actually genuinely a bit sad about
Because I stream so much
I don't have time to watch everyone's streams and it ups it like it genuinely upsets me
like
um
I raided into mercy yesterday and she was playing oh mario
Or whatever the name of the game is. Oh, I've never seen it or played it before
And um, she was like yapping quite adorably
But I just feel bad that like I don't have time like
Just everything like when I popped into ac stream playing that puzzle game. Obviously she be live right now
I have terrible news, but I don't have she be
In my ear right now that you guys can't hear whilst I game and stream and talk at the same time
It's just not possible for me. I did not remember this map at all. I'm like, um
Let's go for it. Let's see what this maps all about then
What is this is this a run through type of thing?
Uh, no, this is a search
What is going on? Whoa, this is pretty
What is going on I need to learn to do that protection spell more wait
Why did the area just moved wait, so am I supposed to kill who's in the area?
Let's go
Let's see. Yeah, it's kind of shame that all your streams are overlapping
I will say one thing I did ask the girls to push on the first week to stream as much as possible
However, um, some of them are going to settle into streaming. Um,
I literally said to them do not even dare stream every single day
After this like you will be taking breaks
That like I was I've lit and they can all vouch that I told them straight to their
Faces don't you dare stream every single day? The only reason I can do it is because I don't experience
Burnout the only reason I would not stream is if I am on desk store. I'm not even kidding. Um
Oh, that horse is beating me up. They're jumping me. Wait use the ultimate use the heal heal heal. My goodness
You're so so what am I supposed to do here?
Stop
I'm gonna need to take these I'm getting hurt by something. Um
What I might get hurt by
I'm no idea
Right. Wait. Why am I just to run around these sectors or just
Stop it. Oh, there's more of them here. I need to kill
Are you forcing them to take breaks?
I'm not going to tell them not to stream because that's not my place to do that
But I will be worried if as time goes on like
I've noticed one of them are like non-stop streaming
But I will always like take their like if they say they're fine, I'm not going to question it
I'm not I'm absolutely not going to question it if they want to stream they can stream
But I would be a bit worried like hopefully, you're not like overdone
Because when I do it, it's fine. But when others do it, hold on a minute. I'm getting worried. I'm
I'm turning in a mother mode. Like, are you okay? Uh, is there something I could help you with?
Is there like a reason behind the scenes why you want to stream everything?
You know, I just want to make sure you're okay, baby. Okay
You're my wing. You're my wing
Oh my goodness
Uh, you literally just stopped me from doing that ultimate
Okay, objective quickly
Take care of your daughters. Yes
Uh, unironically, I've been getting nightmares about my daughters. Um, I had a nightmare
That I didn't
redirect into one of them and then they wanted to leave real or because of that
And I literally put in the message. I was like, am I real mommy now?
Without her many because I'm like, I'm literally having nightmares like of like, oh no, something's not going right
Or like I've done something wrong
Are we babies?
Here we go
Well, like, uh, I
I managed to get streaming
No streaming detachment anxiety
That's not the word is it? What way am I supposed to go this way? Um
Separation anxiety from the reefing
Um, that happened
And I don't know if I'm gonna develop it again for a little bit
Uh, plausible
But it's happened with the girls where when I go to sleep I get so nervous
For them and like I'm worried like something might happen to them and I'm not there to like help them through it or something
Um, help me return to but yeah yesterday was weird going after the two hour mark
There was so much time in the day, but the good news is I got a lot behind the scenes work done
Wait
Uh, I may or may not blast through that dialogue and I don't know a match is for her
Mr. Horsey that was me twat
Wait, what? Oh fucking spank you today. What are you playing at?
Oh
Protection
Where's the other guy? I literally just saw him or did I just get them both in the goal?
I assume I'm gonna score in her too. Yeah, okay. This is like an escort mission if I've ever seen one
Does she attack or does she not attack?
No, she just stands there and lets me do everything. All right, Hannah see have it and lazy bum
Lazy bum lazy bum. That's right. I'm calling you a lazy bum. What you gonna do better? Oh, I love that one hit like fly by
I swear and those it wasn't thing in the movies. No, it definitely is not. Is she getting attacked? No, she's fine
She is getting attacked
Uh, right we can progress to the next person
I'm very caring mama honestly
She's got worries. I'm like
I remember my mom telling me when she had me
She used to be a deep sleeper, but when I was born she became a late sleeper
And I'm like I I feel that because I've not had like a really good night sleep since debut
Oh before debut. I didn't even have a good sleep either
And the yap is the best part also in general a really cute thing for
now is that
They are yapping a lot, but not in a bad way. No, I love when the girls yap honestly
It's like so nice to listen to like their stories and
And the situations have been in they've been in like quite humorous situations. Um
And it's just like fun to hear different
People talk from like different walks of life. Like I know that sounds so freaking weird to say
but like
um
It's just fascinating and it just I just I just I just made it fascinating
I feel like you can also learn a lot from people's stories as well
Even if it's a humorous story, normally there's some sort of like thing
Or element where they can look back and giggle and be like, oh, I wouldn't have done that now
But like oh, isn't it funny at the time and like, you know, just a little good things
I should maybe do a reef link story time where we share stories
And it'll be like sure like I would be have to be like a google submission thing
And it's like oh share your
um
Share like a memory that makes you embarrassed and like I'll read them out and then I'll share you an embarrassing story of mine
Like that kind of stuff I would absolutely love to do
I feel like those kind of interactive streams are quite funny and we can all like kind of have a week giggle at each other
Also, you guys must remind me to brush my teeth at the end of the stream
I keep forgetting to brush my teeth
for that guy and
Um
We need to do it together for 21 days so we can establish
our beautiful training
Yes
Hello rocks village behind village the shards are behind honestly me speaking french
rocks
Go I did I forgot what behind is dead air
The village no
Dead air will and then rock is probably just like l rock
Rock
Al
I think there's not a will stand below
Or is this a fate is this a fate or it's a fate it's on peer protection
I'm literally a warlock peer protection
Oh, we don't like fire fire bad
Oh get rekt
Get rekt
Get rekt. I'm getting rekt. I'm getting rekt by the
I leveled up though, but I'm currently getting absolutely you can literally see the ammo shot
That is coming from me from that freaking thing. Oh unlock new armor. Whoa
I'm naked
Is that less protection? Oh, no, it's the exact same
Well, if it's the same as the green one, yeah, we'll just use it. Um, oh my god, I'm a
Bro
You're
Reload or something. Jeez get me out of here. I'm just gonna run ahead. Oh having invis as well right. We'll do invis
Try to speak because I saw something
Literally I was green a minute ago with my armor and then it all disappeared and I'm like, excuse me
Where's my uh protection via armor?
Like you're telling me the navi still haven't figured out that uh, maybe we should
Literally have bullets or getting thrown and you're telling me the navi haven't figured out that we should probably
There is much they say you can do uh, I can do is they're a shard nearby. I'm going to drink a water
You should think about how you think
You must help we were attacked by humans. Many have died
You are not too late go find Alona when he can help and Mercy says
Uh, I'm sorry. I've accidentally stumbled into the algorithm on twitter and I'm like congrats because I don't know how that heck
It works either. Uh, and a lot has been you to find all low new in in the village of to the east
The red feathers look pretty bad
Where are we going? Oh a bit of a bit of a walk. Oh, no, no not a bit of a walk
Because there's a horsey horsey
easy there
Would you let me read you and say easy there like this dire horse from the hit video game james karmann's avatar released in
How many resurrections do I have I've actually not been collecting much samples does that attack me or you friend
Oh
Well, that got answered real quick, didn't it?
Whoa
Bit too much action on these roads for me
Bit too much my only I would say my only complaint about this game
Is that you can never freely explore the land like things constantly keep respawning which I'm not a fan of
I quite like the idea of like clearing out an area and then it's like faith
Every time you like want to come back. We're gonna unlock the tree of vision
This game
Well, this game did become PlayStation Platinum. Um
Uh, apparently there's a multiplayer mode in this game. I don't ever recall playing that as a child
So surrounding when is the history stream of yapping about the Irish potato family?
I don't know
I was going to do a teacher's day where we have like 40 minute
Or well, maybe 30 minute classes
So we do like English study and then we do like a french class and then we'll do like a pee class
And we're like literally I'll just instruct you on what we're supposed to do and you'll just hear me jump up and down in my room
um
Um other we'll do mass as well. I'll teach board mass is how we do it in
The UK or maybe maybe just Scotland. I don't know. Uh, board mass is brackets of division
multiplication addition subtraction is different what the heck am I supposed to do? I wasn't paying attention
I think I'm supposed to collect things in this area. Yes. I am. I am slight things in this area
If that's the case in viz right now
Right, we'll just do the outskirts of the area because I think that kind of highlights what the dealie was
Where the heck
Uh, right there's one
I can hear lots of enemies, but I'm trying not to engage in any of them
I am gonna get him to not attack me by doing this. Nope. That was not
That wasn't it. Oopsies literally just aggro time on me for no reason. Oh, there is
We need one more pink tentacle
Oh
Oh, there is there is right. We're safe safe safe safe
To ease
We're gonna try and avoid all the fights because you really do
Once you do like if you engage in all the fights you really do get like tangled up in like all this time
Strongly teaching man, and it's not gonna go well
But like we would do all the most basic covers like we do biology we'll do physics we'll do chemistry
And like a full day and the way I was going to do it is we're not allowed to progress until you guys actually give me the
Correct answer
So depending on how fast you do it, we'll get through the school day like really fast
But like I'll put a little teak. I don't know if I can get looking teachers. I don't know
Maybe put like a graduation cap
Oh, wait, hold on. I just realized I'm not gonna light on I think that's why my mouth track is being all funny. Hold on
Hold on professional streamer moment. Oh
Oh
There we go
Right, I'm gonna recalibrate just because I keep seeing my mouth is kind of like wiggling away
I assure you I'm not about to cry, you know when someone's about to cry and their mouth starts wiggling
That's what I do anyway
But we will recalibrate a little cheeky recalibration
Nope, and uh, my blanket is currently trapped around the microphone. That's not fair
Mr. Blanket, please please work with me here
Oh
Your math phobia, I hope you don't have a math phobia numbers. Oh
So I was calibrating so I had to go into that silent. It's like, oh you scared the numbers. Oh multiplication. Oh
Yeah, that terrify you that stuff made out of nightmares for you. Yeah
Where's these horses? Let's go
You could give a history lesson on the battle of bannock born. I absolutely will we'll do we'll have a scottish lessons stream
Segment for it because if we're going to study english, literally
Then I'm gonna stay off the horse for this. I think I'm just picking these people up horse. You're in my way. Thank you
Reunite the hunters
That's all I really had to do
Well, we'll just
I'll just let them fight in the background whilst i'm in a cut scene. Don't worry guys. You're doing fine. Keep it up. No, you're fine
You're fine. You're doing fine
What's your favorite protest?
What does that mean? What's her protest?
I don't know what a protest is
Oh my god a veiler group calibration with the math because apparently all of you struggle with math
literally
I like playing incremental games, but you know, I don't actually like doing the thinking part when it comes to numbers
So, yeah
Yes, this is correct. This is the way to victory to victory to victory. This is the way to victory and this is the way we'll go
Hmm
I'm actually so fast on this
Is this faster than the Thanator? It actually might be, you know, oh, there's so many samples around here
I'm just gonna check. Oh, I'm actually max on revives. I've got five revives
Oh, we're getting ready to attack. I can see you. You have done much for my clan. We stand beside you
Even Shibi was struggling with the puzzle. Oh puzzle games are
Hmm
I asked Emmy and AC see if they would maybe collab on
We were here that puzzle game
And they had to swap the game
They gave it a little short like just as a five 15 minute practice and they were like we're not playing that and I was that's fine
That's fine. You don't have to play a spine. He's fine. I wanted to see if I could do it with a wiefling
But then I would have to like if I could do it
Oh
Yeah, they wonder the rock killed me. It's sort of a fucking entire boulder on my skull. Are you joking?
How is that supposed to know that was about to happen?
That's outrageous. Oh map design change. What's in here?
Enemies got a lot of oh
Can can you guys really not see?
Oh
Right, okay, I give up I give up that's really annoying
What's going on here?
I've done protection. I've got knocked back
I hate when they knock you back because that's when you can just absolutely eat
All of the damage that they're laying out
Which is not good
Yeah, like I'm literally getting so injured
Oh
This your spawn point is it behind here?
You suck
Get rid of that spawn point get that spawn point out here
We're straight ahead. Oh, we're just like literally going back
Could you do a lesson on maricuna scots?
honestly
Oh my god. I have to make you do force
Force peak re religious education as well. Actually, maybe not. I may not be that fun for what people
I'll make us sing a song
Force choir, I'll have to get us all to sing at the same time
But it has to be it has to be like internet culture songs because it's fun. Why are we why did
Why did he just oh, there's a dog there but a doll dog with a book?
um
I don't know what songs I could make us sing it would have to be related to
Meme culture. What did you guys think about all the songs that made the girls sing?
I freaking
I
How am I supposed to avoid that? I'm sorry. There's absolutely no way you can dodge that
Unless you went to attack but if you am I am I going the wrong way?
I've gone horrifically the wrong way
Uh, sorry, I had to like really think there. I think I'm actually about to lose my dire horse coming back here because of this car
Yeah, wow
literally
Brian what if the more games show with the girls where every stream the questions are about a different subject eyes
Hold on. I'm getting absolutely right. Hold on protection and biz. Let's go. Oh and biz
Sorry, right. Hold on narrow. Thank you for the tip. Hey, Shawnee. What if veal or game show with the girls where every
Stream the questions are about a different. I don't know that. Sorry. I can't do two things at once. Hold on. Hold on
What way to go stick to this one?
Oh
I'm no I'm no I'm no smart enough to do two things at once. I'm gonna have to read that all over again one more time. Take it from the top
Hey, Shawnee. Why is there more enemies? What if veal or game show with the girls where they stream the question?
There are different there the questions are every so we do have one game show
Coming up that I'm gonna make I am going to reach out to a
creator
For possibly they already do a game show, but I was gonna set it up for them
So literally they can just rack in all the money
If you didn't know the easiest way to collab with people is to do all the work
But let them like take over type thing. It's the most like
likely way that
Collab opportunities will be accepted. So I've got possibly a game show that we're going to show up on someone else's channel
And and then I'll get like a highlight reel made
and
So I need to reach out to another creator, but I'm letting this first week settle down
Like it's been a bit hectic like trying to get a script manager in place
And we're trying to deal with this clipping issue that we've kind of already know
Things are a bit slow to be produced, but the girls are gonna have shorts that come out consistently
on their channels at some point
But like me and she be are literally lagging
for shorts because
I'm waiting to get us monetized first before we start putting shorts out
Because this is just a fact but shorts do better if there's something in them. That's a bit
humorous in that way
And the one that I got she be to do that a fauna speedrun challenge
Like that did well and all and I actually really
She got to show off her mine like a voice, which is absolutely perfect. Um
But um the other ones I actually got her to discuss
Milf body type v-tubers
Um, which I thought was super interesting, but I'm too scared to put it up
Right now because I would be mortified if the girls didn't get accepted for monetization
And this recent ASMR stuff. Jeez. I'm literally getting grenade launched. My goodness
Draw destroy the amp soup. Well, okay. I was gonna say where is it? Um
But there will be a lot of shorts coming up like one monetization is freaking dealt with
Uh
Because the stats updated but it only updated halfway through debut
So it says I still haven't reached watch hours even though
I think I have like a
Stupendous amount of watch hours now, especially after that assassins creed my
Assassin's Creed brother you'd stream almost has more views than my debut stream
Which is hilarious to think about because I streamed for so long and I guess people just didn't expect it
So like they came back in the stream twice at some point
You made 20 hours in two days
Literally like but after debut we all successfully had enough watch time at that point
It's just youtube has taken an entire week to update and today
I was supposed to be able to apply everyone's channel for monetization
But it only partially updated the thing. I think it's faster if
I
No, I just jumped down on this bridge that comes up. Um
But I only did it halfway through debut
So I need to wait another 24 hours for it to update and then I can submit all the girls channels
um
Like I've got an ASMR short of sheebie as well
But azure's short got denied for monetization
For advertisement and I think it's literally because her voice is just too strong. Like I don't know how
But her her voice is too strong. It needs nerf. Oh, I really don't want to go down if that's there. Can I destroy this?
Hold on
Did I just snake him out of that car?
Did that car just disappear?
I'm just going to invis through this section, but that looks like I snaked him out of that car
No, I clearly didn't because he's right there
You don't hear anything that's called
Uh, the ai cheating
What's this a bomb?
Oh a bomb
Oh a bomb. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. There's far too many of you right now. There's far too many of you right now
Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. I've done it now. I've done it now. I've done it now. I've done it now
Come it. Come it. Come it. Come it. Come it. Come it. Come it quick. Quick. Quick. foot
Where's the other one? Where's the other one? There's one more in here
There is I see it. I see it. I see it. I see it.
You can do this we can do this as long as I do it
I'll hit a checkpoint right. Get me that heck out here. Oh
I don't have heal yet. I don't have heal yet a face of maneuvers a face of maneuvers
A face, I have a heal, I have a heal, I have a heal I have a heal. I have heal
What's going on? Why?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
okay get on the horse get on the horse get on the horse get on the horse got
am i on the wrong side
if i go this way i can teleport to that other one and then go from there
yes we will do that
aww no there's another one of these
oh my gosh they're so pee
goodness gravy
what does that even mean
how ... literally i think it's because
very sadly sheepsters and Azura might have a cover-up for their... I don't know
I don't know I don't know what's going on we're kind of we're at the question mark
stage of what's the problem what's the issue but we'll get there okay
did I say thank you for the tip Nero? sorry if I didn't
but yes there are game show type-esque things coming up there's no horse
games November is my Scottish game show
I don't know if one of the girls might be interested in holding a
type of VTuber collab game show I'll need to see
yeah mate I was actually helping you do you mind
jeez you're so rude and stinky all right I think I'm to go this way and then
I'm sorry I'm getting really switched around to this freaking map
but we'll just we'll go for it we'll send it
ooh no thank you no thank you no thank you
hehehe not interested no thank you your horses butt is soaking up all those
bullets like a chat honestly staggering amount of endurance
on that thing um the Easter wheels oh are they finally
giving me a path with no enemies you know what I'm not speaking ever again
that's ridiculous timing you've embarrassed me
I would I think that's my only complaint about this game it would be so nice if
there was areas that you could just enjoy for the beauty
which I know this sounds like such a weird thing to say but like I really
like admire the game okay I'm a little a little map design
admirer and like look at how much nature there is
I'm pretty sure there's actually a steam game that came out and it's all about
identifying plants in nature and I'm like honestly I wish I was like more
entertaining so I could play it but I'm not there
B or B I gotta go somewhere okay let me just pause the stream we'll wait for you
to come back
see you when you come back
oh it's not osha pet is it peta
peta that's that animal organization
peta that's not working in my head I don't think it's peta
oh new armor oh check that out oh I like that hold on
let's do a little wardrobe check wardrobe check oh wait whoa
my mobility is way down but my protection is so up from that
we might leave that up I'd rather like have more indefinite
protection than having to deal with all these issues
with constantly like getting barraged
uh right okay crystal crystal crystal let's beat them up
where's the crystal oh whoa whoa whoa steady on steady on
where's the crystal
I'm like literally jump-scaring these guys whoa you're on the crystal
right where is it I'm staring at it oh it's up oh wow okay I would have known
that it's like I was on that crystal there mission complete
ow my ankles no again protection is more important
uh the mobility I would say so yeah that's a big old horse ride
um can I let's go wait is that that is done uh huh uh huh yeah yeah just reading
the map yeah I don't know where to go I don't know where to go I don't know
really turn around uh I think it would be faster if I took a teleport
near this location um hello
uh I have to redo the set all right okay no I just fell through the map okay
classic open woman but there we go
I think we're actually getting pretty close I have never done that before I
guess this game I mean I did say that games have
problem with the vertical stuff especially older games
when it comes to mapping you you just fall through the map so many time in
older games right we are gonna teleport
where it looks like that and then just take a weird straight ahead
what a strange layout for a map a skill issue honestly childhood me would
never do that and yet here we are being an even worse gamer
pardon me I'm doing this with baby barbs this time
whoa I saw the truck I saw it wait I need to climb this
I don't know oh my I don't know if I can I get away with this
oh my god I can get away with it oh oh that poor horse I've just left it I'm
so sorry you get to meet Ewa now hush hush your
plate is over you no longer have to you can frolic in the fields in Ewa's
heaven now I've just left you to perish to
the RDA oh I would make the joke but I
don't have any more sound effects
magic your way to the other side of the map honestly
a bit cheeky to climb when there's an entire tank shooting at you
you're the best gamer I am especially when you rage oh no
I always feel bad when I rage because I feel like it's like
I like doing what I like to see and if I see like a streamer rage I'm like I'm
not sure I'm finding this entertaining but if you guys like it then sure I'll
tap into my ancestors rage we're almost out of here I'm
literally the uh is it the orcs in Skyrim I
think their special move is called ancestors
ancestral's rage and it's like 10% more or berserk type thing it's like 10
percent more damage what's going on here
the last song right look for the thumping when bumping
nope there's a fight why is there a fight I thought I just had to interact with
the tree did not have to interact with the tree
oh okay okay okay okay we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it we're doing it come on let's do it before they destroy absolutely
everything uh uh uh uh is it not here triangle hello
triangle looking for a triangle triangle this is a triangle there we go
are they gonna blow the tree up before I get the phone
no the ancestral stuff was done man uh berserkers rage is the one that works
out ah
uh right invisible because we're not out here trying to have a billion battles
every two seconds yeah probably feedback on the game
kind of calm down on how many enemies you put on the map because they are
constant hello barrier did this did this game really say go
round no way this game just say go around
oh no it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine you have some yes yes let's get out of here this place is going to
blow oh we must return to kello draw take your
ecrane we ride to home tree okay we go
to home tree home tree
I think we're getting there I can't really recall how much more to the campaign
there is this would be three songs and if we're playing the classic video game
rule uh I can't remember what comes after the third song
I swear if it's like go for another song on my right wrap it up wrap up wrap up
you're taking a bit too long now take a bit too long we're gonna need to do
something a bit more than home questing but look at kill that armor looks
honestly that's pretty thick
it would be so cool to see this game remastered but I do not think it sold
well I think it hardly did it it's numerals
hello we love James Cameron you did it again
is it snowing no winter in Australia
is and so just fake it never goes below freezing
the song yes yes the song the song a was song
please be the last song no more singing
tells where it is please no more songs surely we know what's up many of the
people believe in you yet some fear the
cute spirit inside you let me get bed ammo
he blames you for much there was just a whole missing voice line I think
it was so hard to come to our realization
that Christmas is summer final song it's not natural but
it's a pretty decided once I wrap up a business
that I am going back so you must gather
walk with care bed ammo yeah if you ever went to open up a business in the UK
don't you better do it in Australia but then go back to the UK once you're done
with all your business that's here for more
entrepreneur tips like and subscribe
sharpens his spear
tangela wants you to fly to a new location I
don't know what this I'm afraid my memory is getting very hazy now for
the game
you'd kill for a warm Christmas it is bizarre I did not enjoy it like I
phoned my family and I was like oh I wish it was
cold I wish it was cold um because you do get
snowy Christmas in Scotland which is really pretty when it does happen
when the stars align it's very nice
hello I haven't given up where is the shot
where sky machine has crashed you are so mean I've literally been helping you
for ages I'm sorry but I think enough times
pass where he should be alright with me and you're giving me any nonsense
you make it sense to miss to go it's very beautiful where is that
what the heck is this map I do not recall at all
memory's getting a little bit hazy I can't see where the map ends because of
that very top right corner very clearly that's where this map
location ends but I don't know what happens here
can't believe it right I think we're just gonna leg it as we always do
but yeah like these look the map details like the
kind of the further you progress the more damage the areas are and
you know it was trying our hardest but like there's only
only so much awa can do and the navi can do against literal bullets I have to
admit bows versus bullets like I'd rather have the
rather have the mp5 or the famine some way why did I get off I think I just
want to activate that oh well I needed to get off anyway
because I need to cut open this fence I'm itching my little
what was this Elden Ring oh you've got me
let's see
uh we'll just avoid thank you for spawning in but
not really interested me wait am I going the wrong way
no I can go this way I just happened to walk right into an RDA
aligned and I need to cut this fence as well
get in the scraby
I might make a cup of tea shortly and go for a peep because we've actually not
peeped in three and a half hours of uh unless some of you guys have a
detached headset and then you go for a peep
whilst while still listening to the fact that there's a very high
chance that a wiefling has dropped a loaf of bread while
listening to me ramble on stream that's right wiefling I'm on air
I know exactly what you're up to mm-hmm I know what's going on
hmm
a drop a loaf of bread honestly drop apparently the there's another same
which is um drop the kids off at the pool
which is uh guilty is charged oh no it's been confirmed
you know when people say like oh what did you what what did you think would
happen like when you became a beach over etc
uh apparently I didn't account for someone dropping a loaf of bread to my
voice so there's that yeah um yeah quite a few unique scenarios
definitely definitely
how are you ever like he teleports around this map for fun I swear
okay hello no the shard was blown up
not sure the first voice is not sure oh I'm being called the first voice I'm no
longer dreamwalker oh my tummy rumbled if you heard that
listen into your patreon audio we'll see in a man
about horse I didn't want to miss a second to your
beautiful voice though if it's any consolation
you make dropping and you make dropping a loaf of bread hell of a lot more
comfortable you're done you're out out you're done
we would be not identifying as loaf of bread droppers
oh that came out nowhere
oh my poor horse I should have picked up a new one
because he's so low health I want him to retire and live a happy life
but I don't think that's gonna is it left or right it's this way
she knows
oh right I'm gonna pick up this horse here because I would like this one to
literally retire and have a happy life excuse me mr horsey
see you go enjoy yourself and heal up and then I'm gonna have you
tada and then everyone lived happily ever after and the
and everyone around me clapped yay
how else are we supposed to listen to the field shoot honestly though
um wow that's a lot of power
a lot of manpower behind that they're destroying the crystals before we get
them is someone telling them this
how do they know where the heck all these crystals are
right we'll finish this map and then we'll go for a tinkle and I will
also go for a tinkle and make a cup of honey tea to help soothe my poor voice
it's really bizarre my voice is so broken
but the microphone makes it sound so like fine
and not broke wait can I just teleport no I can't go fast
um so I sound like pretty normal on stream
my voice has been broken since uh the the violor exposed violor stream
um I don't know thankfully I've managed to record a lot of stuff in advance
but don't be surprised if you get a patreon audio
and I'm just sound like a frog I'm like yeah you're like my good boy
and you're such a good wee boy and you're like my good boy
like it's getting it's getting curious it's getting curious
and you are a demon how is it you live
with so many honestly that's kind of a fair assumption
there's something I gotta tell you we must have been
those who have fallen so we attack
do some patreon videos in full pantomime
you get 3d models and start like mime in the axe
yeah
wouldn't be the first thing patreon box and audio in me
a little frog voice moment you let a horse die
oh it was a mistake I can't save them all but I can try my best
also I just want to say I am still getting
marshmallows of people asking me to save Vichu oh that horse literally just
perished right before me oh where am I supposed to go
uh that's quite far to go by foot but we don't really have a choice there's
one more horsey horsey
skull horse skull women sound really cute when their voice is
cracking and squeaking from over using their giggling
asking you to say what no they're they're asking me to save
certain Vichubers and I said it on that stream the other day and like we're all
having a giggle but I woke up and I got a few more and I'm like
I don't I don't know if it's refling sending it or whatever but like I'm
gonna be on it oh it's full health again and I'm gonna be honest
I hope it's understandable no I can't literally save all Vichubers
you know I'll try my best to look after those who have faith in me
um you know I'm a big believer in reciprocation
in terms of you have faith in me I have faith in you type thing
well I better not am I on a timer and I don't know it
I think I'm on a timer
gotta go gotta go gotta go I know I know I know I know
I'm trying
I can unlock this uh to your vision you can lead from the front and try and
change I think the content creator owned
agencies definitely have a place
um definitely have a place um because I think people are a bit
mmm it's not for me to say what the the overall feel is but I think
for me anyway it was very disappointing to learn
how little creators that sign up for these agencies
get in exchange for all their hard work because did he just go ahead me
did he just go ahead me um hello hello human resources
do you guys have human resources on pandora because um what was that
excuse me
uh yeah because we have very specific it's unlikely but
um I did actually learn about another agency that did have a higher split than
the 5050 which I'm I'm quite happy to hear about
um so I think hopefully over time that 5050 split
gets raised because I will tell you right now
for however hard the girls work on stream it's absolutely nothing to do with
me I don't tell them what to do they do it all themselves
um and I believe that they should take home the lines
share that's just me but not every agency that there feels like that
um but if you value um if you genuinely like
as a special thank you is what wait hold on I'm getting absolutely annihilated
here Danny take these down I think so
hold on I'm doing I cast protection where's that other one
what's going on here am I just to destroy because I'll do it
ow we're on the same team right I don't have protection anymore but
okay okay we're to just kill I can do that I can do that
we got I'm a weapon what's this what's this
anything in it no uh whoa whoa whoa whoa you're not aggro to me
hey hey hey hey hey we're helping a while we're helping helping you know what
helping is yeah these guys these are the best
are they spawning oh my game just froze there did you see that I don't know if
that was caught on stream or not but that was for me and I thought I
can hear bullets from over here so to check out okay let's go
one more one more mission oh here here
spawned a navi resources
there will be a beautiful place if you're more like me
the only problem is
you never know if someone wants to take advantage of you but I got very lucky
in all my pics of the girls and none of them and I've given any indication
such things we got the crimson yeah froze I saw that
monk is monk is monk is please don't please don't crash please don't crash
please don't crash
and yes I've um I've always been described as naive like my entire life
um and I like I'm used to it and I do have to agree I do have to agree um
but the the good news is it can lead to such such crazy
experiences you know like I could have easily like
have just never bothered about any of it and just you know get the resources to
myself all that kind of thing but um
I'm passionate about helping people achieve their dreams and you know I've
already kind of achieved everything that I
kind of wanted to do in terms of like successful content creator and
to give people that experience that kind of thing just like that that's the new
goal you know that's the new goal like as but like
yeah yeah you know life life's good life is beautiful
um and you know if you don't try out these things
at least you know at the end of this at the end of everything like well I mean
wrap it up wrap it up come on wrap it up at the end of
everything at least I can say yeah heck yeah I went for it I did it
um and wow what an achievement you know what a
what an experience as well like an insane life experience
just to even be in the position to make any of this happen and
it's just lovely lovely lovely right I just saved you you better be nice to
me now
you still don't like me gather your soul let no more of my warriors
you still don't like me you're joking what you are joking me
starting here being inspirational right now on a Thursday afternoon
you're doing great dumb dumb but try to also think of your health
I've been good I've my health has a just been
oh it's been going up and up and up what the humans know what we're doing
they destroyed the shark this you sent us to die
for nothing no I think I can still do this
you will die human I can do this
what am I going to commune without the shards
Ava loves me sorry I'm Ava's little teacher's pet right now I'm not even
kidding I'm floating no I'm not sorry that was the
camera angle I thought that was levitation it was just the camera angle
my apologies got a little excited there
uh
got a little uh head of myself that was a cheeky little camera angle moment
we must return the song to tahi tsunami
wait you spoke as the first voice all of a sudden he's been nice to me
I would not hear him one day I will repay you for all
is it because he saw me commune with Ava that he's nice to me now if we're
still alive after today beers are on you if that is what it takes
he doesn't even know what beer is do they even know what fermentation is
humans will soon realize are you telling me the navi gets steaming every
weekend I'd believe it honestly
I'd get a steaming with a navi not gonna lie I'd like ask them to carry me around
on their backs and stuff
he was we discord kitten honestly he's not a hater anymore literally
he was just a bit stressed from all the war just a wee bit of war wee bit of war
you know strong men war times you know how it goes
you know everyone needs a bit of release to the freedom and then it's just what
happens just what happens oh do you approve of me now
you think the first thing the humans gave to the navi we're making friends with
beer honestly there oh here's a bit diazapam you just get hooked on that
uh cause a little uh drug pandemic you know
here we go
the humans gather
do you have the final song oh wait are we at the end
I think so something happened are we at the end of the game already
I don't know why I see the nia they mocked me
I'm like 90 percent sure if you look up how long does dream scammers avatar take
it said literally eight hours to understand
now quickly um sing the final song oh but that's like such a short screen though
oh I never thought this far ahead I thought it was going to be like an eight hour day
I suppose the only good side if it was a short stream I can work on my ASMR then
because I've got collapse with five other girls that I'm working on outside of
the other
yeah you know yeah uh yeah we can do some marshmallows after the game
wait am I seriously I was going to make a cup of tea and pee from all of that
wait I think that's super about to do the last level
so what do we do now
you you are the melody more creepy only first voice can awaken the well of
source okay how am I supposed to do that oh so many questions trust himself
now rda playthrough for more time no I refuse
I refuse rda like to open your mouth rda players
that's what I think of your rda players
any percent speed run honestly I feel like we're about to play the last game
like the last level human you're so tiny oh you're so tiny
human human human you are so okay
I'm gonna go support that
Kendra hello writer look at you you really look full naughty now what are you doing here
it's falco he's found the location of the dormant site I know you have to move fast
falco sent a dragon to the site he's gonna drop the emulator on the well of souls
this is the last mission what the heck you need the true first we're not even on the
forever mark of gameplay yeah about that looks like it's me the eight hours I must be four
yeah I was gonna say it must be four hours navi four hours rda I gotta find tangela
wow I didn't know I expect that oh
oh I was like strapped in for a good long hmm though I'll say one thing the only good
thing if I do go offline earlier is I can read into another viewer member and I can get to work
on those asmr scripts because their girls that I'm collabing with are waiting on are you squidding
me right now Brian big big please play the rda with money on top oh you can't give me money and
ask for it because then I feel like I do have to do partner it's still me if we play the rda
you all have to call me a good girl okay what about tantis thank you for the tip iron refer
that's crazy to put that money behind that door oh I've never played it before
right we'll finish the navi sites and then you are a good girl you're the best
thank you
I just got home from work no 12 hour stream today well we might do a lock in for another four hours
if we play the rda side but I get really scared because the rda side you're so small and the
camera's so small and the navi are so big and scary I can't promise I'm not going to be scared
because I've never done it before I don't know what comes up but like with these ones like
my kind of remember what comes out it's a good girl he's a good girl yes you are
best girl we got a war cry
right let's unlock the classic tree of vision momentum thank you
hmm head pads and scritches um my freaking tags aren't working on the alternative twitter
I'm trying to retweet all the like things I get in for a fight here or what oh
we must attack the commanders put their forces in disarray grunts will not know what to do
you're such a good girl how the hell do you know something about me oh she grew
also all the plants and animals attack you and rda no I'm so scared I'm scared already
um we share this battle like I'm actually going to be scared I'm not even kidding
hopefully my abilities keep me alive when we do the rda side but
oh I'm like genuinely dreading that I don't know if you can tell
many boom
you're gonna hold my hand through it yeah you better I just know there's going to be a
hypnosis mark actually no I didn't ask secret subject I'm very very busy maybe I should just
get the balls to do that enough what is this map I do not recall
hmm
right we'll go grab a horror horse let's go and then we'll see where that takes us
I said I was gonna make should we should we pause for a tinkle in a cup of tea then
possibly wait I need to go left or right I need to follow the path clearly
burning the countryside literally oh careful because that plant will accidentally uh team
oh my goodness I hope I've got good armor this is crazy thank god they're not locking onto the horse
whoa this is getting quite a lot what am I supposed to do here
I'm to kill certain guys sure okay oh he's actually got health hold on let me get these
first so I'm not getting like crossfire damage they have special abilities he literally just
precision freaking pulsed me no the horse is horse horse let me take them
horse let me take them you're getting oh horse
breath perish perish I commandee to perish before me
me sky people rename dreamwalker rename the first voice you will perish under
by my command I'm actually gonna have to walk through this freaking battlefield
why is there an eight commission mine there's two oh well we'll go we'll go for it uh invisible
let's go invisible uh I'm pretty sure they all all this location stuff responds genuinely not a
point in clearing any of the ow I got called crossfire there I suppose that's a good detail to
have crossfire level four on abilities is the highest like in most effective to go I've been
literally I was gonna say I've been invisible for a very long time there so we'll get to it
everybody let's get to it to help a while expect expel the humans and restore nature
when I start drinking my hmm does all my thinking
no more and I
blame on this whiskey shift and get me tipsy buy beer or pay the rent my signing bonus
was quickly spent something something and I'm gonna beat the meat like a bitch or
let's get this morning I'm so sorry I know
Brian you didn't say anything you forgot to put a message anon anon did you forget
to put the message in the message box thank you for the tip but anon you were you're you can
put like a little message and then Brian will read it out and then I go Brian and then we and we
discuss what you put and then I say thank you anon but next time that little box that says
you put a message here you can put anything you want anything you can even ask me what I think
about Pythagoras theory you can even ask me what I think about all um things we can even talk about
the Ming dynasty if you really want it your wish is my command but thank you for the tip
are you squinting me right now you telling me a shrimp fried this rice thank you snis snis
then but I appreciate it I'm the tear squinting me right now anon anything you want anon don't waste
your money like that you goofy guver thank you for the support but don't waste your money like that
but thank you I appreciate it you're you're clearly a man of few words why say many words
when few do trick clearly the Ming dynasty I don't know if I would listen to something of them now
I would go over look at time bomb I just seem to remember that one song I wanted to do a Scottish
cover of it Brian no smile that's the little money I've been memeing about with thank you again anon
no smile you've been granted the nickname no smile anon congrats oh I didn't mean to jump
down I didn't realize there was a ledge I just sent that per horse off the ledge
it listened to me though it like trusted me I learned this about horse riders apparently it's
really dangerous if your horse doesn't listen to you Brian work ahead I sure hope so thank you can
quit me for the donal good work ahead I sure hope it does that's good thing
oh my god there is so much exploding I don't think I'm gonna make it out of here honestly
thank you for all the support guys I'll push you getting that oh it's just gonna let me through
open cumin my
um um um I have protection on I don't know I'm trying would you stop doing that I need to heal
now I need to heal okay hold no I lost my special I should have done my ultimate first okay we did
it we did it okay one next one next one next oh I love it I love when the game makes me go all
the way back I'm actually gonna go ahead and get this uh unlock we haven't been using our bone
I got jump scared in real life I did not see that whatsoever I don't know if you heard that inhale
there that was so dramatic oh my god my heart is pounding I jumped scared in real life I blinked
and then something was right in front of me oh my wee heart oh my goodness right that is so much
quicker we're gonna do that go back to the thingy can confirm a fellow for it do you tell me a shrimp
right this are you telling me I called this fish damn right I called this fish
go go gadget jump scare honestly hello did I help you again I am amazed many believe
not be killed we'll now press our attack
right I'll call a break when we finish the navi side because I feel like we're about to do it
mount the banshee and report to the third leader banshee banshee banshee mount the banshee banshee
I don't see a big ecran I see a horse where am I supposed to go
blink blink blink blink ecran
ecran
ecran oh okay yeah I was gonna say something's not up here something's not up here
well I wanted to do like meme song covers where I purposely like really put on the accent for
it um because I think that's funny like uh that song is funny I wanted to do an M&M one
like everywhere I go hmm always know that channely scene he's called how we made that
he lost too soon wake up grab rear grab rear put on some scene gear when you get drunk come on
wake up wake up with my girlfriend's working I'm undead unfed been sleeping on bunk beds
since 10 so if I don't booze it I'm gonna lose it everybody get to it to it let's get this party
started let's get them 40s
hi mero sorry about that we're just enjoying the old Scottish accent and singing and seeing what
the combination is like and it's pretty cursed but it's like the good kind I am currently absolutely
destroying this pro banshee you smack it against all the rocks how realistic are uploading song
covers do the rates cost a lot no you don't have to pay rates at all you just get a copyright and
you can't monetize it really um it's the biggest thing it just won't like monetize it let me guess
wait it's the strongy it was the strongies we made along the way strongy can I send you a meme in
dms and do it for me on stream someday thank you heck yeah what was your have I got you on discord
have I only got you on twitter I don't have you on discord
so I am you're not you're absolutely no I apologize for using that language
I'm not I can't look at my twitter this sounds terrible but the game I'm playing right now
Mero is so old that if I tab out the game crashes so I can't actually look at your twitter communication
so I apologize I will try and add you on discord shortly though um because I'm wanting you
I'm wanting you for a secret mission Mero a mission so secret
now is that it's okay it's okay yeah maybe I'll make a short maybe if it's like a
quote thing I'll make a wee short of it I'll be like thanks for the oh my god thanks for the
the the money idea money money money maybe oh I'm getting wrecked I like I chase the whole
weeks I'm doing four weeks right what we're supposed to do in this area the classical right
I'm gonna do protection prayer I'm gonna warlock up in this okay you are definitely not looking down
I don't like you at all who are we going for next to you yeah okay
oh that auto lock onto me those rough I do like that you can knock them over I do appreciate
that detail what are we looking at oh just walked right into oh wait he comes out of the mech
and he does this oh I just unlocked my special as well
wow
don't do it don't do it I know you're tempted don't know you hear all the news
you know take that oh that ultimate was cool though I'll give them that
did my horse survive I don't think so at all oh look at the mech little mech it's just a little
guy is a wee a wee lad barely more than half my size oh right okay I should heal up once I'm out
of range of that enemy so I don't need to use my use my um my healing ability ragdolled honestly
the mission even if secret is punching humans punching me honestly
if you if you try and dissect the gameplay a little too much you might find yourself a little
a little underwhelmed it may be a little lackluster but oh don't wait wait wait
then you worry about it right then you worry about it you're all destroyed Savoy and his
demons oh demon skin I like the description for America I'm currently in my demon skin
how do you do fellow demon skin enthusiast take your banshee and ride it oh
have I done it a wake well of souls I think this is a a gasped and my throat made a noise
I'm sorry if you heard that I didn't mean it oh level up
Rathmo oh my god new armor I saw it I saw it I have a skull on my head
oh hey I almost forgot this game because congrats you're the second person to play this game
uh that even knows about this game because one person said they played it earlier and then
now you've said you played it so now all three of us who have ever played this game are now here
because literally no one has played this game does anyone I wonder if there's a public record
of how many copies were sold because I just feel like it's such a thing way too late for this stream
but I'm also one of the two people I played yeah everyone thinks I'm playing the new avatar I think
possibly I don't know actually I don't know what the new avatar games called because this one's called
James Cameron's avatar the game well we've got to say oh my god mansion armor twinsies
go waits for me in the in the cavern okay to the cat to the cavern to the cavern
or something's waiting for me waiting waiting waiting cavern right I'm not to go around okay
I'm to go around my apologies this the game has an interesting story I like it basically you are
human and then it turns out a wa planned on you kind of I don't know it's really bizarre
oh a scalpel perimer comb that beach why is that phrase called comb a beach what's that mean
what does he mean what does he even translate to am I going the wrong way I'm getting nervous I'm
going true they can literally hear me like jump about I hear this oh my gonna make it is in this
oh I almost made it past all those RDA soldiers oh I'll take it I'll take it a couple paths yeah
I assume when we play the RDA side we're literally just playing the exact same maps but doing the
opposite of the bad people and destroying everything wow I need prediction on right now
I'm getting absolutely nailed them right now I don't want to use healing because I actually
do a full health bar when I heal let's speed on speed on through okay this looks more navvy
paid four hours is it gonna be another endurance stream I think so originally it wasn't but
I got paid money to play the RDA side and you guys are holding my hand through it because I am
genuinely afraid of what happens hello how do you do I'll hope lies with you dream walker excuse me
I'm actually called the first voice I'm no longer I didn't I don't respond to dream worker I'm the first
boy will not let them any first voicers has asked you to kill RDA forces yeah
so Emmy is going live YouTube moderators I grant the permission to link
a sheet streaming is mine it's unarchived okay smart and Michael smart smart and
uh this looks like it's uh destroy everything mission because there's a timer oh right there
is actually a timer on the door I don't know if any protection spell yet I'll wait until I'm getting
whacked I don't I'm not experiencing the whackinging yet
uh right okay I think the game's actually being mildly oh my god imagine three navvy
ganging off on you it's over it's over I wouldn't even bother just put the gun down and be like
actually I'm gonna be one of you oh wait oh sorry I'm getting distracted protection I've casted
protection okay there we go gang violence gang violence we're literally ganging off in the
upper guy oh that's terrible absolutely a wipe in the night I guess
one for you one spank for you and one for you okay we just need to defend the village now
without perishing which I can definitely I can hear someone getting hurt over here oh yeah
one for the true warfare I think we're cheering each other on we responsible
okay I'm gonna need that prayer to pop again because now there's mecca's getting involved
demon skin parish
but yes uh Emmy Bezu uh the beloved hex maniacal bealer is live right now you are welcome to
jump into her stream and uh make sure you're you know make sure your little sister stays
in check don't want any issues
imagine Assassin's Creed but plain as a temp yeah that's what I'm kind of like why on earth
would anyone want to do the RDA but like money talks dirty cash I want you dirty cash I want you
oh money talking money talking okay oh um oh camera angle steady steady right we've got one more
minute isn't that a game already what game are you partly viewing about identify your topic of conversation
one two three four five ultimate yeah honestly that ultimate is actually pretty sad so I'm gonna
heal because it's not gonna all heal when we're not around it because the enemies keep coming back
so protection oh there's a mecca over there I think oh it's out of bounds wow I just do this for now
oh no no I won't someone's getting me oh maybe not maybe not the navi are actually helping hold on AI
that actually attacks the enemies that are around you hold on a minute this game's 2009 and you're
telling me they nailed it here and then games afterwards it's my biggest like great with video
game development if you have allies that can attack but they do not actually end the enemies
looking at you lego franchise looking at you and they actually don't help at all
I don't know if the newest lego star wars they actually do help
is she playing this because she genuinely likes it or is she as a warning to the rest of us to avoid
this it's my childhood game I do like the game I'm just rubbish at it I like the navi side I've
never played the RDA say whoa oh that's so cool looking I think we get to write it
that's like such a cool looking dragon such a badass looking dragon and if you wanted to shorten it
I guess you could see we're raiding that bad dragon
oh thank you thank you I'll be here all week try the veal
it's awful I'm so sorry
2009 my child I'm too old for this oh my god we are
that was fell it was I apologize that was a good one thanks came up with it on the
it probably is the game I completed the most that's much fun should be ashamed of yourself boom
dragon dies oh my god look how big its wingspan is oh gorgeous
oh beautiful beautiful I love that design that's so cool Jen too can we get this color palette
or something because that is wicked sorry sorry my bad it's first time riding you hold on hold on
there's a saddle on down excuse me thank you very much it'd be nothing I heard that that creepy
noise oh I'm not sure I'm ashamed of finding that joke funny what is that noise I think that's the
where the soul is calling on me first time raiding warning warning
raider hardly even nor oh oh wait I don't even get the bidimps for that oh okay sorry
I wouldn't I would entertain the idea of uh gen two dragon that hordes you like treasure and she
calls you like my treasure my value like that kind of angle I like that that's that's not bad
I would entertain that hmm I'm gonna entertain that oh you have crickets too yeah
I would actually entertain that um
before anyone asks fendom no I don't like it I don't I don't think it's okay
oh what the jelly what the land jellyfish gonna do huh
oh I've completely forgotten what happens in this cutscene if I'm gonna be honest
uh
was that an electricity sound are we about to lighten and bolt this thing out the sky
electricity oh thunder and lighten and maybe
okay
okay question mark
okay question mark question mark
we're saved though that's the fantastic news first voice does not need a second
he really this is only the beginning tanjala more you did it
oh we did it we prepare a storm is in the sky
thunder we did it na vi na vi na vi we're the best we're the best better than the rest
better than the rda let me take a little little uh drink too
congrats on getting second place for na vi any percent lemo let me submit this stream for it why not
another game down well uh we're gonna go for a tinkle winkle and I'm gonna make a honey tea
because my voice box is dying and then we're gonna do the rda so hmm so don't uh emmy I believe
shibi is playing class of 09 emmy bezu is doing an unlisted unarchived stream so please don't be
afraid to go check that out because I'll still be here actually I don't know how long she's gonna
go for that maybe I mean if it's four hours to do the rda side it is very rough on the voice to
whisper for four hours so hopefully I know boo rda rda hate me is making pin pals do math oh no way
I think to know if you play as a human you have multiple places where you can betray them
hmm what is that like all the way up to the very end
because wouldn't I wouldn't I just become a na vi at that point or am I still human
you wouldn't I have to do the evil side now unfortunately
I think I would ruin the run if I did it I beat the game already literally I think it's
four hours for each side yeah there's any rda hate but gun and flamethrower fun though
then every straight up ask you to switch like three four times oh do they I would know I love gun
shoot so I
right I'm gonna quickly go peep um and make a cup of tea I highly suggest everyone to stretch
your legs don't be afraid to open up any stream the now I will be roughly three minutes it takes
me like three minutes to boil the kettle and tinkle and all of that so please do fish pee absolutely
fish pee all over you right now um please don't be afraid to check out she be or any um I will be
a couple of minutes and then we will jump back into the naughty naughty human side bad human bad
human stinky human stinky stinky um but yes please do consider standing up stretching your legs
getting yourself a little snacky wacky um and then we'll jump in and you guys have to hold my hands
with the game because I am actually genuinely terrified to play with women all the way through
his camera angle so freaking low to the ground and if I've got big navi running at me I'm actually
going to be scared so yes hopefully I really hope the game doesn't break while I'm awake for like
literally three minutes but the game's so old right please do stand up and get some rest
did it work did it work oh yeah okay I go now
so
I have no idea what I'm talking about.
My freaking headset.
My freaking headset cable
is wrapped around the mic.
So I couldn't put my headset on there.
Wow, been gate kept from on-ing.
make up is the game crash doesn't look like it so we're doing it we're doing it
we're actually freaking doing it who we playing we just play the same right I
can't believe bad guy confirmed yeah we're playing the bad guy I have a cup
of tea I don't know if you can hear me my nails against that I can't believe
the bad guys and me is a little scamp what's she doing what's going on in that
stream I can't eat ill I can't I can't you see it
we're the bad guys doh
she's actually doing math homework okay I should just straight up doing homework
okay I thought of a funny stream where you guys like who are actually in
education like send me what your college essays about and then we have to make it
live on stream whatever the subject is but the problem is obviously I don't
there is no are we the baddies here it's just we're the baddies she's getting
help from big bro yeah nice RDA I'm a really happy German boy I guarantee
berries and cream his name is Hans and he's a happy German boy the problem is
you're too smart and would be and you're too me smart are you joking or have you
never heard me speak for like longer than three minutes me
sorry I'm not sure I don't know when I pranked you but I'm just saying you got
pranked hard if you genuinely think I have any intelligence to offer this
world hey I'll let my cup of tea cool down I may actually be cheeky and order
a markers do you guys want anything hmm you guys want to make it with me I know
I literally just said it makes me but I'm enjoying this and I'm
you know I'll be in charge of your orientation now which one what's her best
subject get that's me what Emmys okay she can't do any can't do my shit don't
like it I'm Mercy says she can't do math I don't need me I'm vocal I feel picking
the RDA is like siding is like being like being siding with Elden with
English oh my god I'm so sorry I absolutely butchered one earth you put I
feel picking the RDA is like being siding with English during the bath right
it wasn't me it was you oh my god I thought I was having a stroke oh wait
sorry sorry let me do that again oh I thought I was having a stroke but not
the good came sorry okay I was okay I was a little too obvious I
apologize okay we can skip through the dialogue so that's what we're gonna do
we'll skip through and get to where we are oh brother use the crickets wait I've
already forgotten what I was gonna say wait what did I just say to make that
joke no good line the joke made me say I've already forgotten what the frickin
joke was I'd rather you go back to the Raider joke for the fifth time yeah
oh brother this guy
the stroke joke oh wait what did you want crickets oh I'm having the stroke and
not the good kind
oh okay to my next card what do you call a man it's so goofy it's so goofy
turning the stream into a dad pun string on his blue I love this bit well when
you guys like do witty comments I can repeat on stream I'm literally stealing
them and then doing that gag over and over again
shouldn't be straight up to working okay I have to go now bye bye thank you for
hanging see when you when you come back because I'll still be like I work I don't
know if it takes four hours to do the RDA side then I don't yeah if anyone says
like they go work or sleep then sadly I don't think I'm gonna be there I think
this is a eight hour stream rather a bit more on the shorter side than what we're
used to but hey well let's laugh I don't know why but the crickets make me laugh
hmm let's see but what do you get when you cross a snowman and a vampire
frostbite
why was that so delayed I don't know why the crickets were so delayed that was
even more embarrassing that made it worse that the crickets were delayed oh
trying man trying all right ready for this we're skipping we're skipping even
the crickets aren't having it literally and we're showing up eight hours
built on the shorter side I'll let you like I've kind of mentioned I weave it
but like going offline after two hours I like sat and was just staring at the
screen for a little bit I was like what do I do now like I've got like an entire
day and I'm not on stream like it felt so weird like I don't know but I reach
them a smart collapse type thing which is really good hopefully make some fun
her little cheekies are definitely red I think I'm too German for the jokes are
really bad they are terrible the jokes are not funny and that is why we we use
the yeah because no one's laughing at the joke
honestly it felt weird like every week I do plan in a couple of injured streams
but the days that have shorter streams like the two are one like I really
enjoyed needy streamer overload I did not expect to enjoy that I looked up the
ending I would have gotten if I managed to not ignore her and like she was like
ready to become a god and like take down 10% of the world's population and all
that and I'm like whoa I so wish I could have gotten that but I messed up too
badly that's okay I couldn't have known you know play for them you know you get
none of the squat you got you and none of the squad laughing with that one I
giggle you're still sitting on your feet I'm sitting on my right one right
now and then left one is just wiggling the back of the chair don't abuse
what do you say
Nico from undead and what I don't know think of crisscross applesauce the way
you sit like that but I'm sitting on my foot like against my good way good way
to really enjoy streams of you I cuz I constantly like wiggle and move my legs
type thing
I was gonna be either putting pressure or moving them like cuz cuz I'm sitting on
my foot there's pressure against it so it's like keeping me stationary you get
a little grin over us a little mouth curve oh yeah did I have the ability to
make you put air out your nose a little just a little bit faster yeah I'm
thinking crouched no I'm not I'm not crouching I'm like sitting on them this
time but I do go on crouch on the chair sometimes like I was having to send all I
was talking to like eight people at once trying to organize something for the
girls and I was golem crouched on my chair because I was trying to like get
it done so fast so I could go to bed because I was exhausted I'm like trying
to like send this an editor and upload these files over here and send them off
and get the link and make sure it's a pretty like oh so yeah it was horrific
although they attacked me when I'm Navi as well so honestly I'm just a
wee bit deserved honestly these things are indestructible honestly I should
unplug my mouse and keyboard right now I'm not even paying attention honestly I
should but I think you could probably xp farm here if you had the tolerance part
because you're getting 50 every time and my it says I need 1,600 xp to level up
so yeah that's the pretty big xp farm ow my angry you're like I got paid to side
with the humans okay this is this is not me I'll put a little disclaimer at the
top of the screen not me not me you're not funny
but your accent is doing the heavy lifting fucking hell you're not supposed to
say that part out look that's supposed to be an inside thought absolutely just
got annihilated oh my I don't even know if I can come back from that oh that was
brutal I can't even come back from that I got 10 xp from driving over that plan
literally okay the dogs don't get like perish from the bungee which is fine
carried by the Scottish literally we do have to be careful we know do this do
the slow mo for me so I can actually oh jeez the way same box are you trolling me
right now I'm sorry but my bullets should have sprayed all over that goodness
gravy you just like oh I don't like that they win some pain either I just feel
so mean why are you being so mean you're a mean mean man cuz you're just
jealous oh my gosh I don't like it I don't like it I'm sure they were probably
win some when I was Navi but it's everything feels so meaner I'm going
in biz so I can get around here without attracting the other far away one what
did that do recovery gather ten seven pulls through our recovery okay my
second chance I heard that I heard that I knew you were coming here we go hello
thank God you're here please you got it's running out here spraying all over I
mean I'm a cultfish I don't make sure that ink gets far you know for
protection to disorientate is it to disorientate creditors and escape the
threat and must be whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I can feel one behind me as
well which I don't like they have unlimited ammo oh I do not okay okay why
do I not have unlimited ammo that's a bit of a problem I heard that I don't see
like cuz the camera angle is like way smaller cuz I am smaller as well makes
Pandora like even scarier the accuracy of our drunks
beep beep beep beep beep that is unbelievable but that no it's
comedically slow that reverse considering how fast and a what's the
motion sickness and just in the forward spring I've unlocked a grenade launcher
okay maybe maybe mucking around with the weapons would be such a terrible idea
trooper pack unlocked some sort of believe it excuse me excuse me excuse me
I'm just driving through here then you mean me no I'm not looking for any trouble
just backing up here don't mind me the dune buggy what's the that music video
from gorillas that had like a random buggy in the desert oh I need a gun to
keep myself from harm the poor people are burning in the sun they got a chance
thing go I can't move to the forward base
there's all I do is dance cuz all I do is sing and then the buggy out of nowhere
boom boom boom no way kids go old military sound gearbox don't want to go
backwards only forwards towards the enemy this is like a flashback right now
oh can you like see the music video in your head as I'm talking about it oh can
I put images in your head if I talk about things oh my god I never even
spoke about that so I can't like see things in my head the way others can
like the way it's just like I can't do that so if I say things does it appear in
your head
sometimes okay okay I'm totally not gonna use that I guess at any point mmm
can I do a music videos I am now making you think of the gorillas music video
we're noodles is dancing in that room and then the guy has a big head and it
goes never did no harm never did no harm
wait is that the wrong one I don't know one of them the giant head literally it
was just a man I saw the comments and someone was like that a key jaw honestly
his jaw so and if you ever take the recreational and also known as the
bex to say and that makes your jaw clench or something along that line and so in
scott's you say like oh his jaw was spinning or like he's got an a key jaw
and like the comments were all saying that and we'll watch it back and I was
like oh wow really oh excuse me excuse me I'm just a signal specialist I'm
looking for a fight excuse me excuse me no no I don't want to fight leave me alone
get me in the boat get me in the boat geez Titanic all over again get me in
that boat oh I forgot it's just like a lot more than here it's dare do you know
the song from grills kids with guns oh no sorry I thought your reference in that
music video I know the what's that other one I really like humility I don't want
no isolation unfortunately I don't know the words very well like I never oh I'm
just jumping whilst I'm accepting all these I've unlocked a nail gun veteran
pack I can call in a motor strike hold on a minute hold on a minute this is
actually uh maybe I admit it's a little bit cool I'll definitely keep zoom
because it keeps me away significantly increased damage
oh but that one's calling an airstrike destroying every enemy and be aware it
takes a few seconds for the strike to our right maybe just defense I think
defense speed and health to get me out of there and whatever the last one was
invisibility and zoom get me out of whatever situation I'm in the video
but Jack black follow that signal yeah yeah so I'm about to go full fortune
son on the nappy I don't know what fortune this one is but how hot take
coming in hall I don't like the gorillas oh yeah that's okay you don't have to
like everything some things are for some people and some things aren't for some
people that is how the world works I don't think anyone should be punished
however if you don't like assassin screed brotherhood then I will happily put
you in either Marcy's basement or Sheevee's dungeon take your pick you know
up to you right we are just skipping through this for those of you have kind
of just joined in you're not quite sure what's going on and we have successfully
finished the nappy side of this game we are now purposely joining the RDA which
I have never actually played before but we are still in the tutorial section so
I know what comes up ahead like it's not a big deal or anything like that and I
prefer paranoid myself you're always a good girl the whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
why am I getting... hold on a minute why am I getting praised out of nowhere
What do I do?
Not everything no everything but no human
Reminder stories. Whoa. Where's the print? Whoa. Whoa. You can't be doing this one
That's not fair. You know like to take me when I'm not prepared. Okay. That's not fair
That's cheatsy doodling don't cheat see doodle. Okay, Dr. Harper. I presume
You must be rider
Let's get you a day. You need to do something to prepare it. Oh, man. I mean you got you gonna get the guy give good
I'm sorry, I think people in there are prizes not punishments
I'm not here to make enemies
Then we'll get along just fine. Now, please go and assist. Oh
It's gonna be so weird doing the RDA side you listen noob
I need you to grab me some flora listen noob. You ain't afraid of a few carnivorous plants. Are you aren't afraid of a flower among friends
We aren't friends. Oh, you need to learn quick
Okay, geez Louise talk about being unfriendly around these part
Make her blush for every bad joke of today's stream. Honestly, it's been pretty rough
Right if I remember correctly, there's literally
Yeah, um, okay. I've just noticed that we have infinite ammo on this gun
One that's not how they work
to
Actually, it's a wee bit of a pet peeve the one. Oh, we should watch those kiana reeve movies because they have the ammo reload thing, correct
Um, how am I trying to say it?
Like in movies where they just like
With a pistol and like pistol literally have seven max like if you're talking like the m7
Or something like that. Why where are the enemies? I can hear them
Oh
Well, I did ask to see them and no I can see them loud and clear
Geez the cam. I'm stuck on something
Oh, geez. I need I need some space. I need some space in order to like actually shoot please game
If you're not gonna give me aim assist at least let me freaking shoot
All right
Oh
They sound like puzzle gum from viva paal. It's almost like they're based after flies
Wait, we're so
Johnson the babayaga
Wic yes that one we should watch those because uh lake heather actually accurate with the guns
It's very nice that they're accurate with the reading
I love the way john wick uses reloads to set the case for gunfights. I don't even notice that that's true
Unlimited ammo and mass effect cool joke
Oh
Someone said I might like mass effect
I've actually never played the series before but some said I might like it
I know he's called shepherd
That's about it. Oh, no, I don't need to do that at all. I'm getting confused
All the john wick movies are good. Yeah speaking of john wick. Have you played cyberpunk? No, I haven't
I watch
Cyberpunk but um
I am still absolutely heartbroken about rebecca. I am so sorry
is it
Her name is rebecca. What's the name of the?
The cyber
You're all with the rainbow hair. Is it lucy?
Is it rebecca and lucy like brotherhood? I'm getting brotherhood assassin's creep brother. Wait, it is rebecca and lucy
What the odds assassin creep brotherhood and
cyberpunk the anime
I am I am heartbroken over rebecca. I'm so sorry. I'm gonna see something so controversial
I have no comprehension
No comprehension on how rebecca just doesn't auto win like people are like, oh, let's see. Let's see this. Let's see
Lucy
Oh, listen, are you can you open your eyes and look at how perfect rebecca is?
I'll actually tell you some more development notes. Um
You don't have rebecca's voice
um
On the concept of icy obviously icy before icy, you know applied and all of that
We actually were quite happy to give icy to
a
Someone like that may have had a deeper voice because of rebecca from cyberpunk. So that's a fun
Behind the scenes. Um, I am not over rebecca. My first
True
I actually am interested in potentially cosplaying her for an ace more stream
Um, I think that would be a hoot and holler. Um, I won't show my face. Uh
I'd not
I'm not for that. Um
But I'm happy to do like
Nick down
Is the point. I'm going to take a sip of my honey tea to see if it's simple
But yeah, I don't know. Lucy everyone arguing about rebecca and lucy. I'm like, how is anyone looking at lucy?
rebecca's just peak like design everything. It's insane
Um
You know, it's a really sad detail if you haven't seen the cyberpunk anime close your ears for about two minutes
Um after no
No, I need to say this part out loud close your ears for two minutes
If you don't want spoilers about cyberpunk the anime the really sad fact is that rebecca
Got an upgrade to her hands after her brother died to the uh, the crazy guy because
Of the blowback she got from the shotgun
She never gets any root ricochet from shotguns anymore after that fact after that scene and it's such a sad fact
but yeah, um
Anyway, sorry back to the camp. Uh back to the actual gameplay
I'm just really passionate
The cyber cycle. Yeah, so the cyber cycle takes out her brother
But in that scene she shoots a shotgun at him and she goes backwards
And then after that moment her her her hand upgrades come in like her fisticuffs
Um, and she never experiences recoil when shooting weaponry. Um, and it's all because of that incident
And it's so sad
Um, but her design is just beautiful
Absolutely beautiful. What am I doing?
Yeah, let me drink my tea
The recoil so a little background on rebecca studio trigger was asked to change her because
Her design was too lollipop, but trigger went nah lollipops these
rebecca definitely influenced icys
creation with the hips area and the legs
I'm not even going to pretend otherwise at peak design. Sorry
I knew from the get go I wanted a troupe of tan, which is what emmy was and then icy
um
Is not troupe of tan
but
And but I did want her to have like the thickness of rebecca basically it is
I mean, I'm happy to talk about development. I know it's um
Like a zurra. We knew we wanted a charcoal and thick. So we've got a goddess and
Yeah, we just took it from there. Obviously. Um, sorry, let me finish this tea
Oh
Yeah
Adam sandler said you look like a cut of me. Are you wait in the game? I'm pretty sure that's from the game
I'm sure I've seen a clip of that game
Coming down with the
I'll actually tell you some other developmental notes, you know if I had a lighter voice
uh emmy
emmy's design and every in lore and everything if I had a lighter voice
uh
I would therefore be uh, um
I would therefore reflect if I had a lighter voice, but unfortunately I don't um, so, you know, uh, I take like the the big sister look approach
But yeah, uh, don't be surprised if an alternative outfits. Uh, I look a bit more true to myself. Uh, and I am
I suppose I'm a rebecca. How tall is rebecca?
Net away doing centimeters. Don't give me freedom units. I can't do freedom units
Um, but I guess rebecca's really very reflective. I think that's probably why I'm gravitated towards her so much as well
Uh, because I'm just like hey like I just love her
I'm gonna leave for the night. So here's your bro teeth brushing. Yes. Thank you
So burping my I'm gonna burp my teeth if I'm not careful. Hold on a minute. Um
Although I'm just gonna check how far away my my delivery is of my macs
My cheeky mac is any any mac at you enjoyers?
um
Oh
It's still on its way freaking driver at the restaurant always driver at the restaurant
It's never drivers picked it up and it's already on its way. It's always at the restaurant
Just hanging about waiting for a second freaking order
I know that shit's gonna get here cool
The version 2.0 update they did on smash her with
He needed the update who's smash her
She's 145 150. Oh, I'm too tall for rebecca then
Oh, I need to get at that to the cymbord
For now, I'll just use my
Hey, Adam smash her
Oh, the the guy that says the quote she's around 152 wait. I'm out. No. I'm not. I'm 16. Okay
Okay, take rebecca and make her slightly taller. Oh my god me. She's so me for real for real
She's so me for real
Behold how tall is she streaming on out?
Oh, no, it's time
We're the baddies
He said the b word
Wait, why the stuff that let's put the the b word together
Oh
I'm sad. I don't know what to expect from here on out though
Strongly told rebecca calls
honestly
Is that what you're here for?
Right. Oh, we can't skip this cut scene. I'm gonna do it
The donations are broken again. Are they actually great work, right? I smell promotion in the air. Wait, pay pay pal book
Better not have think about what you're telling you guys haven't given me so much money. It's broken again
wait, that's
Have you broken it again? Be honest where the navi be honest
There's a page not load
I like the edits of john wick and cyberpunk so funny of him see yes. Oh my god
I wanted to do that with the girls debuts, but I don't have time
I have the highlight
There are currently two out of six highlight debuts
Created so far
And i'm so excited
Uh mercies and azuras, but i'm going to release them all at the same time
Uh, but mercies and azuras have been made and
The rest are on the way. It's so exciting
It's loading but not going through. Wow. I really is broke. Wow
Uh, thanks again for breaking uh donation
I really like that pause as well
It's now or never we're the baddies
Let's do it right now right now
Well, this is it. This is it
We're doing it. We're the baddies
We'll just spam them down I guess
I'm missing because of the hit marker
Please don't heal don't make this harder than it has to be unironically because I'm not I feel bad
I picked the woman's
I didn't think that was possible. I can't have you broken it twice hold on
You feel
Wait, what happens? No, I can't be a navi like I'm a fully human like I'll never be able to come back in the
Wait, it worked
Wait, so it does work
Thank you for the tip. No, I don't know what to respond to that
Maybe uh
Uh, what wait, so it does work. Maybe just time and yoke because it's
It works in fire folks
Anyway, you don't actually have to tip or donate or anything into the work, but thank you very much
We just got annihilated by a banshee. Jeez
Oh, well, we all saw that move into frame, but hey, who?
Okay, this is actually quite different. I thought he was just gonna
Wow, I didn't even know
We don't have to but we want to give her
Oh my gosh, okay
Well, we survived a helicopter crash and an attack from an akran
Are you all right?
I think I'm okay, but the pilots banged up pretty bad
The radio's fried too
You've got to go for help. There's an rda mining camp a few mikes from here. I'll stick the pipe into my can
Don't worry. I'll be fine. I've got a full clip any vultures come home
I'll have to go out on my own
No, I don't want to go out on my own. I'm scared
Have I got new oh wait, so is this my wardrobe change? Oh, I literally is it's just more armor
Mmm
I'll just follow the HUD. This has to go this way. What is she shouldn't she shouldn't?
Oh, she is oh things can attack me from the sky as well
Wait, these aren't recycled maps at all
No, the plants I'm scared. Wait, I can't have a limit on what I like
All right
Is it maybe the head is gonna take more damage?
I don't I don't know
Flamethrowers are effective against all plants that have one. What's this gun?
Oh, they'll have a flamethrower. Oh, I'll have infinite pistol. Okay. Okay
I have to show my shooting skills
literally
I thought they were just gonna recycle all of the maps, but this is like an entirely new side of the game
I know this sounds so silly, but I just assumed they recycled the maps and like
Oh, oh, I'm claiming that all right
Uh
Okay, I can do it
Okay, I've got more ammo
Do these
Do the ikran
Okay, I get I get points for just uh, I'm so tiny. I'm so small
I can't even I can't even see over the freaking ground to see the enemy
Oh my gosh, give me more ammo. Oh
Please stop spawning in I need to heal. Hold on
Right, we're doing a biz
Oh, there's one over
I can do I can do I can do I need a level up so quick so I can just keep spamming that run
Oh
I'll need oh, there's so many plants in the way as well. Oh, they're back again. They're back for more. There we go
I'm so tall. I'm so small. I'm the opposite of tall
Oh, I can't do it. I'm actually sweating right out
There is so
Can I make it through the poison without having to destroy them all the time?
Oh, please keep your ink to yourself
What are these?
Are these bombs? Oh, there's a I think the pretty I don't the purple have health. I think they're
Uh
Uh, well, there's no secret behind this waterfall lake and legend is Zelda
Right, let's try that again. I didn't know me. Yeah, I didn't know me to the oh goodness me
Using vehicles and amp suits will be your friend. Okay, so I can go in the suits
Oh
Moby heart, right. Let's try that again without doing that
No running
Just shoot. Wait, are you not responding? Can I respawn or my game already broke?
All right, hold on
Hold on. I think my delivery app just uh, just oh, oh my delivery
Hold on. We've got a food delivery. Is that gonna swipe for me?
I have the health bar
Hold on. Let me go at the front door
So
Hello, oh, there we go
I'm not doing a thing
I'm back. Oh, we forgot it. Okay. I'm glad that thing doesn't slip down and like take my freaking eyeballs out my skull
Rather terrifying my mcdonald ray. I've got chicken nuggets for everyone open your mouth go
Wow I've got uh
It is the uh freaking how you call it this the thingy my bulbers
All right, yo, wait, yes, this is so bad for me
But if it's bad for me, why does it taste so good?
Well, it's like I'm gonna need to be so brave. I'm sorry. I'm so bad at this like
Hmm, you're having a sip of my chocolate milkshake. Yes, I'm literally having a chocolate milkshake at 9 a.m
And then nothing you can do about it
Is it cold you bet your ass it's cold because that guy was sitting at a flipping restaurant for ages
Okay, um, I would tab out to read any
Marshmallows, however the game breaks when I do that. So, uh, I'm just gonna read chat and munch away
Uh, so, uh, please if you don't like munchin sounds emmy's live. She's live, but me. I'm a munch in your ears
My it's my my
I'm having a beer at 7 a.m
I will enjoy my new things are they just spicy nuggies so I've got spicy
And mukbang time honestly
More headpats for the most adorable cutlery
Okay
Hopefully I don't mess up too many times actually doing the RDA campaign, but I have to admit it's like terrifying
I had no I thought the maps were going to be the same and I was like, okay
At least the maps are the same and I'm familiar with the paths. Nope
Hmm
I don't they apparently sold 2.7 million copies of this game
Yeah, that seems really low for like any game. I feel like that does that mean it flopped, you know
Mm-hmm, I'm gonna inspire people to get a McDonald's breakfast at this rate
Do it
A little hard in America they do 24 hour breakfast. So I'm jailed if I have to admit
You still think the tips are slightly broken or you're getting limited. Oh
Hey
I'm not sure
That
Last tip did come through. I wonder why that would be maybe reach every region locked
No, that seems silly. That's the answer
I don't like break I don't like the breakfast menu of most fast food places. I'd rather try it for my main menus on
I know it sounds weird, but I love to make some nuggies a salad and put them both together
and wheat wrap
and yogurt that just sounds like uh
um
What's that Greek thing? Where's the chicken in a wrap?
I've completely not a kebab, but like a it's not different
Be right back in 10 minutes. Bye. Bye. See you shortly
um
a gyro
Fun fact gyro means to be on benefits in scotland
Uh
I'll I'm gyro. Okay gyro is Greek. Oh, but it's with pork. Okay. Okay. Oh
It's pronounced hero then why did the fannies put a g in front of it?
We've got them we've got them in 4k has that dropped a chip on me
Oh, it's um, it's gif
It's not a jiff. It's a gif. I don't know why jiff started
And if your name is jiff
Um, or should I be like, oh congrats if your name's jiff because it sounds like jiff
I don't comprehend where jiff came from unless it was from non native english speakers. That's the only like
um
Thingy, I don't know why it is a thing obviously. It's funny in internet culture, but why is it jiff?
I know jiff literally
Wow
My name is jiff. I feels good ma'am honestly
Literally g and gif it's also there's a thing in um
The uk it's a shop called pray mark. Okay. It's like a clothes shop. It's like
And it's called pray mark, but folks say it pre mark
And the folk that say it pre mark. I'm talking to you right now directly
Do you say primary school or do you say primary school?
You say primary school. So the shop is called pray mark and I will not like let's oh
Uh, congrats if your name's mark by the way
Oh
I don't know why
It's a debate in the uk
Pray mark
It's the same one pre mark. No, it's no it's pray mark primary school pray mark
Hi to all marks. Yeah. Hi mark. Hi
Congrats if your name's mark
Also jiff is a peanut butter company. Is it?
Okay
our peanut butter and
And jelly sandwiches actually is tasty
As american movies make it out to be because all kids unanimously in tv shows have a a pv and j
Is it actually that good or is it being hyped up as I choke on my food?
It's a comfort food. Yes, it's okay. She seems to think so. Okay. She be's word is law
Yes, it's overhyped. Yes. It's an acquired taste. It's good yet pv and j's good
They can't be it's okay diabetes in a sign language
Ha
Absolutely, they're a good tree. Okay. It's a tree kind of not like a everyday thing
Hmm
I skip the jelly and only the peanut bar
I've tried the jar ones. It's
Pretty okay, but just okay
It's a thing they are raised on so as a result. They love it. Hmm
I suppose like iron brews my example if you don't drink iron brews a kid, you'll never have a taste for it
It's so bizarre and flavor
It's like that and
Japanese natto
fermented soybeans is a breakfast thing
apparently if you are a back-of-guy gene
and
You like it's really hard to enjoy natto unless you like force yourself to eat it over a while and then you get used to that
Yeah, like it's hard it's hard to get into it. Hmm
Hmm
Remember the old commercial from it made from
Gerders
It's cheap as heck and that's why we eat it so much
I've had peanut butter toast and banana and it's delicious. It's very nice
What's iron brews supposed to taste like they advertise it as ginger and bubble gum
It tastes like battery acid. That's the only
explicable
Way that you can see what that orange liquid tastes like it's battery acid, but nice
Hmm
Literally mountain juice the closest you'll ever get to
That it's just not positive. Sorry. I'm trying to eat and talk and I want to eat the food as fast as possible
So I'm not holding up the gameplay too much. Hmm. I take a drink from my chucky milkshake
Hmm, they forgot to give me a straw. So I'm literally just drinking out of it like some animal
Hmm do you see mountain dew yes, I said mountain dew
Oh dude, no
Mountain dew mountain dew mountain dew. Oh, whoa, that's so close
Mountain dew. Whoa, you can't tell the difference when I say that
Oh, that's crazy mountain dew
Whoa, it sounds like I'm saying Jay, but I'm no
I'm saying you
Oh, that's so cool
Did you drink my manju? That's weird
Hmm, okay, I didn't know I said a little kind on here now literally
Did you drink my manju?
Wow, why does it sound like that? I can hear it. No, dude. Do you?
Did you drink my mountain dew?
Dew
Yeah, I've tried my Andrew. I don't think it tastes like I'm brood. No, but it's only the closest thing
As a German, I feel not good here. Monka is bro
love
To do a drop of dew and to do that's all the same pronunciation
You now have a new earworm enjoy
All right, I've got two more nuggies left and then I've got this like burger McGrittle thingy
I don't know what it's called. It's called McMuffin. Well, we call it McMuffin, but I think it's called McGrittle
Mountain dew was originally made to be a mixer for whiskey
I don't know when I'm gonna do my first like drunk stream
I'm down for drunk karaoke, but I would have to rest my voice a day before
I was very nervous about it like the first time I ever did it, but now I know that
I'm not hitting them notes. So I'm gonna go for I'm gonna send it
Mmm
The original Coca-Cola had cocaine in it. Honestly, I just know that
It would just have been such a good time to be drinking that stuff, you know what I'm saying
Mmm
I'm sure I learned as well that, um, what did I learn that they used to prescribe like, um
I was a heroine they used to prescribe that if you were feeling rough back in the day
The drunk stream would give a hundred percent a hundred out of 10 bar, but I'm sorry
Here in brazil come to brazil many restaurants serve nuggets with creamy cheese or green green sauce
What would green sauce consist of would be some sort of veggie blended up
I would do cheese sauce definitely. Sorry, I'm looking my fingers like an animal
Most of the nasty addictive drugs started as medicines honestly like they were just having a good time back then
I just choked. Um, I don't know if you've ever heard about this guy called Sigmund Freud
He was absolutely wild and with his theories, but he was also highly addicted to
and um
Like a lot of his stuff got discredited, but like as time progresses, he gets proven right again and again
Also, there is the oh my god, this looks fucking awesome. I'm gonna take a big juicy bite for you
I went out yesterday after stream to get those american sweets
um
The lady was so nice. She was like, oh, can I help you anything?
and i'm just like
Anything american you've got
That's like smaller packaging
I would love to take away with me because i'm just gonna taste it all
And she was like so nice and helpful, but she was so surprised with how much i'm buying
And I didn't want to be like, oh, i'm rooting them on a stream and all that. I was just like, I'm just really passionate about american sweets
I'm like
Hmm
I'm on paw independent shop that I supported
And
I'm gonna inhale another bite. This is good. Yeah. Sorry. That is that's just what I imagined like a murky. Oh, any moment. Yeah
Oh
They used to prescribe they used to prescribe smoking at people we asked them off. That's terrible. Okay, go on a brother
You got a pretty accurate spread of my well, like I put the picture in the discord for the girls to rate it
and I told them
I spent 53 dollars getting all of that stuff and they were like you got absolutely scammed
Like that's not even worth 12 dollars. I'm like, oh, okay
But um, I'm gonna make a little
Rate thing
um
Like where I rate them
So hopefully we'll do a fun little chart. I don't know if i'm gonna like anything
I think i'm interested in this was it spicy cheetos ago or a spicy thingy or the or tackies or whatever
I always hear about tacky
um
And
Hmm
It was rough, but like i'm gonna support like a wee independent shop. So
Eat the chips last it's overpowering. Okay. Okay. Okay. We're getting the strats. Thank you mayor
See for the strats
Are you streaming the day? Well we team minus well less than four hours for mercies. Use your start time
I
Don't know what don't I thought dr. Pepper was in the uk but
I think i'm confusing it with pepsi. I genuinely can't remember if i've ever tried dr. Pepper if it's an american thing
Oh, you're playing that climbing game. I remember the thumbnail
Because we had your skirt was open. So we had to close your skirt
Honestly, maybe that should be a toggle for you. No, i'm not. Maybe we should toggle that so you don't have to worry
Dr. Pepper isn't the okay. I've just never tasted it before literally i'm brewing cola
I used to be a fan of fiend and a sprite fiend as well
But fan i was like addicted to so much
I do have an american dr. Pepper so at least i can stay true to the the task at hand not my open skirt, honestly
Then you can accidentally toggle on and off and stream true
The only person who worries for receiving followers aim
Dr. Pepper taste dr. Pepper taste kind of cola with with mint mint mint fizzy juice
I'm not sure mint fizzy juice is gonna go down well with me. I do apologize
I just remembered i'm not sure another brazilian already took it first
So i'll do it myself come to brazil cutlass congrats. You're the first one to do it
Come to brazil
I don't think i know any
Plus so tell a bae
Plus so tell a bae is all i can say
I'm almost finished i'm so sorry for those who are waiting on the gameplay
I think dr. Pepper tasted medicine
mint
Not like cinnamon. Sorry not ice cream soda just cream soda
Dr. Pepper's cherry cola
Hmm
The guys see the online discourse about the ingredients in like american food versus like any other country
And like so much stuff has been banned
Hmm
Hey, scrawny did you know that mint and spacy can be active at the same time in your mouth try it in your experience heck
Mint and spacy
I've never even thought of that
It's like spicy water
It'll be interesting to see what you actually
Hmm
I think that other drink was a and w
Root beer. I think i got like creamy. I think it was cream soda or creamy soda a root beer root beer
No, root beer root beer
McDonald's you can check for ingredients big don's do you say 35 ingredients most of them are code numbers?
Oh, yeah american drinks for instance. They often use high fructose corn syrup and
What happens if I ingest high fructose corn syrup dialects explode? It's a dangerous
Hmm
No, kinder eggs
Actually, you know what's even sadder about the kinder egg ban the new realize
The only reason those children
Hmm past because of the kinder egg was because their parents weren't even paying attention to them
Which is such a wee shame like it's
Um out of everything
They have to ban it
Instead of being like hey here public announcement pay attention to your little ones because we didn't know
um
little ones explore
Using their mouth. That's why you can imagine literally licking any surface because you did it as a wee babby
It's an exploratory thing. You learn so much from it
Like for example if I tell you
To imagine what it's like licking a cold pole with rain
It's gonna sound i'm in danger. Why is it red? Why is it red? I saw that
I saw that I just entered combat there for a second
Monka is Monka is I saw that looks like I'm not watching your game
um
My HUD went red. I I'm covering up the HUD like with my big hair
But it went red which meant I was under attack there. So I don't know what just happened
The kinder the American kinder egg man is real if I was a mean no I feel
Oh
Is that also why there's no toys in the cereal I never even thought about that
Oh flew into my cross here
Okay last bite
Last bite. I'm gonna go get a cola actually
I wouldn't mind a cola after that just to really really make sure my health is really bad
McDonald's and cola why not
Oh
My god my headset
My headset just moved in a flinch. I don't think I was getting attacked in real life
Yes, Louise
I'm farming the dump it on
Ain't swallows before a choke. Hold on a minute
Oh
Okay cola time have a little sip of cola with the edge. I'll try and have a little bit more of that milkshake
Yucky milkshake
Right, I've probably got a big burp generating because I've just eaten so I do apologize
Unless you want me to get out of the way in there
Mm-hmm, so I can have a sip you absolutely can't have a sip of the cola
Oh, so how's the Nutella seen in your countries?
Uh as Nutella
Although I know in the Belgium they have these like adorable little self-serve size Nutella
I don't know where the burp is it's hiding in me, right?
Right. I'm a big girl
I'm a big girl. I can just ignore literally everything
Nutella is on a cracker honestly. Oh, there we go. It's all coming up now
Make it stop make it stop. Right. I think that's it
Okay, there we go
No, they're never in it right. I'm not running off the map this time
Whoa, that was a joke
I don't like oh I got 50 for that one is it because it was multiple in a row
Oh, there's another one for you. It's all coming up. No, it's all coming up
Yeah, we're
Where are we going?
Where are we going? No one's no one
Kaka kaka combo breaker
Bonus one breathe in have a big whiff. I go
Mmm delicious. Oh my goodness. What is this? What is this?
Can I fly it out in those helipads? It looks like it
Whoa, they swoop that actually have to be careful of them. No, our guys are just tolerating their presence over here
Wow
So I can use the bikes to get a boot
Okay, okay. Boom. Okay
Oh
Thought some marmite. I've actually no had it. What is going on in here? Hello. Oh, this is like a proper facility as well
Who the hell are you?
Chopper went down over that ridge and my team's still back there. I need a new bird. How are you so perfect?
You've landed in a bloody hell all night
Banshee's been killed by men, but thanks for the constant
I've not tried it. No our vagemate. No
She's fueled up better firing circuits of fries because everyone's given it such a terrible review
I'm like, I don't really want to spend money on it just to like have a wee dip
Look around they destroy my paper. You don't have to tell me
That's the weird. Oh, that's the weird thing because you are okay. You're timing the blush or something. Hmm
Um, actually, I should probably you know, I've paid a lot. I'm not gonna lie. I've paid a lot for all these emotes
Uh, yeah, man's not using them. Like I'm just I'm just a bad
I'm just a bad streamer. It's fine. It's fine. We'll work. We'll do a thing
But like I'm not being funny. How am I supposed to be mid game? And then like someone goes good girl and I'm like, all right
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on pause pause the game. Let me just uh, oh
Like I mean you can hear it in the flexion of my voice. Okay
God, it will send a ger a vegemite if you
We were discussing should we have p.o boxes
But I said to the girl like it's just far too dangerous on this day and age
Like with trackers and stuff and there's been so many streamers
Oh
Oh, that's how to go up. Oh, right. Okay. I'll go up like this. Whoa. Whoa
Uh, how do I move? Oh, this is awful. Oh
Hold on. Oh my god. This is how to go up go up
Oh, this is awful. This is even worse. This is even worse than riding. Oh, no. Oh, no, the flowers are mean
Oh, this is not gonna end well. I'm not gonna end alive in this. I can just tell
Hold on. Uh, right. Just bear with me. Bear with me
Icy's in the room because bear with me. Holy. No, don't get me out. Can I land like right now? How do I land? Okay
Okay, let's get out. That was awful. I was literally having to say blame that
That was terrible. Don't recommend
Oh, he perished the banshees are pretty hairy out there. You're gonna need the chopper missile online
Grab new firing circuits from the samson ruckage
I'm sure regiment wouldn't be considered a bio weapon
And uh
Oh unlock new outfit or new perks upgrade and perks already. Okay
Okay, I'm starting to understand why that supersonic thing is the one because they gang up so quickly
Yeah, can you reload please? There's literally an invisible one. He's cheating. Oh my goodness
Oh
Oh, where is he? I hear him
You don't feel that
No, you don't feel that that didn't hurt. I know even a little bit
Jesus
Jeez Louise right what am I doing here?
What am I doing
Am I to search the craft or something? Oh, okay
Kendra save me Kendra
Kendra
Kendra, please start shooting Kendra
Kendra Kendra
I know you can see me spraying and praying for my life right now Kendra
Oh Kendra
The biggest pet peeve if you give an enemy that can shoot an ally that can shoot but they aren't doing nothing
Wait, am I safe? No, geez. Can I enter the cutscene or am I about to get like absolutely mugged in the cutscene?
Give me
No wonder only two people have played this
That should clear up the skies and help Kendra. Hey, you've got help. Nah, I got this
Where are you going? She just stands there watching me
I want to check out
Oh, no people box. I'm just have to send money to shoot money instead. What a shame. Uh-huh. Whoa
What we doing?
Wait unlock again. Is this like super easy to level up as an rda?
Hmm
Right i'm to use
The helipad
Over the heck I put it did I leave it? Whoa who parked it? Who driving this aircraft? This is terrible park
How to go up? Oh my god, this is awful
Whoa
Hold on
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Okay
Oh my god, this is awful. Oh, wow. Whoa there. I'm getting bombed
Pandora
Pandora like super strong and I whoa, whoa, whoa
Can I like shoot that one from here?
This is awful. I'm so sorry the controls are not like straightforward with this
I'm just trying to see if I can spray you. No, I'm not hitting. Oh, this is terrible
Close your eyes. Don't look mercy. Don't look you're gonna vomit
I don't really want to get hurt by that, but I think I'm gonna have to
Oh
I'm out of like the render distance for it, but there we go
Where's the next one?
Wait, there's one behind me apparently. It's right behind me uh nest
Where oh, whoa, whoa easy easy easy easy
Oh
Wait, so I can like actually die in these choppers
Oh my god
Oh, did I do it? No, I got you now
Get me out of this like right now seriously
Go up and then go forward a bit and up and forward and up and forward and up and forward right just up
And then we'll go just forward. Okay
Easy easy on the tilt. Why are you it's literally tilting me? I don't know why insist on tilting me
Squishy human versus navi with their carbon fiber reinforced bones. Honestly. Oh my god. I just missed the helipad as well
Oh, let me sit down
Get get me out of that. I'm gonna vomit if I'm in that any longer
You guys can deal with the freaking bad guys because I'm just absolutely rubbish get me inside
You have rockets. Oh, I didn't know. Okay, that might be a little bit easier
I'm holding on good girl. Wait. Why are we thinking?
Must be because everything wants to hurt you here
Wounded are in down
Commander palco is ready for you. All right. How's the game so far?
We've completed the navi and we're doing the bad bad human side now
I'm going to keep this simple, but I don't know what to expect
I'm pretty scared of that because I've never played this side
This project starts with you our signal specialist
This is the sector you're currently in. We need you to go to these three ports
Once there, you must collect small shards of unoptenium
Oh, right. So we're literally doing
Directly the opposite. I mean that makes sense
But right now just get those three unoptenium shards. Don't worry too much about the details, writer. We don't have a lot of time
Okay
Good Falco out. You heard the man. You need to
Okay, yeah, I have a few questions. All right. I'm out
Uh, honestly, I'm like leveling up so much. I don't know I can call him. I've got weapons up for it as well
It's trying to hate humans
We are not human
And you make it a lot harder for yourself than it has to be
Hey
Look, I'm no very smart. Okay. All right. I think that one will have full health. Where am I? Am I flying? Oh, I'm
Is that flying?
That has to be flying. There's no way I can do that on foot. Sorry. There's no way right who's ready to get motion sick
me
Okay, let's first turn to the first wait, what one's closest? Yeah, that one is closest
Okay, first let's get hate so we don't bump into the walls or anything
Is this the ceiling of the game is wow, we're already at the ceiling. Okay, uh
Sorry ceiling of the map. My apologies. Hold on
Whoa, this is like humongous. What? Um
Oh my god, this is so much harder than driving an ikaran
Am I looking for
We're dead plant we're dead part. You know, you guys don't have a helipad here
Oh, there's navi down there. Oh, I'm gonna get rolled by them. Hold on. Wait. I can see transport over here
Which makes me think it's safe to put down the chopper here
I don't know if that's true, but we'll try it. Oh my god. We're about to go against navi for the first
Oh my god, that's horrifying
Oh my god
That's horrifying
Oh, I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like it. I don't like it. They're so big
They're genuinely so big
Oh my god, I don't know what to do. Is this a sniper shot?
No, this is a shotgun. Oh my god
Okay, it's a shotgun. Oh, he's using a billy
Oh, this is awful. This is
Okay, I'm a big girl. I'm a big girl. I can do it
Okay, it's fine
I can hear noises
I can see I'm getting shot at but it's okay. I've got oh, you're so big
Okay, okay, okay two two shorties and dead
I hear you I hear you
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. No, no, don't stop. Look you stun lock me. I'll stun lock you
Oh, not now
Okay, okay, okay, okay, it's okay. Okay. Let him get up. Let him get up. Let him get up. Let me reload
Great
Oh
Whoa, they just keep coming
Oh my gosh, golly
What does the cell samples do? Do they not give me ammo? I'm gonna run out of ammo
I'm just gonna have to I think I'm just gonna have to go for it
If they come at me, I'm just gonna have to deal. I can hear them respawn in the corner of my ear. I'm no bother
I'm no bother. I'm sorry
Oh
Oh, that's awful. That's horrendous. That's truly awful. I'm sorry that that height difference is freaking me out
They're like so long and elongated from this movie. Where'd I go? Where'd I go?
Oh, they never told me this was a freaking horror game
Oh
Oh, right, okay, I'm going the completely wrong way, but no I need to go back
No, I don't know I don't because the cave's freaking collapsing
I don't like that. They're so tall and lanky
I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like I don't like I don't like it. I'm so tall. I'm so tiny
Oh
Please leave me alone. I'm so scared. Please leave me alone. Please leave me alone. Please leave me alone
I'm gonna have to pay. I don't want to
This is so freaking please. Please. Please. Please one shot one shot. Oh
Oh
I just need a aid from that guy. Is he the only one is he the only one I'm just going for it. Oh
Where's my heel? Okay, that was heel
Oh
Oh my god, like the creepy whispering in my ears and helping either now
Who freaking said do that in da scene? I want to be tall. I want to have third perspective work and actually see the enemies over the grass
Oh, they're everywhere
They need to be eradicated. I can't handle this. I'm the buggies going everywhere. Please. Please work with me
Am I going the wrong way?
I'm just gonna have to come back for it. I'm sorry. I'm going to the other one. Oh
This is awful
This is horrible
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. It's relaxed here. See look there's no baddies. Oh this game's so fun
See
Okay, yeah, we're going the right way. Oh look how relaxed this is see nothing's attacking me
That's game's fine
I can I can handle the dogs. I cannae handle the navi. They're too tall
I don't mind that right, okay
Excuse me just coming through this holy site with a buggy
I need
a shard
To keep myself from harm the navi are absolutely terrifying
And the kills I need to farm
They've no got a chance
Okay, wow, it's actually quiet for once a Christmas mark
Of course they spawn in of course they spawn in of course they spawn in the moment. I try and achieve anything
I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I'm actually stuck. Jump! Jump forward!
Goooo
I don't know where to go. I can't see anything and I'm getting barraged right now
Okay, leave the buggy behind leave the buggy behind. We don't need it. We don't need it
Oh
This is gonna be a really rough four errors. I'm gonna be honest. I'm like, oh, please don't unclog
Please don't unclog. Please don't unclog. Please do not unclog
Please don't unclog
I don't want to unclog for the navi or le
I'm getting spanked
And no the good things
Oh my god. Oh my I'm getting gang violence. Come on. Right. Right. That's it. That's it. Ah
I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying. They all have abilities and they're all freaking ganging up on me and I don't even know what's behind me
There's more behind me
Hey, they're
How are you supposed to play this the rda side? Honestly
Freaking I'm just happy to see a plant. I don't mind if it wants to freaking do that to me
I'm I'll welcome it over these freaking giants
Then there's like 12 of them behind me
I'm making this the most freaking stressful game experience of my life
Oh
I can't handle this
Can I get like knee surgery to elongate me so I can at least see a little better where it's like going
Oh
No, you're no you're not even scary dogs. It's the navi that are terrifying
It's absolutely horrific. Hi pimples. Hi to me
I'm currently playing this horror game cause jame cameron avatar
It's absolutely mortifying. Wait, there's a helicopter there. Do I want to take it? No
I think I'll just take the car
How is your unlisted stream or archived stream?
With pin pals, was she being was she behaving?
Was she behaving?
Oh, you guys have her oh she mark
I'm ignoring all the navi couldn't give less of a rats orce. What's going on?
Oh, there's dogs everywhere as well. What is bombing me?
No and vizgo
Oh
I can't do this my wee heart can't take this where I'm supposed to go
I'm supposed to go all the way back right. I'm going to take that helicopter
And we can get the heck out here and we've done one of the four shard collection missions
I assume it's just going to copy the previous
um
Tactics. Hi. Hi. I'm me currently playing a horror game right now. It's awful
It's terrible
Oh
We did homework and brushed teeth. Oh, did you actually we're brushing your teeth, too
Is this gonna be another 12 hour stream no, it's gonna be eight hours if I don't die too much
I have successfully completed the navi storyline in this game
I'm having to go below because the map isn't letting me go above
Is this a dead end?
I'm not safe anywhere
Genuinely not safe anywhere
How do I do my bombs?
I don't know how to do bombs
You say I have bombs but nothing oh, wow, I do have bombs. Okay, well
Whoa, whoa, I need to go up. Holy crap. Can you go up so we can get like a bird's eye view on these?
Oh for goodness sake, where can I land there's navi everywhere
I can't believe it. There's people everywhere that live here
Oh, this controls are awful
I missed the falcon from halo and literally I'm getting wrecked and decked because of controls
Great, I need to destroy that ikram that's there. I don't know
I'm screaming but I think I'm at a render distance or something
Okay
This is terrible. Oh my god. This is awful. Can I fly in here? Excuse me? Pardon me coming through. Excuse me
All right, just land just land. This is awful land
It won't let me land. I can't believe it won't let me land in the tiny freaking
Right a crayons get my face
Right everything's getting annihilated. I think they're just right right. I think there's a landing spot over here
This is my guess because of the map. I know you can't see it because my big head's covering it up
Just just freaking get out of this thing. No get out. How do you get out? Hello?
Hello can I get out? I'm stuck. I'm stuck in this freaking chopper
Get in my face honestly
I need somewhere to park but I'm about to park next to all these freaking navi that ready to demolish my boss
Okay, there we go. There we go. We're actually out of success
I am
Playing the lovely game of please ignore me
And we're getting the heck out here and we're just absolutely speedrunning these because these are horrifying
Shawnee doesn't know what she's doing only
Wait, I'm probably really wrong
Where the heck did you come from?
Identify yourself she
I killed all yous on purpose and you've all respawned
Ah
Eat lead
The archers are probably the worst because they can pin me
At least
Oh
I know that other ones around the freaking corner. Yeah. Yeah, no way that still hit
Can you guys stop using your abilities? I honestly do not remember the soldiers even this amount of
Abilities are all
I'm getting
And another one's just one
Follow the same vibrations
I'm not the only one that can use oh wait, you're not the only one that can use freaking abilities around here
Again aggressive. Oh, here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Right triangle time triangle time
Oh, this patch of dirt looks a bit different. I wonder if it was here
Where's the triangle somewhere over here? Oh, this patch of dirt looks slightly different. Okay, we did it
I played like two minutes this game back and then dropped it. Yeah
um
You have to play the navi side for it to be and remotely rewarding if you want to play a horror game
Feel free to uh
Oh
Midori how nice of you to show up
When uh, you could have done that like five minutes ago and help them some firepower
But why is on fire? Or is it just supposed to be dirt?
She's becoming wild i'm becoming the very thing I swore to destroy
Whatever keep going
All right, we've leveled up so do we get more armor?
Got yeah more armor. Thank you
Wow my reward for uh, whoa, whoa, whoa, you ain't taking me with you
I got hurt by that
Hey, the name's Trudy Chico. Hi Trudy
Falco's assigned me to make sure you don't go tango uniform on me
T you
Means you're safe with me. So let's get air to you. I ain't getting paid by the hour
Is that supposed to be the actual character?
Fighting for humanity isn't easy. No, it's not
Oh, okay. I don't even know that's good for that tea tea up any tea uppers
Freakin horror game honestly
Who said play this
Hydration check
Slipping tin of some sort of liquid doesn't really matter what it is at the end of the day
Oh, sorry. I've just why are you going to the side? I don't know but i'm drinking all horrible
She's just really enthusiastic about the wall. Oh, okay, little cheeky camera. I don't know why you're doing that
But I hope that's not joy con drift. Oh, oh, that's what I should name the gamer
If we ever had a 2.0 model joe con drift with an eye with the joy
Oh, I need to like a wink sound like a whee every time i wink it goes wheezy
Hello, ah writer you brought me the first harmonic. Let's get started. I still got some time before the emulator's up and running
The emulator
Ah, you don't know yet all in good time
Right now we need to upload that harmonic pop it into the module and let's see what we've got
Okay, sure
Here we go
What's happening now? What's all this stuff for doc?
Yes, let me explain the knobby have a unique relationship with the plan
Using a sacred site the tree of sorrows. They're able to link directly with the ecosystem
It's how they communicate with the entire class, but we're searching for something different
Our research tells us that there is another site that can help us sever the knobby community
You're after a site is undead for thousands of years
I place the knobby call the well of sorrows
If we can find this old door, this is why they aren't letting you name any more car. Honestly, I know
I'll never live down front of the bosom
But honestly we can take control best name. This is where your harmonics come in right?
We don't know where this dormant site is so the harmonic helps you find its location
I'm actually enjoying these cutscenes because I've never seen them before
We can triangulate the precise location of the dormant well of sorrows. Now. Let's see what your first harmonic shows
Excellent, did you notice the red dots? No, those are supposed to be a cutscene
With each harmonic, we'll reduce the number of red dots to the end of one. And number one, we'll be our well of sorrows
Do you agree with this plan?
Indeed. Now I'm finished. It's time to check in with Commander Falco for your next mission
I've got your next mission on deck
You're getting to the feeba officer midori will meet you at the top feeba a new area. They really didn't recycle any of the maps
She ain't no plumber. You'll be good with her
An escort. Oh my god, dug it help. Please. Please dug it help. I would love a freaking partner in crime
Those tree huggers are crying foul over this emulator all worried about
Monroe mentioned that what is this emulator? You stay focused on your mission writer
You start growing the conscience and you'll end up on the dead end of a navi spear
dismissed
Okay, okay
Falcon needs you to travel to feba
Hmm
That's where they made different maps for each one. I genuinely assumed it was just gonna be recycled. I can't believe it
I'm I'm I'm surprised
But we've picked up one song so we need
Two more songs and then I assume the third we destroy it or the navi destroy it before we get it
So it's like literally a complete 100
I could uh could flip. Yeah words and stuff. Um
Hello, please fly me to the flea ball. Let's hit the envelope. Just promise me no power
She really said no projectile woman
The feeba
Oh
I feel like I'm gonna be even more scared
Are you disappointed that they didn't reuse assets since you know the rda
Period no
I'm just a surprise. Like I just assumed the opposite was going to be same maps, but we're attacking from a different side, but
Uh
Well back into the free let's unlock the teleporter first and then get a sender voice from Kendra
That's what it was
I was I was wondering why the voice sense so familiar
Is a bad ass navi warrior and his men have kind of said they put so much effort into it. They didn't get much traction
There's an old conchak here. I'm heading over to I think in 2.7 million sales you made your money back though
So investors can't feel too bad. I think
I don't know if like avatar because when the movie came out it was like this big unexpected hit like no one expected it
How do I
Oh motion sick buggy. Okay warning for motion sick people
Oh, all right, where we go first take a right
far
Maybe to the
We'll go talk to the person however we need to obtain this quest from okay
No navi, please you guys freak me out to high heavens seriously
Oh in the plants even when I'm in the buggy
Oh my okay, okay, okay. It's like lamp posts in that one game
Oh, I didn't see it. It just came out of nowhere because it's the same color
Shade, okay. Let's just accept the mission first
Hello
And grunts left and right you can't grab any shard until we take it down
Oh I can hear a navi's bow and arrow behind me in this cutscene
But kill the hammerhead before
well
I do seem to be a level. I'm not real quick though. Can I get more armor, please courage pack
You know what? Whoa
I can hear that. Oh
Oh, I need like a long range gun
Oh
Come on in
Now let me relive before we do this. Oh our we go cutscene
I've heard really went nuts in here. Whoa
Wait
We don't even get to meet these in the navi side. I didn't even think they were in game
Oh
My god
I'm just so surprised about everything
Oh
Get back up are you joking me after that?
Is that me I hope that's not me and they're about to put me in the cutscene where it's right like gameplay where it's right in front of me
Thank goodness. I thought it was pranking me, man
We'll see what the deal here is
Oh come on
Why are you supposed I dashed to the side I need to get like vertical like right now
Holy moly, why is that only going for me?
I need is there like a rock I can hide on I need cheese on a rock like right now. I need cheese on this rock
I'm not even being funny
I need to like breathe on this rock. I need to cheddar the on this rock. I need to
Do anything on the rock. Please jump on the rock. It's all I ask. I'm so small. I can't jump on basic rocks. Okay
uh
Yeah, see this is why I don't even want to bother
I don't know why I just changed its mind. I am going to see if I can shoot from the spine over here
I can hear it get closer to me. I'm vertical though. What you gonna do about it? Nothing
Because you can't do anything when I'm vertical. I maybe okay. It seems like it can't come here
Oh, yes
Oh, I'm out of ammo already
Get ready. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. You got a lot closer that time
I am going to run out of ammo well before this thing perishes
Azura's just gone live
Okay, if anyone is interested Azura du Le is streaming
Whoa, can it hurt me? It can just stun me
I just put my hand on my head. I'm like, uh
Uh, I feel it. Oh Azura is playing one shot. Okay
Hey, Stormy. Do you think the notification discord could also post the girl's schedules would be helpful?
Um
Maybe I don't know
I'm like seriously have no ammo
Maybe it's a shotgun kind of thing. Wait, do I have more weapons?
So that's my wee shotgun, which does them up cool. So that's my standard rifle. That's what I'm talking about. Maybe change this to what
A nail hammer? Not that
Oh
What's that? Is it going down?
I don't know. His health doesn't really look like it's going down. I'm absolutely spraying and praying and I'm gonna lie
A motor strike maybe? Yeah, that probably seems much more likely because
This is like really
Uh, whoa. No, I press get me on that leaf
Get me on it
Hold on
How long? How do I summon the motor strike?
Uh
B
No, what am I trying to achieve?
It won't let me put down the strike for some reason
Uh
Wow, I just completely destroyed nothing. I'm so good at this game
She be she be finished? How was class of oh, man?
I mean, it's getting weaker, but I'm not probably doing something horrifically. Well, let's be honest a
Grenade launcher sure. Let's try that
Okay
I missed
Oh
No, I missed what she be says and I can't I can't back out the game or it's gonna break
She be she be raid. She's rascist. Okay. Well
Uh, I'm not sure what on earth occurred in class of 09, but as long as you guys had fun. That's the main thing. Uh
She was partying like the 1900s
You were you went to great
Jeez, that was awful that fight. I'm
To say I'm confused about that fight is an understatement. Honestly. I hope I don't have to do that get a flame for next time. Thank you
Don't listen to them
Is the harem telling fibbers are you telling fibbers about my wonderful daughters?
What's that noise you guys don't want to deal with that that that navi right there. No
Hold on. Let me reload with some parish in you
Okay, we're both as bad at aiming as each other am I so small he actually can't hit me. I'm sorry to think that's what's going on
Hey, thanks. I owe you and your boys
You have straight she be streamers funny as heck only came in at the end. I don't even know what happened
I'm just here for this here and won't snitch. Oh, okay
Well, for those of you who are comfortably joining in
Mercy modis is going live in t-minus three hours at the moment
We are playing a game known as James Cameron's avatar, which is childhood game of mine
We have finished the navi questline and now we are playing as the bad guys
I am absolutely terrified of genuinely fighting the
The navi and so
We are
Just trying our best to get through the questline as fast as possible with at least amount of spikes as possible
And uh, the the game has aged a little bit in terms of like, I don't know what they were thinking these camera angles and stuff
Why does that look like it's gonna wallop down on me as I go past it? I saw that I can that is horrific. I've not seen that
Oh, there's noises being made. Oh, there's navi standing up. Okay. That's why that's why
We're just gonna keep driving to objective and everything's gonna be all right and
We're totally not playing horror game simulator at all. Honestly. This is terrifying as a human
Oh, please. Let me roll you over. Please don't get back up again
Oh, please mr. Rocks. Don't ruin this. I don't want to fight the navi
They are absolutely horrifying and terrifying
To me. I'm not oh that car's gonna blow up. So I'm probably gonna have to walk on my feet
Where or what am I supposed to do?
Nope, you're friendly and I'm just shooting at you. Sorry. Sorry. I swapped teams. My bad. I swapped teams. Give me a second
Give me a second. What am I shooting at?
Right, let's get some. Oh, no, that's a grinny. Let's not do that
Oh, oh, wow. Uh, that actually landed the grinny blundered
Why
Why are you not registering?
The game's age should be a bit she we can do no wrong exactly the here and have been
Trained well clearly
Are they
Is there supposed to be a shard here?
I don't I think I'm maybe just to help them
Uh, I will
See like I'm confident as soon as I have allies literally I'm having people help me with these fights
Okay, so it's a it's a clear amount mission. This car is gonna
Oh
I sure wish it came sooner. Oh balance mid-match
What's the blue senderman?
Oh, that's probably I'm actually terrified of them. Good grenade. Honestly. I don't even know how that hit. I didn't. I wasn't even
Hey, Strani, what's going on?
Playing a game called James Cameron's avatar complete the navi side
We are now playing the rda, which are the naughty naughty bad humans and I am absolutely terrified every time I go against the navi
Because they are so tall and lanky and scary and their arms are so long and
Getting shivers just
Right, we've got we need one more crystal from this map and then we can already move on out here
Thanks for your help. You should know that your men didn't die for nothing. I'm gonna make sure of that
Yeah, well then don't get killed. That'll just piss me off more
Man said he's here for the count
This game actually looks well made for a movie game
Hmm
Uh, I don't want to really write that because literally gonna oh my god
But to take all of that on foot with all the navi is terrifying
Can I repair it and we'll get like a little bit? Oh, is it stuck? Okay, hold on
I don't want to run this guy over. So I'm just gonna
Just need to edge it out. Excuse me mate. Excuse me. There we go
This thing is gonna explode the moment I encounter a navi. I just don't know what okay. I'm already
All right, hold on. Hold on. Hold on
This is not gonna go well. I can already see myself perishing in like five seconds flat
This is just the camera angle. Why did they finally?
I was not even like explode out just perish
Well, let's not do that again, I guess
So I have to do this on foot and be absolutely mortified the entire time
Let me put on the protection spell
That was the dumbest thing I've ever seen. Don't ever do that again
Where is it protection? Right, so I have speed protection health and blend
I can do it
I'm big girl
I'm already level three on the abilities. So they're actually gonna last quite a long time
Right, that's okay. That's okay
I'm a big girl
And this isn't scary to me at all. I'm not absolutely terrified
And there's not a bit of pee ready to come flying out of me once I get jump scared
We're cutting it. We're cutting it short. We are cutting it short. I have to admit this thing's about to unclog
Okay, that's fine. It's just plants plants are allowed to expel that thing. I don't know what the heck it does
I feel like it's gonna slam down on me and I just want to confirm or deny
I get XP for destroying plants
No way that's so silly
I know how to farm now
Right, we just need to go in this uncharted territory. I'm sure it'll be fame and there's not tons of navi ahead
I'll need these
doing
Raider fleamin cart. I think
It's okay. It's okay
Okay, this is gonna last a good cheeky 10 seconds
five
six
seven
eight nine 10
11 12
13 14 maybe 50 15
20 20
Oh, oh, I've never been happier seeing a human. How's it going? Oh my goodness. Yeah, uh long day. Yeah
Okay, there's a little fight going on over there
uh
I'm wondering if I should farm the wildlife
You're a lifesaver
You're a lifesaver and face of maneuvers
Can't even explode the car that the higher ups
The vehicle license. Oh my god. Okay. We just run away from the same thing. Wait. These don't go for me
Even though I'm zoom in I am literally
Please
I did say please but I understand
Wait, wait, wait, wait, there's a tail look for survivors
We ain't looking good
Cleaning zenos for XT is always a perfect plan. Yeah, I'm thinking maybe if I find a turret I might try and level up
Hmm
If that hammerhead tells anything is that you ain't got enough damage for bosses monka ass
Are you implying there's a boss ahead monka ass?
Because I I don't I don't know
Stalker's valley
Oh my god, this is where mersey lives
Hey, wait, it's mersey morning and t-minus less than three hours
I have to go against the thana or
You rider. Oh, yeah, I think you were my ride. How can I help?
I'm fine, but you'll have to
Even navi had bosses like those dudes that took a lot of killing and imagine the reverse
What does monka ass mean? It's a twitch emote where you look really stressed out and like, oh, no, this doesn't look good
I'm gonna get that
I'm gonna go backwards and get this
and
Oh my god, why is it such a horror ambience? I'm not even being funny
Like the leaves shaking about the leaves are like so violently shaking about whoa, what what?
What is going on?
You're getting jumped by a pack of wolves you'll be okay
Hmm
This I cannot wait to get through this and let it be over because this is just
This is too much from a little heart can hardly take a a desert guy
They perish. Oh my yeah, this is
How am I supposed to achieve anything?
Oh
I'm a standing in plant poison. They're spitting bile at me
Bro, I'm sorry. I'm gonna need to like literally get a co-op mode right now so you guys can carry me through this
You're not even shooting the plant. What are you trying to achieve?
Oh forget it
We hate nature
literally what
It seems like there's more soldiers placed everywhere though
Maybe to help you through it just because they know they made it a bit harder
With the plant and the wildlife and the navi ganging up on you at least like when you're navi only
a little bit of the wildlife gang up on you and that
Oh
Yeah, we definitely need the freaking oh my is that friendly bombs
None of those plants spank
Oh, okay, okay, okay, it's fine
Kind of fine
This is just a slaughterhouse
This is absolute chaos
Chaos with the a ch. Whoa what got me
It made me jump like the opposite way that you were
Geez Louise right there's a sloppy a sloppy plant up ahead
Actually, we need to play cameo because these plants remind me of flicks from cameo. I don't know
We're just
I cannot wait until I get level four
um
That's out that is outrageous
How many plants there are?
That's insane. Oh, there's a buggy. Thank goodness. There's a buggy
Oh my god, is it gonna have better camera angles? Whatever this is
Head I go forward head I shoot
Oh, no, that's to get out. So wait, wait, hold on. Let me let me learn how to shoot. Let me learn how to shoot
Is there not like an alternate weapon? Okay, there we go. There we go. Let's go. Let's get it. Let's get it
Okay
Wait, I need to walk her down
Okay, I like this I like this I feel a bit better
Feel a bit better things are going things are looking up things are looking up
This doesn't even have a bad camera angle with the eye there
Oh, maybe it does it's just because it's a bit. Oh, okay. Oh
Be
I'm sorry, but you're gonna have to get out of the way literally
What on earth are things a freaking boulder? I'm stuck. Oh
Okay, it's good. It's good. It's good guys. Why are you stressing so much like honestly? Oh
It seems like you guys forget. I'm like MLG four or something
Have a little faith in the streamer smile
How about this mate? I don't know. Maybe I should go in there right?
I'm just gonna bum rush it honestly. No, I'm not. No, I'm not. No, I'm not
I'm gonna go back for that mech that is the bravest. No, I'm getting out. I'm getting out. It's gonna explode
It's gonna explode. It's gonna explode. No, no run away from the explosion
We're going for the mech
Give me this thing
Let me in let me in
Okay, okay, let's see. Let's see what we're working with
What we have how OP are we in comparison?
Okay, okay, okay, let him get up. Let him get up
All right. All right. Not feeling scared anymore. That's
I've had blocked the way for this poor guy. I think so. Sorry mate. You'll have to figure it out on your own
Okay, okay, hold on hold on we're cooking by gas because this isn't terrifying
This isn't terrifying. I'm just kidding mech a time. I can't believe we're playing mech assault. See this game's just mech assault simulator
All right, let them come at me. Let them get up. Let them get up
Okay
Let them. Yeah, see they always seem to hide the navi behind the like corners and stuff
I'm just gonna let them attack and hope they don't keep respawning
And then it's safe to come out. Okay
Okay, okay now hold on hold on all is not lost
This might not be the most painful gameplay of rda side you've ever seen
It's called tools path
The wildlife cannot
Okay, hold on hold on hold
Can you aim why does it never register like I really just not my register. What's going on with this bomb?
It wouldn't even like hardly let me perish it
I've always loved the mech soup here
They're a bit
It's starting starting throwing bombs at me. I'm just gonna move on
I honestly think it's safer just to ignore everything
And like only shoot for like xp or something. Can I like crush them with a mech?
No, I can that's
Oh, no, is that just get me out of the mech?
No way they put this in the game because then you are come on jump
The mechs can jump. Oh my god. That's so cool
Wait, that looks like the mech can the mech's crouch. Nope. That's just reverse
They knew exactly what they were doing freaking putting that one log there. I'll have to get out
The game knew that I wanted the mech. I'm gonna get jump scared by like 10 things at once
Now I'm gonna come flying out right go away. No you're scaring me
I need the game's just freaking jump scare similar
Well, let me put that down
No, this is a battle dome
Stop it. This is a battle dome
Yeah, it's literally called pray to his den
And you know who the pray is me
I'm being prayed at the bottom
Hmm
No
Oh
Friendly friendly, surely friendly, surely friendly, surely friendly, surely friendly
Um, is there anything you already have perished me? I'm literally one HP in a dream. Can I like hate by hate?
I can't I can't win
Hello
Why I mean, I know the game really wants to punish
You're gonna have to give me a better weapon than whatever this
Assault rifle launcher
McGon machine gun
Assault gun a hammer a flamethrower
Brev brev, I'm literally cornered. I'm getting ragdolled
This is a this is the best I can do
This is the best I can do
That thing you're literally turning into beef jerky, please please
Please please please please. I'm freaking please
Please
Please I am beef jerky right hold on. Let me let me take a break
Well, that was a terrible idea because you can just turn around and swipe me
He's not even half held and I don't even have full health yet, please
Okay, heel heel because I only have one raise
Wait, can I use these bones? Is this is is this a trick? It's the bones
Because the AI needs to pick a bone pick a side pick a side
That's right. That's right. You thought you thought you thought you thought didn't you?
Definitely don't want to destroy the bone structure, however
Can you blow him up though?
No, this isn't working. Sorry. I'm needing the the grenade doesn't work him
Okay, but don't give up on me because we're actually getting somewhere. I just need anything that freaking sprays honestly
Gun right these
This is why I need this is why I need this is it just spray and spray
This is it. This is it. This is it. Okay possible. I've not accidentally so flocked myself and this is actually possible
Okay, it's okay. It's okay. It's okay. It's okay. It's okay
Just let it happen. Just let it happen. Just let it happen
Just let it happen. Let it happen. Sorry. This is must be so annoying watching
Oh, well
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me get up. Let me heal
Let me go back there again
Okay, okay. Okay. Oh, it's okay. It's okay. We're actually doing it
I won. I don't even I need to watch other people's gameplay of this to see one earth they did because this is so cheese
This is so that was awful. Don't ever don't ever free. I only got 100 xp for that
That was awful other people played this question mark honestly
I don't know what I was supposed to do like
unless I'm
Just let it happen missed opportunity to the cut off ish
other thing
It's like go sleep. Go sleep. Go sleep. Literally
That was awful
Oh kendra hen you're gonna have to start pulling your weight
Oh
You know you fought me using the old ways honestly, can I get a weapon upgrades stat because
Okay, I've got an armor. What on earth are these armors? I'm just getting
Well, I'm like out the wazoo for that one
I'm doing I'm getting in the plane. All right, get me the heck out of here, please
Officer Midoriya
Oh, it's Midoriya from the hit enemy to uh
Here eat this. I don't know what it's called. I forgot nothing
That was scheme
But we're doing it, okay
But you're running between the bones to shoot is what you're meant to actually do. Oh, okay
You're paving the way for future avatar gamers
Congrats to uh, James Cameron's avatar for me playing your game. You've now gone up two game sales
because of my
My influential influence
Question was this destroyed it is hi kendra. We're all set. I got all three shards
That wasn't so hard was it?
That was awful grab the harmonic from the willow tree. I made contact with hq all's good
He's meeting us at the evac and stay frosty word from intel is that bed ammo himself is gunning for you
No way bed ammo is on the
No way listen to me if you run into him don't waste time just kill him the guy's a monster
Now go get the harmonic and meet me at the evac
No
He's gonna beat the absolute he's gonna beat me to a pole
Oh
Right i'm using the plane
ice
It won't let me drive this
i'm gonna have to go one foot
No, i'm not there's a buggy right next to me
Okay, I felt safer in the mix than I did the buggy
Why would you send one signal specialist on their own? Why would you not send an infantry?
Sorry, i'm trying to discover what's the there seems to be two bridges ahead
Seems to be multiple bridges actually if I go straight ahead and then take a right
Not if you beat him first
This was the best part in the movie
They really paint the nDA is the bad guys. Oh the navi is the bad guys
I mean, I guess it's like justify
Now just spray him
I
Don't know if I should go they're actually really hurting me. I'm not gonna lie
I'm I've already lost maybe like 150 percent health
And I think I'm just gonna run through the best I can
and
Oh, wow that I think that pinged them off the map there. Oops
I mean the navi share three letters with
W w winner. Oh, okay. No, you are a plot
You are you are a plant there's no way you were doing that to titanium steel I refuse
Call me hailey williams because I refuse I refuse
I
Wish I could speed up
Take a right at the next right not this right for the next right
Are you have you cleared the planet for humanity yet? No
I'm not but I'm doing the nose slice saver. I'm doing the rda side
I feel safe in the mecha tanks. I do not feel safe when I am outside of the tanks. I am absolutely mortified
Because this is awful and scary. Can the tank even fit on this? Oh, thank goodness. It can literally I
This is awful and my tank is actually getting low health. I I don't know what happens if it explodes or
No, I'm getting out. I'm I'm getting out. I'm getting out. I'm sorry
Okay, this isn't gonna go good
I need to do the song
And they're all gonna come at me. They're all gonna come at me. They were already locked on before I even came out of invis
Oh no
Oh no, oh no
This is fine. This is fine. This is fine. This is fine
Everything is fine. Everything's cool when you're part of rda
Everything's all gone
Is it safe
Oh, goodness me
Jump scare sim
Oh, get me off this planet
Get me off pandora
Don't be scared. We can hold hands on into the
Yeah
Eh, eh, is that him? Is that him? Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. You're actually terrifying and I only have one revive
Stop stop, please question mark
No way you hit that distance
The
No, he's distancing me
No, no, no, no, no, no
Is this even hurt him?
I don't know what he's freaking fire resistant. Sorry, but you need to patch this I need to patch up update pandora
You're literally a while a while is cheating a while is cheating
It was cheating it was a chain
She's cheating we hope. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Why can't I dive? Oh, I'm out of ammo
Oh my god, the shotgun blasts him back
Stay back
Oh my god, the shotgun blast the shotgun he healed
Only I'm allowed to heal
Oh
Please can I have infinite shotgun ammo that would be grand?
Don't spank me again
I need up
He keeps doing that freaking invis thing and I can't seem to shoot him when he's down like that stop
Stop
Hold on. I need to take my sweet time doing this honestly
Don't heal again. Please don't don't make this harder than it has to be
Please this is what you get for disrespecting me so much in the last run. Let me reload
Let me okay. I love the shotgun from from now and ever. I love the shotgun
Did you see that dodge? That was actually pretty good dodge. I'm not gonna lie. I'm that one
Oh, come on. Oh
Oh
We did it. Oh my goodness
Oh my goodness. I don't know how we did that
A shotgun love
Because oh my goodness
What on earth have I lost my mic? Oh, it blew up didn't it?
Where did I need to go?
Somewhere I've not discovered it. Okay. I need to backtrack
Is he shooting at me or is he shooting at
Is the way of life attacking the navi. Oh the it is
Huh
curious
The the viper wolves are actually attacking the navi. I thought it was an exclusive
Hey, I thought it was exclusive to us malina. Let me tell you something. Let me tell you something honestly
Honestly getting much better um
It was like pretty terrifying. Oh these things whip for quite a distance
Can I make it pass without getting whipped? Okay, whew whew whew whew
Okay
I think wolves just don't like everyone in this game. Please don't knock me off the bridge. That would actually ruin my day
Oh
I don't have invisibility
I'm gonna unlock the transport location unless unless unless that
Have I made a mistake? I maybe don't need this transport location. I just thought it was important to unlock but
Are there any games with hypno effect not that I can recall
Oh
Maybe that whoa these whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa these flies are stun locking me
Sorry guys, I'm gonna leave you behind to get absolutely annihilated because I don't want to deal with that
Dude, I don't know if that card game encryption has hypno in it. I don't I don't know if I'm just making that up
I I've not played it myself. I think I've like paused for like two milliseconds
To see
Huh, wait, whoa
Skipping watching my usual streamers for stroney does a new approach
You I am an endurance streamer. So if this is not your kind of game, don't worry
Mercy is going live in t
minus
Two and a half
I have never been happier to see these these guys wherever the heck they're what are they called?
Let's see what they're called. Don't move
A UT drone, I've never been so happy to see a UT drone
Oh
Depends if you go the other route. Okay. Yeah, uh, the alternative stuff. Yeah, definitely
Not an inscription. Okay. I misremember. I'm hearing radio chatter. They don't most gone missing. The navi are pulling out
You have anything to stress playing this game. I'm pretending. Okay. I really appreciate they already went to the ocarina time
We need to hurry tensions are starting to boil over at hell's gate
I was just puked up
He's starting to invite scientists for questioning. I'm not sure what he's nervous about. We need to be careful
If the time comes we may need to make some tough choices
So
Kendra wants you to report to Monroe at hell's gate if you're gonna give me 8 000 xp for showing up sure
I'll go at hell's gate pretty sure there are lots of sections of everything in
Vampires the masquerade and destroy all humans have hypnosis
Wait vampires masquerade do you get to play as a vampire that hypnotizes people that would be kind of cool. Oh my god
I'm here for that
Oh, you okay. I feel like we level up so fast as rda. Maybe the rda isn't as long
I
Think so. Oh, that's so cool. Maybe we'll take a look at that. I've never played it or seen any gameplay of it
but
Uh, is that like a highly rated game
Dark Souls 3 has rapport for enemy control
I suppose I mean technically more door shadow and more door you can take technically like imprint
enemies
So they're not mean to you
I'm behind on my doomsday diagnosis. This is the second phone wrong with the emulator. We could have an ecological meltdown
Okay, let's hold up a sec. What the hell is this emulator?
Yes, the emulator we're searching for a dormant well of souls, right now once we find it
We need to communicate. Oh, they're pretending being called a first voice
He's the only person who can awaken a well of souls
They're pretending that the emulator isn't just a nuke
Once that's done, we can control the entire ecosystem. So back to that first ecosystem. You're running a new day diagnostic
Well, everything has its risk. Come now. Upload that home out. They're lying to me
naughty
But we're still gonna nuke the planet anyway
Once they're closer to pinpointing the location of the dormant site
You should check it
VTM does in fact have the option to be a hypnotic vanguard and highly rated as a question as a cult classic
Oh, my apology. I did not know that
I hear you took down badama
Nice work
It's good. My need to mess with it a little to make it work though. It's old game
Oh, yeah, doesn't Baldur's gate have a bunch of
Oh, I'm not playing big baldies gate yet
Don't start growing a brain
It says it's co-op. Is it like co-op that I can bring you get you guys in and out? Or is it not that kind of co-op?
The human colony and after which is pretty impressive
Baldur's gate has tons of main control efficient because main flyers are a big part of the port
Hmm
Doesn't have main control of the game
It's quite a
VTM vampires masquerade is old game
It's not that kind of coin. We're going to Graves bog
Okay
Did you know that in scots the bog is slang for the toilet?
Did you know that in australia the thunderbox is slang for the toilet?
I don't know what any slang for any other
This voice actor sounds like grandpa max from band tan
Nice to watch
Oh new scary location, oh me. Oh my
I
Mean Baldur's gate has twitch integration. Oh, it's a shame. There's no such thing
Keep not getting a good night's sleep before streams, I don't know what to do or how to stop it
You know saying I have nightmares about the girls
I keep waking up like way before I should
I don't know how to have a good night's sleep
Ashiva to drop me open I can literally see wills like kendra wants you to collect a shard from a navi village
Oh a village fill a navi. Sure. Let me just go have fun. Why not drive me to the village?
Kendra you suck
Wait, I've already been here before. Oh, no
No
Wait, so dad go the path that I've not been all right. Go the way. I've not been use hypnosis to sleep
Honestly
You know what? Oh wait, I shouldn't have done that. All right, get me up here
Okay, I'm out. Do they they can
I
That's gonna take a lot just to get rid of them geez these other guys I can hear them
I think he's biting my ankle. Oh, there's so many of them
Oh
Not even giving me. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. I just hurt myself and made that so easy for them. Hold on
Get my gun out. Oh
What was that animation that was just like
x wax x axis 90 degrees animation for the rock destroy
Lol
Right hold on
Okay, it's a big fight
I'll ignore the fighting and I'll just go get the mission objective
And then I'll use the xp from achieving the mission objective
Uh
Whoa
Oh, am I burning my own guys or just him? Oh wait, there's a
I'm not really sure what I feel about the flamethrower. I don't know if it's as fast as I think it should be
I said I want to
Do
They're at least helping you this time honestly a christmas miracle
I almost dive into the fire to sacrifice myself
Okay, just grab it right. Uh, now what now what now what check them up
Uh, just keep to keep going the path that hasn't been walked. Excuse me. Pardon me coming through
I'm literally watching all the humans get annihilated next to me and just being like, yeah, not my problem
See you later alligator in a while crocodile
Level four invisible
Please
soon
But that's terrifying
What you didn't even give me a warning
You did not even give me a freaking warning that was going to go down
Oh, I'm getting absolutely roasted
I'm I'm not gonna make it. I'm not gonna make it
I'm gonna make it the gates are right there. Come on. Oh, oh, oh, oh, come on. Help me out turban. Help me out
shoot them
Hello
Oh, thank goodness. I thought they weren't gonna open the gate
I was like, I know you can see me right now open this open. Let me in
Open the door
Oh
Flames are in video game only come into flavors overpowered or a wargun on anything this fresh meat can do
That's like a struck a match and I'm like here take that
One person versus the whole planet literally why not take me out with squadron
Uh
Oh, okay, okay. Well
Oh, I'm burping I'm burping
Spray and pray people spray and pray
Oh, no, don't don't spray the allies. Oh, oh
Okay, okay. Okay. I'm gonna get up
Okay, I'm trying to get like two at once but it's not working
Oh my goodness
Right, I'm not that see I'm not scared when I've got allies, but when I've no I'm absolutely modified
The events that are unfolding five we need six. Oh, I'm getting wax. Whoa. That is a big stick
Okay, I want to collect the samples
Where's the shotgun? Is this?
Nope, that's pistol
No, that's empty. That's why
Oh, whoa
Okay
Is that working? I don't the flamethrower isn't like am I going crazy?
I'm I'm losing it. It's not doing anything
Yeah, the shotgun actually does something though
Oh, there we go. There we go
There we go, that's much better. Hold on. Hold on. I'm getting I'm getting hang of it. Let me get up there one more
Goodness gravy
Yeah, the aim is to stone eggs folks
Can I finish a kill please
That navi just completely ignored me there
I mean, I'll take it a layer north gate is under attack. Oh, we have more
Where what one here?
North gate
Oh
I just looked at north on the hide. I'm like, hmm, where would the north gate be?
Me hapsich would be facing north this shotgun
Oh
Is that we literally just did a synchronized dance there
Yeah, I wish
Literally synchronized dance
Go ahead on skull moment. Good. Oh
Jesus
That's like never ending
And I can hardly see them because they're invisible half the time
Oh, I'm hardly getting the credit for killing them
Is there carrots I can climb up yet?
There's no ladder climb on those carrots. They're just for what? Oh, there's one over here. Hold on
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. This might make things a lot easier. Let's try it. Let's try it. Let's try it
Oh
My god, can I
No, that's friendly
Oh my god, this is so much easier. Are you joking me?
Uh, I've been struggling for how long
Oh, this is too simplistic. No, I missed that guy, but it's still
Yeah, and they keep stealing my kills
Oh
Okay, three and done. This is the last one. There's no way get me off this
I have two razes. I do need to try and
Yeah, sorry. I'm ignoring everything and
Well, I would ignore everything if you get you weren't perfectly you're blocking the way
Grunt
learn your
Okay, okay, let's let's yeah, let's go
Let me progress
Oh, this is so why on earth that I don't think of this sooner
Reflings! Why didn't you suggest this? You're supposed to be holding my hand!
Oh, I'm going to need catch up on chat, honestly. I feel like I'm going to have to sing to beat you.
I'm going to have to sing.
Oh, right.
Oh, done. Jeez, Louise!
Sorry if I'm not part of the 20 players that won this game. RIP. I can't believe it. It's such a legendary game.
I can't even say I recommend, like, all go out and buy it.
The experience, for me, is more nostalgia, although this part is, like, actually...
Like, I'm actually, like, having a challenge playing this part.
I'm still in disbelief. The game even exists.
Your hands are on the controller. B-legs didn't sell the turret.
Oh, the jet didn't see the turret. Sorry, sorry.
You're doing good!
I've got two songs.
I think, so far.
Shawnee, by the way, you missed the cutscene gate flying like a rocket launcher, honestly.
Yeah, you leveled so far. I wonder if the RDA mission is actually, like, smaller than the main.
Wait, I want to unlock the fast travel before I take off, just in case.
Level up!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Did she say whoops? I like you too, Ryder.
Whoa. Wait, I'm not driving? Oh, thank god.
Alright, let's see how this develops.
Oh, the aim is a bit...
In front of us! Are you drunk?
Are you drunk?!
Did I just ignore the ones from behind, or...?
What's the deal? Did I just go for it?
Is this just an XP run? I think it's just an XP run.
I'll just destroy everything, have a look at that.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's getting... that's so loud in my head. Holy crap.
Is it too loud for stream?
That's, like, just a little deafening.
Okay, this just looks like an XP farm run. I'm gonna say it, but...
I can't even see what's ahead of me. There's so much.
Oh, excuse me. Oh, no.
Whoa! I didn't even know you were just riding those like that.
Oh. What's going on? What's going on?
Are they...?
Oh!
The camera angle is like... I'm not even driving. Who's driving this warthog?
That's a terrible job of it.
Oh, I'm overheating. Oops.
Hold on.
Overheating. I'm getting a little too overzealous with this weaponry, okay?
Oh.
This is just annihilation. I'm starting to feel bad for the Navi, like, as much as they're annoying when they're trying to kill me.
As they hold them all clear, I can't see.
Oh, God! They're everywhere!
Oh, I don't know if I'm going to make this alive.
I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying.
It's hard.
Oh, my goodness.
Can I see?
Oh, it's a blue plant. I keep thinking it's a Navi. It's a blue plant. That's, like, right there.
Come on! Start the car!
There's only so much back and forth I can do before we actually perish. Seriously?
Oh, my goodness. Right. It seems like they're just falling back in.
Thank God. Right. Don't do that again.
Get the hell out of here!
I'm sorry I yelled at you, sweetheart, he says, to the car.
Reeflings, I'm sorry I yelled at you, sweetheart.
I just get stressed when I'm playing the bad guys and everything's all skewed.
I'm sorry if I skewed.
What?
Oh, I don't want that to break.
She's doing her best for humanity.
I'm absolutely denying it.
Denying it? Sorry. Destroying it.
If I'm getting XP,
the first things are running away.
Right.
That's my car. That's one of more guys.
I didn't even know.
Oh, first things.
I just feel bad. I feel like we're entering a zoo and then just executing all the animals inside the zoo.
This is what this run feels like, honestly.
Like, they're literally running away now.
Yeah.
All for XP, so I can unlock a new armor. Why not?
Perish that plan.
In front, are you do- Oh!
Is that supposed to happen?
What a unique game mode to say the least.
I think you see about three of these guys if you play Navi,
and you see 100 on this one section of the game alone.
We're strum-beast-pulling.
That's where it's been. Oh my god. That was...
That was a slaughter. I'm not even happy with that. That was awful.
I'm bad.
This is why the Navi section has so few human campaign colors.
Now you know why you don't see them in this.
Oh!
Is it like all this damage is being done and we're just coming at the back end of it?
Aw, that actually makes so much sense.
We basically come in when they're at the end of the losing fight and we turn the tide.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's so smart.
I didn't give the devs team as much benefit as they do, but that's so smart.
Don't let him... I was gonna say don't let him kill you,
because he's gonna aggro to me and I can just tell he is.
Oh wait, hold on. I'm trying to go.
Hold on a minute. Let me...
There we go.
I'll just let him get in the back end.
What new drift have we got?
Wait, I think we're about to unlock the new one, because now our arms are on short
and I'm like, that's the opposite of what I want.
It does. I hate her.
Oh, no clue if it's kind of, it's just a joke of mine.
I mean it may be, because literally you only see two of them.
Alright, where do I need to go?
Well, I'm taking a car for that.
I'm not taking that by foot.
Can I drive this?
Kendra?
How do I shoot? I don't know. Can I drive him over?
Oh, that was...
I was actually really mean. I shouldn't have gone that far.
I kind of deserved it.
What are all those things? Are those reports?
So can I not shoot? I don't think I can.
I think I can only drive.
I'm driving this buggy.
That's like such a long way to go.
I'll go on the outskirts to get the...
like uncovered map thing.
I actually smished him against the wall.
I can't go that way.
This is so much more responsive than the buggy I have to admit.
I like that they make that differentiation.
Okay.
We can go this way.
I thought we couldn't consider the way the map made it look, but we...
No, I did not just do that.
Oh, I did not just do that.
I freaking did!
No, no, no.
Hello, game.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, this is the worst thing that could have happened has not happened.
Door stock, literally door stock.
And I have to do all of this on foot,
whilst everything is aggressive to me.
Right, how much further do I have to go?
Just leave it for it.
Just down the street.
It's fine.
I just need to pop down the street.
It's like going to the corner shop.
It's just around the corner.
It's okay.
You can just teleport down.
I can't because I've not unlocked whatever it is.
It's not unlocked.
Is it quiet?
Is it safe question mark?
Other than the fly trap?
Just a little bit more.
All is good.
This is called Sniper's Point
implying that there's Sniper Navi
looking at me right now, question mark.
The ho-hum.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Something's getting me.
I don't want.
A fly?
A fly got me.
A mosquito.
A mosquito got me.
Oh!
Whoa.
Look at it.
Freaking ready to like get me already.
I'll wait until my invis comes back.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
Go back to sleep.
Yep.
Stinky.
Stinky plant.
I don't like you.
Abandoned RDA camp.
Well, that doesn't...
That doesn't...
This is just...
This is not good for me.
I can tell you that much.
This is absolutely awful for me.
I will take the teleport point
just so I don't have to do that again.
Um...
Can I hide here?
Well, he looks pretty enraged to me.
Um...
I have nowhere.
I'm gonna go up.
Oh no, I can't go up.
I'm too small.
Where...
Where's the crystal, guys?
I don't really want to go.
Abandoned hope.
Yo, ye who may enter from the floor.
Finger.
But hole.
Oh.
There's this to spray them down.
Hmm.
Okay.
Did they just run away from me now?
Okay, not too bad if I have a tulile.
I really destroy all this stuff too.
I mean, it's 10 XP.
I'm not really sure it's worth taking the time to do that.
I will try and clear up this area
because if I'm trying to find a crystal in the middle,
I'm still free jumping.
I don't even know where I'm supposed to look.
Oh, now you come around the corner.
Nah, you're such a liar.
You're actually such a liar.
You're telling fivers.
Why would you come around the corner now
after I'd already sprayed you?
Where on earth is this...
thing?
And he's already AI locked onto me.
I don't know why the game pretend to be otherwise.
Is there another turret over here that I can use?
I know the things back in that other section.
I'm just wondering what's up here.
Why is there a dead end?
Oh, and it's just like one of these things.
Jeez.
That gorilla.
It's just abandoned.
Kind of showing you it's old.
Abandoned...
Dog.
Pet dog.
It's a turtle.
I have no idea what's hecking crystal on Zoom right now.
It's already aggroed to me but I can't see.
Maybe inside that building and that's why it's like flashing?
Okay.
Oh, pardon me.
I'm gonna go invisible and see if I can shoot it from that turret
or is it already glued onto me?
No.
Is it in here?
Bro, where is this freaking cell sample?
I don't know.
I'm gonna see if I can get rid of that last guy with this
because he...
I just saw a second one.
Wait, let's get rid of you
because you're in Moe.
You're in Moe.
Right.
No.
I think wherever the heck it is, it's somewhere over here.
It's not been here yet.
Right.
I hate you.
What, even if you're invisible?
Oh, he's got protection prior on.
I can see it.
That's what that bloom means.
Boy.
Here.
Oh, I just...
What did I get?
I got new armor and speed four.
I'll take that.
Bro, am I actually gonna have to look up a tutorial?
That was big.
I've got a different outfit.
I'm like...
It's not that way.
It's out of bounds over there, basically.
It's not like up here.
Whoa, sorry.
Sorry.
I wasn't paying attention.
Is it up?
Should it be up?
Where the heck is this one thing?
Hmm.
No, don't spray on me.
Now's not time for that.
Hello.
We're currently looking for something that my blind eyes cannot perceive.
It says it's somewhere in this area and I keep perfectly avoiding it, whatever it is.
Okay.
Now the avatars are coming in this area?
Is it inside that, maybe?
Maybe it's inside this one, whatever it is.
It's in the building.
Oh.
If it's in this one, I'm gonna be mad because I went in the other one.
Oh, for goodness' sake, thank you.
What are the odds?
Right, finally got there in the end.
And of course there's not fast travel with that guy because that would be too easy, wouldn't it?
Ugh.
That speed is fast though, like I'm pretty speedy.
Of course it was in the building that I wasn't looking at.
How could I be such a silly sausage?
I was beating up my car.
Yeah, I had to put a down payment on that.
Right, this is gonna be off topic.
I don't know if you guys have been watching.
There's this YouTuber that looks at people's finances, like for entertainment.
But he always shouts at them for having a car.
And I didn't realize that car loans were like really predatory in America.
Where they like make you pay like a ridiculous like percentage and stuff.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You just relax, little flies, you just relax.
Thank you.
And me two more?
No, one more crystal and then I'm good to go.
You two, huh?
One, and it took four tenths, bad day for bets.
It seems no.
Don't be getting, don't be betting on me honestly.
I want you to collect the shard from a nearby Navi village.
Okay, let's give it a shot.
I believe this is the second last shard collection map.
And then we've done the campaign unbelievably.
We are just going for it.
I love being ignored in battle.
Yay.
I love going so fast that the enemies don't target me.
I love not being a part of the fight.
Ow, he just spanked my butt.
Good night.
Rest well, those who need to sleep.
Sorry about kind of the surprise endurance stream.
I thought it was only going to be four hours.
What were we at?
We're at seven hours?
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Sorry to anyone.
Good night and rest well, those who need to go.
Please do not stay up against your health.
Just watch.
The vaude will be remaining for you soon, TM.
You must kill Tanjala before you collect the harmonic and the willow tree.
Right, we've got a boss fight.
But we can do it.
We can do it.
We can do it if we put our mind to.
We can do...
Where am I?
I'm not trying to go.
I'm behind a tent right now.
Living up to the endurance streamer tag anyway.
Yeah.
I wonder how many people didn't realize when I said endurance streamer
I meant endurance streamer.
Okay.
Right, where am I doing?
Just kind of...
Kind of half...
Hold the map.
Oh!
Oh, I'm in the battlefield by accident.
Stromer, look at this child.
Tanjala near me.
What a surprise.
Look at my speed.
My speed is amazing.
I'm a super soldier.
It tastes like raisins.
I was surprised but I haven't missed them at how.
Oh my God.
I have streamed a heck of a lot of time.
I feel like maybe.
Watch yourself.
I can't even see the enemy.
You know that?
I actually can't.
I'm not being funny.
I didn't mean to good battle but I genuinely can't see the enemy.
What do you want me to do?
Oh, no way.
I've just engaged the boss fight.
Stop.
I've engaged the boss fight and there's literally a billion...
I didn't even see you.
You're going to make me pee myself, please.
Oh my God.
I think I need flamethrower to like...
I'm just getting absolutely gang violence here.
What am I supposed to do?
I need pop malts.
I need pop malts like right now.
They're all using freaking prayer protection.
I'm out of mana.
I actually can't do prayer protection because I'm out of mana.
I'm running out of freaking strength potion as if we were playing rescapes right now.
Oh my gosh.
What have I done?
I've just dived into the enemy.
I literally can't see them for half the time.
Oh and there's someone sniping me from behind as well.
No, sorry, but no.
It's just no on.
You can't even just snake me from halfway across the map.
Why did that one run away?
I have no idea.
I'm guessing that ranged or whatever.
The sniper one is still wound for me, but at least that other one ran away.
Okay, that's the problem I have with the snipers.
They can do that.
Yes.
Thank you for coming freaking point blank.
Why?
Oh wow.
Tangela pushed me so far out of his battle area.
He has literally...
DC?
No.
I can see that other NPC though.
Can I shoot him once?
Oh, that's the flamethrower darling.
That's the shotgun.
Can I?
I just want him.
There we go.
Okay.
I just wanted him to attack me.
No one else.
Okay, let's take it nice and easy.
She says that she gets caught in the tree.
No, that...
No.
Shotgun.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I missed.
Okay, this is what I want.
The shotgun stagger is exactly what I'm looking for right now.
It can be...
What's the name of a shotgun?
It can be a spad.
12 is the name of a shotgun.
A stakeout is the name of a shotgun.
Another gun.
I don't remember any other ones off the top of my head.
Not very good with gun names unless they're in Black Ops 1 and all, honestly.
Famous, AK-47.
Sub-machine guns.
Susies.
AK-47U.
MP5.
Very classic, normally shown in movies.
MP5K.
Brian!
I have returned from the job strongy.
Hope it's going well.
We're currently doing a boss battle and I'm getting absolutely wrecked, tiny, spiny.
But...
I can only do as much as I can.
It's taken a while.
I don't know.
I feel like maybe there's something I should know.
Like, maybe I should be in a mech at this point.
It's very plausible.
But thank you for the ship.
We're getting there.
He's just cast protection, so I don't even wanna...
Like, I don't wanna waste the ammo since I've only got two left.
Like, stop with the prayer protection.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, I'm out of that.
So next is Flamethrower.
Nah, he gets so close when I do Flamethrower.
Like, so close.
Has he got Fury on so he does double damage to me?
I think so.
I think that's what that was.
Right, we're just gonna have to do this.
It seems he staggers with the assault, right?
I think he's got a light machine gun, actually.
He's getting low, so if he doesn't heal,
then I think we're in...
I think we're cooking by gas if he doesn't heal.
Oh, okay, we did it, we did it, we did it, we did it.
I cast Mystic Barrier, honestly.
Getting wrecked isn't needing to use ult and hasn't poked the damage,
but someone either, honestly.
First try, like, I'm just glad I'm not dying and getting stun locked.
Where or why am I here?
Why?
What am I to do?
Oh wait, I'm to do the song.
I'm to do the song, I understand, my apologies.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You need to relax
and take your little acrobatic self away.
I need to do the song right now, where is it?
Right, one, and then do a triangle.
Somewhere here?
No?
Somewhere over here?
Somewhere in the water?
Okay, okay, triangle, triangle.
Triangle?
Oh, you don't attack.
Whoa, they are humongous if you're a baby.
Wait, where?
Triangle?
Well, that would be a triangle, maybe here.
Okay, okay.
Not a perfect triangle.
We're about there cages.
Staggered to death, honestly.
Humongous wall.
Strongly doesn't.
For democracy, wait, wrong thing.
What did you guys think of Helldivers?
I got a chance to play it and I was like,
hmm, I wonder if one of those things,
like if you have good company and then it's a fun game,
but who goes there, identify yourself?
Whoa, get me out of here, because I just heard that.
We're just doing this.
I only played one, need friends for it.
It was good until Sony.
Oh, yeah, wait, actually, holy crap,
we like completely missed out on all the war hammer.
Okay, all the friggin...
All right, well, and then all the kills in.
Can I die in a cutscene?
You did it.
Oh, right, last song, question mark.
I would like to return to Hell's Gate, please.
Thank you very much.
Oh, sorry, my little feces are moving my feet.
My hands are very sweaty, but my feet are very dry right now,
and I don't know if that means I'm dehydrated.
I won't have a mention of your pop-up.
Sorry, I misnamed it.
I meant Helldivers, Sam.
The Helldivers, like, it was like people were...
They tried to make it so you had to have a PSN account or something,
just to play the game.
Even though they advertised, like,
you can still play your game even without the PSN part.
When in doubt, drink.
Okay, is this...?
Okay, this is the third song.
Monkos.
Oh!
Jesus.
That's so, um...
He's so stinky.
Level up.
Yeah, they tried to force PSN accounts to play,
which would have locked a lot of people out.
And they're known for getting, uh, leaks, you know.
Yeah.
Deep Rock Galactic.
They made a Lord of the Rings version.
I think they called it Mines of Moria.
I've not played it, but I hope it's multiplayer
and I can, like, play with you guys.
It'd be so fun.
Speaking of which, you should check with him
for your next mission.
Oh, no.
Huh?
Oh, I'm having an avatar fight with him.
Jarhead.
I'll prove to you that I'm a real trooper.
I'll eat crayons and smile about it.
Deep Rock is crazy fun.
We're it!
We are going to the Hanging Gardens.
This guy's very ergo.
Part of the Jarhead clan.
Oh, that's right! In the movies!
These are part of the Jarhead clan.
Movie quote spotted.
Mushroom.
Rock and Stone.
Hello!
We already...
Let's hit the envelope.
I've never heard that before.
The Hanging Gardens.
Did I hear Rock and Stone?
You did.
Do you think I can convince the girls
to remain Zamorio with me?
Triple Cannibal?
Oh, dear.
Uh, hello?
We've just landed?
Can I reload?
I'm already out of money.
Eh, money.
I'm munitions.
Did I not...
Did the game automatically reload it for me?
I want rid of these bow and arrow guys first.
I only have three revives.
I need to keep pick it.
Wow!
This is why I want rid of these bow and arrows.
Oh, goodness me.
Can I get a breathing space?
Oh, this is crazy.
Give me some space.
Give me some space, please.
Oh, space, space, space.
They just keep coming.
Oh, I'm getting spanked about.
Oh, wrong button.
Actually, no, protection's fine.
They keep going around.
Stop with the bow and arrow.
Oh, this is so unpredictable where they move.
Alright, I need to kill one more,
and then I think they stop respawning.
So this is...
I'm just getting stun logged.
I wish I had that.
Is that what my belly did when I was a Navi?
Oh, my gosh.
What a rough landing.
Oh, yeah.
What does it say?
Oh, it's a Haiti landing.
Why?
Why is it Haiti?
Why Haiti?
It's not Haiti.
It was a miss input, miss input.
That was chaos.
That just dropped me right in there.
Batista.
Destroyed the Navi.
Haiti, as opposed to smooth.
Oh!
Now that you have said that out loud,
that makes so much more sense.
I always wondered why the heck they always mentioned that.
Oh, that was Harry.
That was Harry.
Harry.
And I'm like, and I'm missing something.
Clearly, brain cells, the whole thing.
Alright, how do I get to this location?
Take the skinny path behind me.
I need to do a big old 1A.
Why is the camera angle so bad in this game?
Wait.
Oh, no.
Yeah, we're not doing that in the buggy.
Please let me out.
We will do this by foot.
Is this where the flamethrower comes in?
Can I even get close enough?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Flamethrower for the wildlife.
For the plants.
That's fine by me.
I will try to remember this.
If I make it across here,
the dogs will go everywhere until...
Get right.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Yeah, just keep going and then go to the right.
Okay.
Brilliant driving.
Look, I'm...
Thank goodness I don't actually have a driver's license
because I'm not going to lie.
It would not go down well.
I can hear trombone.
You're so rich.
Oh, there's quite a lot of you.
As long as I can jump past you, it's fine.
I'll let you live.
You know, I'm doing...
I'm doing a while.
We favor not killing you all, actually.
So you should be...
You should be grateful.
You should be thankful.
I said you should be grateful
and you should be thankful.
What the heck is this?
I don't know.
A repulsor?
A zone repulse.
Oh, that's right.
Please.
No, no.
Please just let me do it so you guys leave.
Oh, okay.
They're safe.
Nah, I've seen worse drivers.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I contributed to the stereotype.
Wait, is this grunt here to help us or...
No, he's here to give us our next job.
Booyah.
Don't worry, we're almost there.
DT.
Sure.
Oh, that makes broken.
I was gonna go in there.
If I go straight ahead,
should be fine.
Let's go.
Why not?
Wait, straight ahead.
Yeah, straight ahead.
Okay, let's...
Don't flip the buggy.
It's my only request.
It's killing...
Why would you do that?
You knew exactly what you were doing?
I can't get up.
I can't get up and everything's gonna attack me.
Literally, look on the map.
There's like a freaking massive ass battle bone.
It's over.
This is over for me.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, Golly.
Oh gosh, Golly G.
That really was not supposed to happen.
The Dave, who have created this map,
knew exactly what he was doing.
Giving me a heart attack.
They're still here.
They're literally waiting to attack me.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
It's getting a bit non-smooth.
It's getting a bit heady, lads.
It's getting a bit heady.
Okay, we're friends, it's fine.
Friends.
Actually, there's no way you're a super stash.
You'll play the game by just dodging everything all the time.
But this is the best I can do under the turquoise.
Can I get this package, please?
Thank you.
Objective complete.
Let's get the heck out of here.
Jeez.
Where'd I need?
Brett, can you stop sending me one side of the map to the other?
I don't...
This game is having an awfully fun time doing that.
How...
I can't even teleport there.
There's not even anything to teleport from.
If I take a right and don't fall off, man...
You fell off.
Oh, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Just ignore me, I'm not part of the field.
I'm actually...
Oh, I'm just a field medic.
What is it?
That British Red Cross rule or something?
I can't get over.
I have to go to a low.
I don't want to take any fall damage.
I'm literally two centimeters off the ground, so...
Oh, we have to take the long way around.
Through all those navi!
And they're literally right there.
And they're already attacking me.
Oh, the navi.
And attacking me.
Name a better duo.
Do I go that way?
Yes, I can go that way.
I literally went invisible as that guy struck me.
No white crosses for health packs and games and stuff.
Apparently that's a war crime.
Also, shooting unarmed medics.
Exactly, like seriously, what's going on here?
You cannae jump it?
No, I cannae jump it.
Right, I'm sure these are bombs.
Yeah, okay, I was gonna say, I'm sure there's something up with those.
I had to find out for myself, I'd find out the hard way.
Oh, there's so many of them.
Okay, you don't even respond to that.
Oh, let me guess, they don't hurt the level, so it's gonna be too easy.
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no.
There's no human here.
I'm actually a...
I'm a mouse.
I'm a mammal.
No, wait, navi aren't considered mammals, are they?
I'm actually a...
I feel like I'm going the wrong way.
Technically, if I just keep going forward, it's fine.
I just jive right into them.
I'm not real.
I'm actually gonna claim this pod first, and then go in with...
I'm probably gonna get shot in the bum with an arrow though.
Oh.
Oh, and there's another one right there.
Har har har, very funny game.
No human here, only a co-
Literally, I'm just an innocent little sef full of pod doing my thing, you know?
Hey, no good time.
Just need to try and speedrun getting out of all these
absolutely atrociously dangerous areas,
and then we can finally destroy Pandora,
and live happily ever after.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, no, you do that much better.
Wait, this is a dead end?
Can you stop?
Please, I'm literally stuck here with you.
Is this a dead end?
Yes or no?
Have I just gone a horrifically wrong way?
Why would you do that?
Okay, I need to now take the biggest frickin' circle over.
Hi everyone, I'm back.
Thank you for joining again.
We are still the RD, we're still the bad guys,
and we're still avoiding every fight possible under the sun
because this is just impossible, there's no way.
I refuse to believe this is even plausible.
Humans number one, baby.
Innocent.
Innocent, no.
I'm an innocent cuttlefish.
Hold on a minute, I don't know if you've seen them or anything.
Oh, that scared me.
I actually need to heal.
I need to heal, but I want to stop because I think I'm going to get my bum bitten.
Oh my god, the paralysis from those flies are so punishing.
So punishing.
I'm going to see if I can run past both of these, but...
Oh, poison, poison, poison.
Hello?
Am I walled off again?
What have I done to me?
Why?
What have I done to deserve this?
I'm so confused why I can't access this area.
I literally need to go down.
Okay, that dog can't come on me.
On the branch.
Oh, can I climb down this?
Or is this Navi only?
No, it can't be Navi only.
I'm human.
I can't freaking do it.
Bro, I'm going to explore the whole map before I actually get to my location.
I can't believe...
Bro...
Explore the whole map.
I mean, drowning people might have been a thing.
I've not done it yet.
I'm not even successful in doing my first hypnosis stream.
This is...
I'm getting absolutely spun about in this game.
You know that?
I'm about to discover an outpost.
I don't know what's going to happen when I get to it, but...
I'll literally discover the whole map before I unlock the next objective.
Oh, goodness me.
Everything's abandoned and there's the name on it.
I've freaking saved me.
So if I go down here...
It's still the wrong place.
I need to drop below.
Can I drop below in the upcoming thing?
Oh!
Did I miss that?
Please don't put me all the way back.
I have been travelling...
for day and...
Why would you just...
upon me?
I need to...
I need to gently go down on the map.
Gently go down on the map.
Getting the buggy, we're driving.
Because this is taking far too long to unlock the next objective.
I don't know how I perished from that, but whatever.
Right, so that's a crossing.
Right, so...
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, there's a really...
I'm getting trolled.
Where am I?
How...
I need to go backwards, like this way?
No, like this way?
Go back and do a U-turn.
Right, I need to do a U-turn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need...
I figured out how I get there, I think.
Oh my goodness.
That was a fun noise.
That was just the noise of pure shock and horror.
Oh, and I'm about to hit a Navi tri-
Of course I am, because why would I?
Why wouldn't I hit a massive Navi tri-
straight ahead?
And I'm about to uncluck right in front of them all.
Hi guys, do you just want to totally annihilate me one by one?
You might as well line up and have a little Congo going, you know?
Just to really drive at home how much I am dead meat in this game.
I like how, actually, I just...
I will say one thing, I like how I'm always, like, congratulated, like,
from how much I'm achieving,
but the reality of the situation is,
I am just, like, cheesing all the way through the battles.
I'm, like, literally not injuring any Navi whatsoever.
And they're like, wow, you're doing amazing out there on the battlefield.
And the reality, like, I'm just doing backflips all the time
and getting away from the enemy.
We finally got there, and yeah, that took so long.
Take us out to dinner first.
Mm-hmm.
This can happen to you.
You love nature.
That's what I get for loving nature.
That took...
Wait.
This teleport site was already on...
Mm.
Mm-hmm.
Success.
I got it.
It was already unlocked.
It's fine.
It's fine. I'm fine.
Fine, that took me how long?
Together.
Please.
Try not to blow yourself up.
I passed the first one, honestly.
Right, what am I doing?
I can't believe that.
Ten thing.
Did they both blow up, or what?
Or just the one?
What am I blowing up?
Something, anyway.
Oh, I'm blowing up the freaking rocks
that blocked me from moving in the first place.
Hardy, hardy, hard, very funny.
Already freaking...
Ooh!
That's not supposed to happen.
What was it?
What am I getting shot by?
What's going on, guys?
Oh, this game's trolling me.
It seems like we've got company.
I don't like the samples.
Too many Viper Wars.
There's got to be some way to slow them down.
I'm on it.
Okay, we got a new unlock.
We're almost there.
Hold on.
Hold on for me.
You're so close.
Right, I've got healing four.
That's what I like to see.
Let us put down these.
Oh, is that a bomb?
That has to be a bomb.
Then it might be.
That's supposed to be a bomb, yeah.
Oh, right.
The bomb did activate even though I did it at the same time.
Okay, just to do it one more time.
One more time.
It's okay.
Right, they're both...
I'm getting slowed down by the...
Enough, enough, enough.
I'm getting slowed down.
That's all right.
You just want to spend more time.
Yeah, see how you're doing.
You have to say you're out,
but you know, you just have to do a lot.
You keep running through the dang thing.
Well, how about that?
Half as dear as older than I am.
Hydration check.
Windsor's orders to fill the power cell in the system.
Reactivate the thing.
Okay.
I'm analyzing the map
so I can basically go whatever way I want.
I just got the sweep since I was looking at it.
Dog was getting shot in the background.
Literally, the pervy thing.
It's not their fault they spawned on time, bro.
Me.
Oh, it's such a shame.
The pervy dogs.
Also me.
The dogs won't leave me alone.
I've had enough.
No.
That's too many.
No, that's one too many.
So, that's actually one too many.
That's three too many.
If any more come at me,
I'm out to be raging.
This is too much.
How are you supposed to genuinely do this?
Does the devs expect you to pause
and do this every single time?
There's no way.
I'm getting bit to death, though.
There's no way in heck.
I refuse.
Then we're going to get spat on by the flies
and then there's mere dogs.
Okay.
I somehow am making it.
Do I need to take a little to the...
Okay, I need to drop the buggy
when I get ahead here.
And then I'll have gone through the section pretty quickly.
There.
Okay, we're all good again.
That is a pretty plan, honestly.
I'm surprised.
Wow.
Okay, there's allies ahead.
That's all I like to see.
Mate, you're just letting that plan
absolutely decimate you for no reason.
Okay, this is like so much easier.
Can you actually burn the plants?
You know that?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
It's too many.
Too many dogs.
Why are there so many multi-different colors?
But when you play, like, the Navi side,
where you're supposed to, like, be appreciating nature and stuff,
it's just like, you know...
Oh, for goodness' sake, what am I doing now?
If I have the backtrack one more time.
Right, thankfully I can teleport here.
You make me backtrack one more time game.
I'm going to have it out for you.
I might not self-clear.
Hmm.
We surely must be getting backtops soon with this one.
I feel like we grabbed all the songs, so what now?
So we're to get in Harper Deeds.
Um, the Navi side of the game is good.
The RDA side...
I'm just wanting it to be over with.
It's too hard.
Like, I'm genuinely hard.
No, I'm not hard.
Sorry.
The game is genuinely hard on the RDA side.
Okay, so Kendra's gotten doubts of what the thing is.
Nothing yet.
Let's keep focused.
You need to grab those shards.
Report back when you're...
And I don't mean that, I don't mean that.
So when we get the offer...
Why is it sending me...
This map is a nightmare to navigate.
I'm not being funny.
This is probably one of the hardest maps.
No, this will be the hardest map ever.
That I've had to navigate and do all this stuff in.
I don't even know where to start.
Maybe the one to my left?
If I take a left and then before...
No.
If I take a left and then take a right...
This is the filter for the human campaign.
Literally, like...
It's getting rough.
It's getting rough being told to go.
And I know they provide transport via the mechs and the...
Buggies and that.
But if you're going to do it that your buggy health makes you explode and you have to reload...
There's no point in providing that kind of thing.
Like it's just...
The name was going to be...
Wait, if I go...
Okay, I can resurrect it.
I need to take the first right though.
I can resurrect it.
It's fine.
Oh, please don't.
I'm going to run out of hiding.
I am running for my life.
I didn't even know they were going to do Thanos in the middle.
No, no.
Please leave me alone.
Please, I ask kindly and respectfully to respect my space.
I very kindly ask you to respect my social distance.
Social distance and keys?
I don't know if you've seen that Scottish meme where the guy goes social distance, please.
But he said it so politely.
I'm just hauling ass.
There's no way I'd make this without...
Oh, right.
Where is it?
It's up here, to be honest.
Okay.
Oh, this is actually...
Okay, I'll give the game Devs something.
This is actually kind of cool.
I like the classic like spiral up something.
I'll see it.
Whoa.
Lovely!
Lovely.
Thank you, Devs.
Thank you, Devs, for putting a crack in the fricked rock stairwell.
I'll take everything I said back about this design.
Take it all back.
Random gap in the stairwell whilst you're getting whacked by Navi
and the dogs are biting your ankles at the bottom of the rock face.
And things are exploding.
There's like an exploding plant that's aiming on me right now.
That's what that...
Oh, oh, speaking of exploding plants, here's the bomb himself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, right.
I am now going to use that teleport to go back to that wiggly one up there.
No!
I've losing the will to live.
Just get me out of here.
Right.
If I go here and I take a right, I definitely have access to whatever that right one is.
Wasted.
Surely saved.
Yes, thank God.
Mission failed.
I'll get him next time.
Just spawn me on whatever you want.
It's fine.
I need to take a right?
Like this way?
Yeah, go that way.
And get her gone.
Is this the last NDA?
NDA.
I just saw that in the corner of my eye.
No.
You can AI lock to something else because it ain't me, buddy.
It ain't me that you're AI locking to.
Get out of here.
Get out of here with that.
I'm no even entertaining.
I am taking so much fall damage just to...
Wait, I've already been here before.
I just need to go left now.
I might actually have to pop, heal, and...
Yeah, okay, lovely.
Can you...
Yeah, do that.
Yeah, and then get the heck out of here.
Oh, my gosh, golly.
This is just running similar.
I'm literally Tracer from Overwatch.
Maybe I'll be Tracer.
Should've been Widowmaker.
What about Widowmaker?
What about Bastion?
They're Bastion.
You're a race of Winston.
I will not be Winston.
How about Genji?
I'm already Genji.
What about McCree?
I already chose McCree.
Right.
What's your idea?
Should've been...
Any other...
Right, if I come back the way I came from,
I can hit whatever that big sector is.
I assume this has to be the last mission.
Like, this is for map design...
For map...
Maybe not right now,
whilst all the navi are on my butthole.
That'd be great not to get some luck.
Um...
Oh, just make me Invis.
Should I pick Mercy?
Okay, watch your stream.
Mercy up in one hour ten.
I repeat, Mercy up in one hour ten.
I believe everyone is offline for the day,
but Mercy is online in one hour ten.
And of course, my Invis is gonna run out right on this guy.
Have I got straight ahead, actually?
I don't know what to do.
I'm getting so close to him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We knew, we knew.
We knew there's no point in being pretending.
Azura is still playing one shot.
Oh, Azura is still on map.
Apologies, Azura is currently playing one shot
if you are interested in that.
If you are...
Buy Azura, buy Azura, buy Azura!
She's playing one shot.
Which is not super hot,
which I actually thought it was super hot.
I am currently sharing tree branches.
I don't know what to do
because I'm gonna get knocked off,
which is not what I want at all.
So I'm actually gonna have to fight.
I can't believe it.
I'm actually gonna have to fight for one.
Yeah, sorry.
We cannot be sharing tree branches.
These trees are too skinny for me to not perish.
Buy Azura, buy Azura.
What is getting me now?
Oh my God, it's a boss.
This is a boss ring?
This, this is a boss ring.
You have got to be kidding me.
I don't...
This is exactly what I didn't want to happen.
I'm sorry, but he's gonna have to come down here
and fight me like a man.
I can clear all these guys at least.
Ooh, I'm not gonna enjoy this fight.
I can tell you that much.
Yeah, I need to clear out all the other little guys first.
Well, little, I'm little,
but there's literally nothing I can do
until all of these guys are gone.
I'm just, I'm just...
Relax.
I am literally, they are going invisible
so I can't see anything.
Okay, back off.
Seriously, back off.
This isn't funny anymore.
I'm no laughing.
I'm no getting sniped.
Well, the quest...
No.
Rob, Rob, you're gonna have to give me a chance.
AI, AI, you're gonna have to give me a chance
to clear these guys out.
And now the dogs are joining in.
It's fine.
Everyone just freaking unanimously...
Gang...
No, I can't say that word.
What do you know what I mean?
This is game.
Rob, Rob, Rob.
What am I supposed to do?
Go and be real.
Be real.
Be hashtag real.
These are gonna need gears to break.
Gear break, gear break, gear break, gear break, gear break, gear break.
Are you guys infinitely spawning?
Or is this just getting really unlucky?
Are they infinitely spawning or am I just...
Oh, right, no.
Let's get rid of the freaking flame sword
because it's just absolutely nothing for us.
A bush boss!
Right, well, I'm sure whatever.
Wait.
Is everyone on go right now?
I've killed his...
thing.
Oh, his navi's gone, so he's dead.
Oh, his navi's gone, so he's a human now?
Am I done?
No!
Oh!
This has to be the last mission.
Hold on, let me reload.
What's going on here?
Here.
Wait, hold on, I need ammo.
He, like, flew off.
I'm sorry, but the full damage would have been enough.
Oh, thank goodness, Gravy, he's perished.
Don't ever come back again.
You're not fun to deal with.
Right, where'd any go?
I'll go here, and then if I go southward, I'll get the next one.
The anti-strongy coalition has been founded by the navi.
Literally...
Literally let me destroy nature and peace.
I'll go this way?
Yes.
Let's get to it.
Everybody look for two.
Oh, you weren't...
Wait, what are they fighting?
They're fighting each other.
Right, go, no, no, go fight the navi.
Then they border with me.
You were fighting him a minute ago, all willy-nilly.
Then you look at me all of a sudden.
No, I haven't.
What am I supposed to be doing here?
Hold on.
Put me up here so I can see.
Oh, I'm supposed to go down.
Oh, that's not nice.
Who's doing that?
What's that?
Whoever's doing that, you stop that.
I can see you shooting it, but I can't see you.
Yeah, stop.
Cease your activities.
That's ridiculous, the plant.
Being able to freaking send off a bomb like that.
Who wrote this game?
I'd say I can write better, but that's not true.
No, I have to go all the way around to get down there.
There's no way to fall down there safely.
Well, well, I need to do a big ol' U-turn.
Do you hate the navi yet?
No, I hate playing the RDA, say, to deal with the navi.
I can see that much very strongly.
But I don't understand how there's plants around here
that the navi can claim,
because it's not like I can utilize it.
I'm just bombing everything.
Actually, I probably just bomb myself, you know that.
Unless I can get out here fast enough.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, we need to do that.
Okay, please tell me I did them all.
I didn't do them all?
Oh, it was to grab a crystal.
My apologies, didn't realize.
My apologies, my apologies.
I suck, I suck, but it's okay.
Please don't do that, please don't do that.
Please don't corner me, because that's not really...
Ooh, not good.
I am in the rock, I am in the rock.
I am in the rock, I am in the rock, I am in the rock, I am in the rock.
Let me out, let me out, let me out, let me out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right.
You can throw me in that direction, throw me in that direction.
Ractomy! Right, no, no, no, no, you're taking the piss.
You're taking the piss, you're taking the piss, you're taking the piss.
You don't need to do that.
Please stop embodying on me.
I'm trying to dodge the aim, but I don't have health unlock.
I can heal now.
I'm gonna go next.
I can almost go in viz, I can almost go in viz.
Hold on, where's the last thing that I need to go to?
If I take...
If I just go back to where I came from?
That sounds...
I mean, if I go back to that hotel, where did I get there though?
I go forward and take a right?
Surely.
I'm a bit disoriented on this map.
If I take a right on this log...
If I get on that log, then I should be able to...
Do you mind?
Honestly, give me a jumpscare whenever he is over...
Like, hanging about, honestly, I can't believe it.
I can't believe that you're hanging about on your planet, honestly.
It's just so good.
They really wanted you to know that the RDA or the bad guys
are literally so punishing to play the RDA side.
Sorry, but like, Navi is so easy.
I'm gonna send over critical, but I don't think the game is balanced well.
It just seems like, unless I'm missing the gun
that you're supposed to use in quotation marks,
I am getting brutally...
Oh no, I don't use the teleport.
I do a 180.
And I go this way, just to make triple sure.
I do not want to take off in the wrong direction.
It's punishing, but fun.
If it's fun for you to watch me get punished, then sure.
Punish me away, but this is...
Raging just thinks I'm just doing so bad.
I can hear the end again.
They gave you a guard down for stealth, no run kills.
Oh, honestly.
Watch over here.
I hope this is the area.
I'm gonna cry if this is like a dead end up here.
Both to play and watch you, honestly.
I never understood streamers that can punish themselves over and over with the same game.
I just don't...
Wow, that's what I don't want.
None of that.
I swear if there's a dog behind me, stop it!
Okay, that's him there.
I'm really not interested in going down to get wrecked by all the other NPCs as well,
but I don't think...
I almost just forfeited all that progress right there.
That's my shotgun, and you put that away so I can do rounds.
Who are you?
This is getting rough.
Oh, come on, come on, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
You know you want to, you know you want to, you know you want to get that health bar to zero for me, baby.
Oh no, fall down it.
Right, I'm not going to go in the vines next time.
He was honestly taking a hammer in.
I feel sorry for making you play the RDA side.
Okay, I've respawned in the area, which is good but bad because the NPCs are literally all...
Okay, okay.
We actually didn't lose the progress on the health bar.
I don't think I've seen that before, but lol.
Oof.
Oh wow, just spawn all the NPCs together, I don't know.
No, it's fine.
I didn't want to live anyway.
Alright, I won't be showing that to him.
Oh, come on.
Oh, let me reload, let me reload.
And I can deal with you.
Oh wow, I'm actually out of ammo, that's how much you've made me spawn that ship.
No.
Can you aim? Can you aim? Hello?
Oh, for crying out loud.
Can you aim at the freaking guy that is literally one millimeter from your eyeball?
Yeah, you're getting...
I thought I dealt with you.
Don't even bother, Mike.
Was he shooting the buggy?
I think he was, honestly.
Oh, this game is going to give me a heart attack.
Right, I just need to make it back to this person and then I think I'm done with the worst map ever.
This map belongs under my sweaty feet.
Never to be allowed to breathe fresh, dry air again.
That was awful.
And I wish not to ever be subjected to this.
Because, oh my gosh.
I know there's buggies everywhere but I don't even want to get in them because they just explode in a millisecond.
Goes to the trash.
Ah, so it's a good map. No.
It deserves nothing but my manky, sweaty grippers.
Paramersweep.
Oh my god.
Don't...
Don't give me another map like hanging gardens again.
Hanging gardens? It makes me want to hang myself.
Thank you. I'll be here all week.
And...
Oh, I've still not defeated Harper.
Okay, I guess we'll go.
Another map after this.
Hi, officer.
More.
More. It's not over.
Wait, say it again with the bidons.
Wait, say what again? Tell me.
Tell me I've already forgotten what I'm supposed to say.
What did I say? I've already forgotten.
What am I supposed to say?
I'm ready. I'm ready for what I'm supposed to say.
Oh, what's the map called? I've already forgotten.
I just picked up a signal way out there.
It's not much, but it's something.
Alright.
The map's called hanging gardens?
More like I want to hang myself.
Thank you. Thank you.
Appreciate it. Appreciate it.
Oh my god.
I've still not done another fucking map.
I just want to go there and...
I actually have to go there.
I've never seen someone say,
Why are we still in the front?
Relatable.
We'll be here all week.
We'll be here all week on this freaking one map.
On this one map.
They really did not want anyone to have fun on the RDS.
Like literally.
I want to say this is the Harper fight.
And then I think that's it.
No.
I'm not even scared anymore.
I am annoyed.
If I take a right,
then
either way I'm going to make it to the location.
Some people enjoy suffering,
myself included.
But do you enjoy watching suffering?
Like,
I actually don't mind watching like a binding of Isaac runs.
And if the person like struggles to get through it,
but still wins,
like I don't mind watching.
Like I find it quite entertaining.
Alright.
If I take the vines across.
Yeah.
Oh, and there you are.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Please don't do that.
Oh, wait.
No, they're going to push me off the freaking vines.
If I go up.
Stop.
Stop spanking me.
It's Emmy who has that audio this month.
Okay.
Not me.
I do not have that kind of audio this month.
I need to go down.
No, I better not need to go down.
Some of them they are.
What?
I need...
Well,
I'm a bit scared to go on this in all honesty.
Oh.
Right.
A boss fight with Harper.
Got it.
What kind of audio do we have this month?
I have sent train in one.
I'm trying to remember the other two off the top of my hand.
I should kind of recall.
One of them is part of my 1.4.
I have two four-parter series and part one comes out.
I almost just did what you think I almost just did.
I almost fell off the map doing that man over there.
That was very scary.
Yeah, rather not you should have changed yourself to suffering.
Oh, that just cancelled my invisibility.
Okay.
That's fine.
No, I totally didn't need that.
It's not like the cooldown time is like a whole 60 seconds or something.
Oh.
Yes.
Thank you.
Please.
Oh, shoot them.
I can't be bothered anymore.
After this,
I don't really like...
Oh, after things,
I don't really like when you have that time.
Seals women the year.
If this human is just miserable,
the whole time is in this one.
It's not too bad.
Like honestly,
I'm actually enjoying to see what the RDA said is,
but this map
size is
mercenary.
Oh, new outfit.
All right.
Girl moment.
Let's see what we look like.
Wait.
Oh, right.
No.
So this is Max.
Max protection.
Well, I'll take Max protection.
And now we need to go
this way.
What's that?
I'm to take one of these.
Shoot.
How do I shoot?
I've already fun.
Um, no.
Oh, A.G.
Louise.
Let's do that one.
What's over here?
Oh.
Lost Cathedral?
Cathedral?
It kind of reminds me of the underground cave
in Skyrim.
Why is the music even scarier?
Oh, please be a small map.
Oh, it's a small map.
Thank y'all.
Thank you.
I fit small.
What just got me?
Who?
Are they above me?
It must be the Navi above me.
Okay, the Navi.
Oh, there he is.
Mm-hmm.
Um, I have a problem.
And that problem is everyone has height advantage over me.
Yeah, this.
Unless they come down and bite me,
I am in so much trouble.
Oh, dear.
I'm going to get sniped out of that.
I don't have infinite ammo.
I can't be messing around like that.
Is there really no way for me to go up?
Unless it's over here I get up?
No.
Wow, this is like really rare to see in a video game.
Unless I'm just, I don't play many video games.
I really do not recall levels where you can't even reach the person.
I don't know, maybe I'm being silly.
Yeah, see this is...
Right, you can go.
Right, one down.
I don't know how much health he has, but...
Bro, I can't, I cannot be spraying him with pistols, like...
Oh wait, I have infinite ammo here.
Silly me, silly Billy.
Hold on.
I saw that shooting.
I just spray him the entire time then?
I mean, I'll do it, don't think I won't.
You don't have to tell me twice if it's a spring-free mission, sure.
He just runs around in circles over and over.
Sadly, I can't seem to reach the other NPCs.
Oh, they're attacking me, they're actually getting me.
They're jumping me!
Yeah, whoa!
The AI is so brutal as a nazi.
Sorry, hold on a minute.
I'm starting to...
I don't know if I should actually just focus on the main guy, you know what?
Instead of the... I don't know if they're infinitely respawning or not.
That's the reason why I want to clear them out,
but I'm getting the feeling they're infinitely respawning.
Maybe?
Oh, I just destroyed that plant.
Where is he?
No.
Wow, I'm like actually struggling.
Wow.
Okay, half health.
I think just moan, I think just moan down.
That's the best I got.
Oh, and I'm out of ammo.
Just moan down.
I'm just gonna tank it.
I am, I really am.
Where is he going?
Yeah, this definitely is giving, like, battle dome unending.
Thanks for waiting around until I stand up again.
I actually do appreciate that, AI.
Oh, that's not good.
That's really not good.
This is what I was worried about,
but there's definitely more spawning,
and I'm not quite sure what the answer is.
Other than spray him.
That's really the best I can do.
Just hope that my weak cross here is going on.
He is getting staggered.
There's no denying that.
But the Navi are getting out of control up here.
I don't have high...
The plants keep respawning.
I don't know if maybe the plants have got something to do with it.
The battle rifle can help you in this moment.
Are you the battle rifle?
No, you're not.
Wait.
No, you're the shotgun.
Wait, am I dumb?
What have I got?
Shotgun and shotgun.
Ah, well, that makes a lot of sense
where I don't feel like nothing's happening right now.
What gun?
The battle rifle.
Battle rifle.
Or any head launcher,
Neil Gunn.
Is it actually called battle rifle?
I've got an assault rifle,
but I think that's what I've got.
Is she rifle?
I've got machine gun standard.
Hold on, heal up.
Okay, let's try this.
Oh, hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm just fluffing on my face.
Hold on.
Are you damaging?
Leave it.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's like a triple barf.
Okay, it's triple barf.
Little...
We're trying.
That's the main thing.
We can do it.
We can 100% do it.
I believe.
It's just going to take its sweet time,
especially if the game just constantly is resupplying
with new Navi for this guy.
It makes me think this is the last boss fight
in the last map, though,
because this is big.
Like, this is big fight.
This is...
I'm going to put protection prayer on.
I can hardly see his body to shoot, though.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're freaking dead.
We don't have to do...
Okay, okay.
Oh, he's mad.
I foiled his plans.
He said,
Okay, let's...
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Let me get up.
Let me go up.
Hello?
I can't even heal,
because I'm getting pushed against a wall.
Oh, I've swapped to pistols.
Thank you for swapping to pistols.
The most useless out of everything.
No, it's very much needed right now.
Very much needed.
The most useless...
No.
I need to go.
My invis...
Yeah, my invis literally...
I'm going to heal on a rock.
Yeah, and I'm pressed up against it,
so there's actually nothing I can do.
Dog, you're going to have to let me breathe
through your sleep video game.
This is like...
I'm just going to run away.
It's the best thing I can do right now.
Do not engage.
Oh, come on.
Who said the same thing?
Oh, no.
No, no.
I did not want this.
Oh, goodness.
Yeah, I think I've actually died.
You know that?
I've only got one cell thing.
I'm glad I have protection up,
but...
I actually don't have faith.
You know that?
I'm losing faith.
I do not believe...
unless I can grab these quick enough.
I literally don't have a revive,
if I go down, by the way.
Yeah, see this?
The amount of abilities they use...
I'm sure I could probably be
utilizing my abilities better,
but this prayer protection...
is so constant!
It's so fucking constant!
I really hope nothing else respawns.
I can't tolerate this.
I don't think I should have been using that other gun.
No, that's shotgun.
If he's gonna get stuck,
I will happily take that, please.
Please, stun lock,
and don't do anything different.
Oh, my God.
More spawned in.
Please, I literally don't have a revive.
I honestly don't have a revive.
You know, I have ammo, look at me.
Where did he go?
Oh, lovely.
I feel like a Lara Croft.
Oh, my God!
Did I have reef?
I don't even have it.
Please!
No more battles!
Please, I'm on my knees!
Oh, I can't.
I genuinely, wholeheartedly,
I'm not gonna make it if they make me do it anymore.
Is that up here?
No, sorry.
I need to find revives,
but I don't have any more revives,
and I keep getting locked in.
On your knees, I'm not even kidding.
On my knees, please, devs,
tell me you didn't do it anymore.
I think I'm genuinely gonna lose this.
Like, lose the game,
because I don't have a revive,
and I don't know what happens if you perish
without a revive.
On your knees for a head pat.
Oh, I genuinely don't have a revive.
I feel like we're about to enter some massive boss fight.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of the Hanging Gardens.
You're dying to keep your town, really?
Shocking behavior.
Oh.
How am I back here again?
I think because I'm not killing...
Navi.
Well, teammates and all, right?
Yeah, right.
Meet me back at Hell's Gate.
This should be the last harmonic.
No.
I have protection for now.
I think it is because I'm not...
What are you...
They're all aiming on something.
Because I'm not picking, like,
Heart and Navi,
I'm not able to pick up more revives,
but, like, I'm in danger.
I don't know if I'm going to win this.
I don't know what happened, so...
On your knees ready to create a James Cameron himself,
literally.
I'm like, did they play test this
for, like, noobs?
This is, like, soul play?
Monroe's gone missing.
Things are going bad to worse.
You'll have to upload the harmonic without him.
Monroe's missing the guy?
He's been rounding up the scientists
and anyone else who questions his authority.
We're running out of time.
We need to find that door...
He really is the body, jeez.
It has to be you who activates the emulator.
If you get control of the well of souls,
you can put a stop to this madness.
Get started.
I'm gonna go check for Monroe.
Okay, let's deal.
So we are about to hit endgame.
Oh, yeah, we're in the endgame now.
But Alcooo actually kills your scientists, man.
Yeah.
They probes didn't play any at all.
They had one play tester.
And he just did the Navi side as well.
Are you trying to finish the campaign?
Yes, we finished the Navi.
We finished the RDA side.
However, he's not in his office.
What's that?
Resource development?
Oh, wow, I actually can't go...
I actually can't go in his office space.
That's a very small detail.
Oh, well.
The office is scared.
Alcooo is always evil.
Yeah, he's like evil till the end.
We can do it. We just not need to die.
Or get walled off by like three Navi at once.
Going into his office space to take his red line stapler?
Stapler?
Why are you so stupid?
Okay, she gives me a thumbs up now.
Wait, so you need to stop Falco in either scenario, anyway?
Oh!
So you never actually hurt Pandora, either way?
Path of Goliath?
Hydration check.
My voice is dying.
Okay.
I hope we can put a stop to Falco with a...
Wait, no.
I was gonna make a joke and then that's not funny.
Because it doesn't work.
My joke doesn't work, so I can't make it.
Falco's gone nuts.
Basically, scenario is planning on using it to take over the plan for himself.
Lightly, scenario, world ending.
Dude, I was gonna make a Falcon Punch joke.
I'm gonna be like, oh, I'm gonna Falcon Punch if I just don't want him.
Tell him, okay, alright, okay.
Oh, we need to stop Falcon.
Maybe we'll give him a Falcon Punch.
Oh, sorry, sorry guys.
Sorry.
You want crickets on that one instead?
Sorry about that.
Please!
Well, this map looks more forgiven for one rate away,
because my goodness, that last one was just in the nightmare.
I have access to mechs in this map, which is curious.
They don't always have a lot of crickets.
They don't always have an access to mech.
Yeah, tough crowd.
Not allowed to go out that way, or...
Excuse me, I would like to out, please.
Can only go out of the green doors, got it.
That one green?
Nope, that one's red.
Not only one door to go out of, for some odd reason.
Give him a Falcon Need to the Moon, first of all.
Oh, to the north, sorry.
Right, those are from the...
I basically just go all the way straight ahead,
and I can pick a tree and then come back and get him.
Yeah, they're like so much easier like this.
Oh my God.
Section Challenge Initiated.
Oh, there's one...
Jumping mech.
I don't know if I should get out and pick up these RDS things.
You know that, because I actually don't have a second chance.
I might against my better judgement, I hope I'm right.
At least if I can have one revive, I don't need to panic too much.
Just need one revive.
Should I camp for it, maybe?
Maybe not, maybe not.
I still don't have one though, I need one more kill.
I'll get out when I find the next one.
Oh my God, it's time for three!
Okay, what if I go this way?
It's still the right path.
Okay, what's the path?
Alright, run it over.
Oh, I need one RDA, one RDA.
Two can earn.
I'm just glad I'm allowed to bring the mech for once.
There's a Warhawk too.
Okay, there's one there.
But if it's safe to get out, I will pick it up, but...
Okay.
I'm getting hammered.
There, we'll grab this one.
Whoa, whoa!
This is what I didn't want.
Can I get into our camp, please?
No, I can't, I'm not allowed to get back in,
because I've just gone ahead and destroyed it, lovely jewel blue.
I'm going to quickly get this teleport up here,
just because...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting it, I'm getting it.
The mech is so fun, just moving down.
Just mowing down the Nuffie in the little wild life.
That's him.
But it's so true, really.
Alright, let's try this.
Maybe we can get around and not be so annihilated.
Oh, lovely, it doesn't even let you pass.
Oh, there.
A terrible driver.
Oh, okay, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
We've made it nice and impossible to drive as they always do.
Can I even get past that?
Okay, Justin no more.
Give me a little spank there.
I hope they're here.
I can, it's green, thank goodness.
Let's have to beat this teleport station.
And then, we can start the mission location.
You're getting bow-inked so hard.
I heard good things.
I'm Colonel Clark.
Our assault is underway on the Navi strongholds.
But these guys fight like animals.
I need you to go in and get their top of command.
Break the morale and turn the tide in our favor.
Let's turn the tide.
Commander Falco's running on his own.
If I don't stop him.
You think you're running your own show?
That was Falco's mistake.
We're trying to stop Falco, but if we don't take out the commander's first,
I saw the AMP between the gate and where you are now.
A free amp?
Oh, sorry, possibly.
They spawned it.
Is it encouraged from the guy from his first movie?
I think so.
They seem to have been able to get the likeness of everyone.
Like Sigourney Weaver was at the start of it as well.
So it seems like when this game was made,
they got the rights to do some tricks.
The new brass said they were sending me a problem solver.
I should have known it was you.
How's your day been, Batista?
Painful.
I got a whole list of them.
I don't think I've ever heard that name.
Batista.
The blues keep sending in their damn birds to turn us back.
How can I help?
Batista.
They ain't moving until their leader comes.
Go by the name of Swata.
You make Swata go ta ta.
And I bet the rest of them will leave us alone.
I knew you would be.
Okay, another boss that you fight.
Yippee!
Where is he?
Um, right.
Can I take a car, please?
Just to really speed things up.
I don't, I have to admit that last map.
Absolutely.
Oof.
That was rough.
But this map, like, literally,
they're giving you, like, so much stuff.
I assume I can glide over the water with this.
So I'm just going to automatically break now.
Oh, sorry.
If they give, literally give me a bit of mobility
and make it easy to move around,
then it's all good.
Is it left or right up here?
It's a right.
Oops, sorry.
That was a rock.
I didn't see it.
I've not got my glasses on.
Tee-hee.
Oops, I'm hitting the curb.
Tee, just Tee-hee.
A little Tee-hee moment.
Sorry, sorry.
I need my lights on.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Never saw that, my bad.
Right, I'm doing a circle, I guess.
And I'm going back on the road over here.
Oh.
Wait, what the heck is the road?
Here?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, right.
I'll just see you take a right.
Oh, it's a tight, it's a tight left.
Sorry.
I don't know the difference between my left and right.
I'm not even going to pretend otherwise.
Got to stick my hand up in order to know what it's what.
Right, okay, okay.
Let's just speed around down.
Yep, let's just do that.
And then we just gently can't claim it.
Can't claim it.
Can't claim it or can't claim it?
Bank!
Oh, I've got my bus banked by two of them at once.
Please don't.
Did they know how to claim?
Or how?
Oh, they've not been coded to claim.
I like it.
Oh, it's cool.
Cut off his driving moment.
Look, I got eight arms.
It's hard to like really figure it one.
I can try to.
I'm claiming very high.
Final boss question mark, maybe?
Whoa, why is he?
Oh.
They are responsible for your Falco's madness.
You can stop Falco and you can help people.
Wait, am I allowed to join them?
Or am I not to join them?
Oh, I don't even have a...
Choose a side in this final battle.
Wait, what did I do?
Freedom of choice.
Attempt, good or remain evil.
Not join.
I'm supposed to be evil.
RDA?
Hmm.
Okay.
Wait, what did I do?
Did I choose...
I want to choose RDA, so I stand in RDA, right?
I want to be evil, so I stand in the RDA side.
Right?
Choose to stay with RDA.
He's taking his bow out!
Oh my God, I literally just heard the sound effect.
Uh...
Mate, you're going to have to give me some space, mate.
You never tasted lead before.
I'm sure you haven't since we humans came here.
Oh, fuck.
And now I'm eating lead.
I'm eating the freaking bow string.
Oh!
I didn't...
Oh my!
While I leave you in the hands of fate.
Um...
I did not expect that, Lamal.
I guess I just go back, please.
It...
That...
Yeah, get move fast, though, honestly.
Right, if I go...
Wait, how did I even get here?
I climbed up.
Can I climb down on these, or does it not let you climb down?
I don't want to get...
Oh no, it does let you climb down.
How strange.
I remember I touched that rope, another one,
and the option never came up.
It's still going strong as already.
It looks like...
What did I miss?
Um...
You missed the last map, which was horrific,
and you should actually be...
Am I going the right way?
I'm getting so kind of them.
You should be really glad you missed it.
The map layout was horrific.
Like, it was telling you to go like all these different ways,
and it was all squiggly wiggly,
and super detailed and complete.
You scared me!
Oh, please drive.
Right, just get back on the road
and go the path I've already been.
Oh, oh, I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to hurt you, little horse.
Uh, then take a right or a left.
Take a right.
And then...
Whoa!
Oh, I thought it was a cliff.
Whoa, camera angle.
You could be...
I have to admit, the camera angle could be
a wee bit more, like, forgiven.
It's, like, constantly wanting to, like,
drive me into the ground for some reason.
Up my way, RDA.
Cause you're in my way, RDA.
I said you're in my way, RDA.
It's up my way, RDA.
It's cinema.
Navi jumpscare.
After all these struggles getting bullied by the AI,
the game felt bad and was just letting me,
like, get through it.
Seriously, that last map, though.
I'll take that one to my grave.
We just hate the hanging cliff.
Woo-wee!
Yeah, you're not gonna wait until the...
Yeah.
103 field commanders.
Okay.
And then, surely, the game's over.
Mm-hmm.
Alright, we're heading...
How far away is it? Oh!
Someone was smart enough to go ahead
and activate that teleport just in case
we were doing a little back and forth.
And...
We actually need to teleport to it.
I am so smart.
S-M-A-R-T.
I was gonna do the Homer Simpson way.
S-M-R-T.
I am so smart.
Said you're in my way, R-T-A.
Oh!
Well...
You know what? I've literally just spawned here.
I'm going to come down, actually.
Actually, everyone just pause.
I've been reported here, and I'm already getting...
enrolled.
Oh, so now you're agreeing with me, smart.
No, the S-M-R-T.
That...
Well, let's hope there's not too many...
How is there a tree of souls here?
Unless, when you swap to the Navi,
you get a Navi body?
That's what I need.
He's on a Thanator!
Yeah!
I need height advantage.
Is there anything I can take height advantage on?
There's a f***ing thing going to chase me on my boho!
I'm now getting...
I'm now getting wrecked by his pals as well.
Not cast... I cast protection.
I just activated, like, five NPCs
to join in!
I can't even run out of the way in time.
This is insane!
This is insane.
I don't know what to do.
There's, like, literally nothing I can cheese on.
Please, can I cheese on this?
Oh, please, oh, please let me cheese on this so badly.
Please, please.
Oh, my God, let me cheese on this so badly.
Let me cheese on this so badly.
I'm cheesing!
I'm cheesing so hard right now.
I'm not cheesing!
I know!
Okay, okay, they all got pushed off.
They all got pushed off.
Oh, my God!
Uncheese! Uncheese!
Uncheese command! Uncheese command!
Right now, uncheasing.
Uncheasing.
You are all going to need to, like,
stop with this freaking blasting thing.
This is an absolute nightmare.
Like, all of them are using...
I can't...
I can't.
I hate to be the
uh, oo-oo girl that goes,
I literally can't right now!
I literally can't right now.
I don't even know where the Thanator is.
Is the Thanator stuck?
I hope I've at least cheesed the Thanator.
Are you stuck?
Oh, thank the maker!
Thank the maker!
This is a buggy old 2009 game.
He led
in puke
because, oh, my
gosh, this game is so hard.
So hard.
I heard that. I heard you.
I literally just heard you spawning.
Oh, yeah, and just heal up. No, it's fine, it's fine.
Just heal all your health, it's fine.
It doesn't matter.
No, it doesn't matter at all.
Get out of my face!
No! No!
All the time!
Get out! I'm literally
freaking walling on stuff.
Go away!
Stop healing!
Stop!
I need to reload like this.
Right now.
Yeah, hold on. Let me take a breather.
I just needed one breather.
Literally a second.
Formulate a thought!
Ah!
Ah, the freaking...
I'm trying so hard.
I literally am trying so hard.
This is just...
And then there's just small more navi there.
They're coming down the hill.
No, I'm stuck against something.
Oh, please!
Please!
Oh.
I'm...
I cast protection.
Oh.
Oh, and I'm...
I don't do that.
Don't do that again. That's not funny.
I'm going to fucking lose it
if I actually die here.
Go and just perish!
To the elements or something!
This is insane!
This is...
No.
Get staggered beyond belief
and they don't stagger when they use that ability.
And their ability,
freaking, is on cooldown.
There's no such thing as cooldown to them.
They actually don't know what it is.
But my cooldown lasts forever!
Literally, I can't even cast protection.
Oh, and I need to reload at the stupid
freaking orange box!
And I've got one!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No one's surprised!
Freaking spraying!
There's literally no more health.
And you just do it again!
Again with the same move!
Oh, this is getting ridiculous, mate.
I'm going to just get a rest, honestly.
Oh, and you'd repel back to health again
because you can't even just 1v
fucking 1v!
Literally, I'm not being funny, but
if these are supposed to be avatars
with titanium bones and stuff,
and you literally can't 1v 1v
without fucking prayer protection on
every 2 seconds
with that stupid move!
Oh, fucking terrible ass game.
Just perish!
Honestly, stop using these abilities!
Oh, my!
God, man!
Yay, we did it!
Let's go!
Oh, I'm so glad that's over with.
Let's move on to the next one.
Yippee!
Yeah, and they're already showing me.
Alright, we'll teleport.
GG, easy.
I keep forgetting that I'm not as tall
as Navi, so I can't just, like, jump
it. Oh, well, I
didn't need to go on that, so, sure, whatever.
We did it!
That was awful.
You don't even pick
the difficulty in this thing.
My controller is literally dripping with sweat.
I thought you loved having autism.
It's such a nice little fun treat on the side, isn't it?
Not.
Oh, and I get to do one more.
The protection prayer made me think
this was a runescape stream for a second.
Yeah, literally.
If I could cast it.
Oh.
Is there a donation? Did I miss a donation?
I think it's working.
I don't know. Someone said they couldn't, but then
I think a few more donations came
after that, so I don't know
if it's messing up on
Firefox or things are just not happy.
Don't worry about it
if it's not working.
Oh, sorry.
I just...
I just choked on that.
Did you plane?
Take a scorpion and report to the
last commander.
Let's try it.
You'll read it later.
I just sent one a bit ago.
I don't see it.
You're not the only one to say
that you've sent a thingy, but it's not came
through. I don't know why.
The last one I see
is from TinySpiny.
It says I've returned from the job.
Wait, did it actually not go through?
I don't want you to don't know if it's not
showing up, seriously, though.
Like, if it's not showing up, don't.
Um...
What was going on?
Where the heck?
What were you not supposed to go on?
Can I just fly through that?
Oh, no, I have to fly through the gap.
I can already tell.
The last commander
sends promising.
I f***ing hope so.
The RDA said
it's been an experience,
but I'm not sure
it's been one for...
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's just break through the rocks, don't mind me.
Don't worry, mom's happy to support my local calm fish.
I know I wouldn't display though.
Where am I going?
Just a little to the right.
Oh, my goodness, Bolly.
Okay, there's the helipad
that I'm supposed to land on.
Make it nice and easy for me.
Oop, oop. A little cheeky crash land in there,
don't mind me.
Is this not it?
Looks like it.
At least when it's over, you can see
you've finally completed the game.
Honestly, it's been fun,
but there's a reason my Tism
didn't attach on this game too much
because there's quite a few things like that.
That was killing me.
Hey, last one.
Oh.
The only reason I could even win that
last fight is because I managed
to cheat that Thanotaur.
I can't imagine if I would even get past that
if that Thanotaur didn't get caught in the road.
I'm sorry.
I said that wrong.
Oh.
Am I allowed to slide to get there?
Or is it a mix?
If I give a mix, I'll take a mix
if it's giving me a mix.
Then you can play the domination minigame.
I like on the Navi side.
I've never played it on this side.
Alrighty.
If I take a right, then everything
shall be alright.
Let's hope this last one.
Strony, you seem sleepy.
I hope you're having fun.
Yeah, I'm having fun. I know I sound like
that's if I punch.
I'm getting spawned
by a freaking plant.
I'm enjoying it.
It's just because I've never played it before
and
I just did not expect
at all how unbelievably hard it was.
For example, there's RDA soldiers
literally getting
messed up by these
plants and they're just letting it
happen and it's just like
I had no idea they would make it
so hard if I was going to be...
Because the Navi side, honestly, you can just ignore
everything, but when you're a wee
human, you actually can't ignore
everything or else you're like a big doo-doo.
I mean, it's not that easy.
It really is.
I'm hoping I do
get a good night's sleep soon because
it's really hard to be creative and do
ASMR collabs like coming up with scripts
when I've literally got like no thoughts
of doing ASMR collabs.
I'm actually going to
pick that up because
they're too valuable.
Wait, I can't even go up one more.
Okay, I need to climb like one foot.
RDA side to real
sad. I hope you're doing a good night's
sleep. Yeah, I'm like
I've not had a decent
one in quite a while. Oh my
god, there's so many of them.
Okay, that was good. I like
that. I think it's heritage that fast
like all the time, that'd be great.
Oh, see, when it
miss...
When it misses, it really
bothers me.
Oh, I'm just going to biz. I don't know.
There's enemies everywhere.
Oh, I can hear one right behind me.
I'm going to try and claim this before
default. Get some rest.
I will get some good rest. I don't know
what my stream is tomorrow. I can't remember.
Is it ASMR?
Or is that a small game?
I think it goes ASMR
sweets.
Oh, this is a boss fight.
Yeah, I'm already getting ruled. Oh, I'm already
getting ruled by boss. Okay,
this is what I can't stand.
I'm about to go do a boss fight
and there's like a billion rub.
Nah, nah, come on,
mate.
Yeah, this is getting
ridiculous.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank goodness I was picking up my RDA
things.
Whoa.
No, no, you're so dead.
Get that.
Right, a spell of protection, spell
of invincibility, because
what the actual
bro, you're going to need to let
I'm dead
I need a breather.
I literally need a health breather.
The AI can
freaking see me.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
She literally won't go down
because she keeps activating all of her abilities.
This is ridiculous.
Right, so they're
Okay.
Bro, you're just stun-locking me.
I literally can't get close enough.
Yeah, how do you
like being fucking stun-locked?
Oh, fuck!
Just infinite
spawn after
spot, so get the fucking moab out, honestly.
What the
fucking is this shit, honestly?
Uh, have I activated it?
Hello? Stun it?
Lovely.
Mm, let me analize.
That did a sweet fuck all.
Right, lovely, lovely.
Don't ever show your fucking hideous face again.
That was what bloody waste that was.
Uh, right, that's the best I got.
Berserk.
Berserk's literally the best I got.
And I get
stunned the moment I use it.
Bro, I need to put
I need to put a little invisible on
so I can literally heal in time.
Yeah.
And get stunned the millisecond.
This is why
I don't play read games on stream
because I literally can't even handle a normal game.
Yeah, and then invisible again,
so I can't get them the entire time they're shooting at me
and then stun, and stun, and stun,
and stun, and stun, and stun.
Okay, we get it, we get it, we get it, we get it, we get it.
Stun. We love a good stun, we'll
yep, and then, yep,
and then into stun, right, what their ability
you literally just used
that one so you don't even have a cooldown
at all. Oh, and then
in comes your buddies, in comes
yeah, and then your buddy uses their ability
and then I'm a way
wasting ammo yet again
on not the freaking boss.
You're gonna need to get a break,
so you're gonna need, again, a straight to ability
can't, need to wait, need to wait.
Again, straight to ability,
fucking infinite buddy.
Yep, and then they get, no, oh,
a Christmas miracle, I actually got a fucking thing from it.
Oh, and your pal's already back.
I've not even been away for like a millisecond.
I'm gonna have to go into this fucking
do this, right, at least I've reloaded,
but, yeah,
and I'm already getting spanked.
I don't even know where the fucking enemy
that I'm supposed to be killing is.
Oh, and straight to the ability.
Oh, classic.
Oh, more of your pal's!
There's nothing I can do, there's
literally nothing I can do other than
tick damage, like this is
just the tiniest
amount of damage that can be dealt
at any moment, and it just
over and over again!
Literally playing this game over and over again.
One hit, get nothing more,
have to heal, get nothing more.
Just fucking
perish off, fucking
map!
Uh, I'm dead, I'm actually dead.
I don't have a
Enviz, and I don't have a heal.
I don't know what you want me to do.
Who made this, Ubisoft?
How many game di- how many fucking
playtesters have you got? Like, one max,
maybe? Do you share one for, like, one fucking
region? One for whole of Oceanic,
one for whole of Bloody Europe, one for whole of
fucking America? Like, what's going on?
None of you's playtested this, not one person.
Not one person!
Oh, let me just analyze
and see if this is there, this seems fair.
Mmm... Right, let's uh, let's do
infinite spawning. Uh, let's make sure
you get stun lot, right. Okay,
mmm, right. Alright, let's do it, let's do it,
let's do it! Let's do it, Cheeky Gangbang!
Oh my god,
let's just do it, Cheeky Gangbang, and make
sure that the enemies, enemies are allowed to
infinite heal. It's fine, enemies
can infinite heal, enemies can infinite
fucking use their abilities, all the fucking thing!
And as soon as you give them a
Sanamir! Off of their HP bar!
HP bar. Oh, let's just make sure they just give them everything all at once infinite fucking mana. Oh
my god
Just let it be over with just let it happen. Oh my god
Like I literally need to go invisible
Oh my god, just let it be over
Just let it be over
Again, yeah instant stun lock as soon as you shit. I don't even have that ability is Navi when I play Navi
I don't even have this ability
Just instant fucking lock over and over and and your pals are back
Mate I would absolutely love to have a whole fucking trade behind me, but I've no bloody got that extension have a
I
Best I can do
Hundred got a hundred shotgun shells was now enough
Now you go get more
Cuz it was now of course it was down off. Oh
No, it's fine. No, it's fine. I didn't want to
Yeah, no, it's fine I
I
Love being absolutely incapacitated
I love it you should do it more actually
How about you just spawn eight NPCs all fucking ones at one time? Oh my fucking god
Fucking RDA fan is honestly
Oh, and I'm probably gonna die jumping off this cliff looking me just to really fucking ace it on the cake
They just I actually can't he stop it. They actually
Yeah
Yep, and all aimed even though in this
Continue probably not even be able to heal in time and I get to die
Cuz I only have one fucking RDA element to my fucking name
Yeah
This better be the last mission. I am like fucking correct right now. I
Really hope like I severely hope this is the last mission
Instant damage to the mech not even in the body sign
For the cheeky gang bang party parrot party parrot party parrot
It's never fucking end and vote was it vault
Volcan thank you for the tip. It's never ending. There is no way that was appropriately play tested unless I'm missing like
Some major notes, and I missed a massive patch that came out for this game in 2009 that there's no way
That is the gameplay and then the dev team happy with that gameplay
I
Refused to accept that that even got passed
Absolutely refused to accept that I got past I
Don't think anyone got this far in the place. I think I completely agree with that statement cuz what on earth was that?
Literally, I don't have an ability when I play Navi if I get hit I have a massive fucking throbbing
Fucking pulse coming from a bloody groin. No, I don't want to teleport. I want to talk to the man
That's right right in there
Please let it be over
Let it be over
Let it be over. Yeah, I'm not
Yeah, that Moab did absolutely
the point of that was
Let it be over. Let it be over. Let it be over. Let it be over. Let it be over. Let it be over. Let it be over
Thanks for borrowing a condom
This game was pretty bad pretty fast after lunch. Thanks to the game getting canned hard in the reviews and took their money around
I mean they made them if they got two points living million sales. Yeah
So don't screw up
Yes, sir. Thank you. You can kiss over there
You so much you put a scratch there there last at least the section span over you mean that wasn't the last section
Are you implying there's more to this fucking thing?
Or just ordered you to board a dragon to fly to some location
This is why mommy likes me hold her hand. Yes. This is why I like
This is awful
You're still streaming. Oh, you just missed the part where I screamed down the make so yeah, oh
Please let me go off this road
Why does the conductor keep putting me on? Well, I did they keep creating more and more sections of this fucking site of the map
Okay, this is it. This is it the map looks like this is it. There's nothing more of the matter
Well, we all pretended that you finished the game and you can go risk. No, this is it
Look at the map. There's no way this map is a fetch quest because look at the state of it. There's not an owner. Oh
Oh
Did I get to drive this at least?
It's over
Oh, how do I fly this? Oh fuck me, man. Oh
No, oh no, I don't like that. Oh, no
Right, okay. Oh, yeah. Oh, huh. Oh, yeah, I can fly I can fly
Call me Peter Pan because you can fly you can fly you can fly
Okay, take it easy easy on the corners easy
Pandora is a little wild for the road bumps and by road bumps the full mass of us
You can shoot the rocks
Oh
That makes them
Wait, I'm gonna run out of missiles
Okay
That was a very successful drive, I think I don't think I actually bumped into one thing
Easy easy
Oh
actual
Best landing ever
Okay, there are wolves, but that's fine. Nothing I can't handle. Oh
I can't do my little flip in the water. Do a flip
What kind of sadistic
Made to say you should be able to run out of missiles
Honestly, it does seem a bit like that flight thing that flying dragon is massive and you're telling me they can't hold more than like 20 muscles. Oh
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Why are you holding that piece of paper? Oh, oh
Oh
What's the plan
I'm gonna I'm gonna put down TNT
As long as there's no boss fight, I couldn't be less of a rat's horse what fetch quest you send me on name your boss fights
What is this? What is this armor?
Protection down but everything else up. I think I'd rather protection up
Just leave it leave it
What's this right? What's the deal?
Oh
As long as there's no boss fight on the other side, I couldn't give a rise of a rat's
I'm not keep tolerating any anymore
If the goal was to make the count in pain memorable, they should be sure succeeded
Oh, I'd say more like miserable because
Again, like literally the Navi instantly do that as soon as you injure them. They do their thing
Except that one I guess
Let's just let's navigate we're appropriate
I don't know if I should just speedrun it
Can the mech even go on the bridge that's up ahead it feels like a bridge on my hood and my wee minimap
Oh
Like this game parish definitely, yeah, thanks for that really appreciate that
Why am I being shot I'm being chased I'm being chased
Oh
Yeah, definitely happy to replay that's true brotherhood not happy to replay
The Navi say yay fun the RDA say oh my god
I think I've almost got two revives, but I don't think I have a boss fight anymore. I think this is literally just
Spring pray from here on out
Accuracy rubbish. Oh
Oh, that's a lot of Navi and they're probably gonna destroy my myth. Oh, I'm not careful
Where's BT when you need them
I just want a few revives on hand. All right, I've got two revives now
As long as I can choose a hate thing if there's a fight ahead. I
Just hope this. Oh my god my mix
Well, look at me
Right just got keep going just looks like there's fates all the way up ahead. We need BT on
Honestly sorry for reason idea of RDA, but thank you for experience in it
Thank you for experiencing the pain. I mean some people enjoy when streamers rage. I don't know
I got taken out in viz for that like some people genuinely love when streamers rage and I'm like
Hold off the Navi. No, you are not gonna make them literally
Um, I don't know how freaking strong you think I am I am not that good. I that's
Okay, I'm gonna try and keep a lid on it and not get overwhelmed
Very quickly. I am so glad I picked up the other RDA
I can't do anything
Yeah, I'm gonna need you guys
Hmm, I'm gonna need everyone to start spamming nades everywhere. I'm pretty sure those are RDA needs
I'm gonna need everyone to do that unanimously unanimously right now
It's not it's okay. Just sacrifice me in the fire
Oh, and I'm taking out in viz, which is the only time it helps to we do my
Uh-huh
Okay, feel and then damage protection to how I can get my heel back up
I need long range
Okay, those are definitely our needs I feel like if the Navi were doing needs like that, I'd be a goner already
Okay, okay, we're not over run
But don't want to jinx it but I'm gonna grab that it's really important
I'm gonna jinx it but it's looking good only a minute 30 of this and then we're done
Okay
But protection on I don't really want to miss me too much
I'll take that
I'm cool. I'm
Okay, I don't know if we're spamming needs, but keep doing that shit. Oh my god
It's literally stun off in them from hitting us. Oh, that's a lot. That's a lot. Hold on
Oh dear
I think I think maybe some of our soldiers went down because we're getting now. Okay. Now we're over run again
If I can just whittle down some base health on them, it just makes all the world of difference
Oh
We may actually have three roses. Oh, I'm getting some of my pardon
I'm not that mad because I'm actually getting help like genuinely getting help and like they're not all all off and on to me
It's when they all all off and there's like nothing I can do hold on. Sorry. I'm getting
Because I'm too busy
Praising the game for not being absolutely ridiculous. Oh, I take it back
Why do you fill out your pistols every time why do you insist on fill it out the pistol?
Well, I hope it didn't die because of that freaking cutscene
Is mercy up by the way, I think mercy may be live. I may have completely missed it
Oh
Okay, no, so they are still attacking whatever but I mean I'm getting left alone devices. I'll take it
I
Danger danger danger high voltage. Okay. Mercy is live. Yes, monster. Welcome to link her. We will redirect into her
I think we're almost done. I am going for a nap after this stream. I can tell you that much
Wow
Mercy's region just yeah, if you're in it, I don't know you'll need to see who rage is more me or mercy. Oh
I
Can sense it I'm licking the screen right now almost done. Oh
You need more than enough
One read stream to the next return to your dragon flight the well souls. We've done it
The evil has been defeated. I will never I'm very happy to say I will never play the RDA side again. Oh
A rank rotten experience
Dev team do not speak ever again and do not cook ever again
Thank you and good night. That's my review
Oh
Forward a little to the right
The game arrangement real I was just it was just rinse and repeat rinse and repeat in the moment
I've got even a hint of damage a lick of damage to speed things up
Either new guys were brought in
Oh
It's actually have a health bar just
Taking these corners to Willy-nilly then
Story show on your back. I can't help it. I know how it when you're angry. Oh my god. I feel like that would be terrifying
I
Make me in that peaky shrivel and go back and save me. I'm so happy terrible
That follows on the receiving end of that
Same here is kind of what no
Sorry, sorry
I
Right we did it we have confirmed the evil
Is the game gonna let us get there without being attacked by a plan
No fighting here, or I'm gonna cry I'm gonna angry spot is more. I'm sorry so that terrifies mummy
Oh
Oh, I'm going
Listen to you
The new recruits fresh from earth. I've been working on this for over 10 years
This is my moment right now. So if it doesn't work
I'll see you on the other side. Oh wait, I have to I need to end him anyway. Oh
Well, this is gonna be beautifully satisfying
Just let me cook a bit. Okay, it's fine. He has ability to go out of but yeah
All things considered actually, you know what I could probably put on that double aggression thing
Reserve her. Yeah
Okay, oh
We healed up
I'm not sure I can send it to you healing up. So don't do that again
Okay, I kind of like some walking around
He doesn't really seem to do anything it seems like he
I'm just giving him it I'm just throwing everything I'm hold on a minute
Oh, wow, so the sonic pulse is too far away none. Okay, he's still healed again
Now sadly, I am going to run out of ammo doing this message
So not really sure
That's fine you're like to do that, but maybe don't heal again
Um
Am I supposed to do something special for this fight?
I don't know when he'll get we get like five and then the game's like, okay, no more heals for you. Well, why did the aim do it?
I
Like a ammo station, there was one back there. I'm literally out
Oh
I'm not like mad at this fight or anything, but like bro you keep healing like there's nothing I can do
Use my mortar strike on him
Yeah
Uh
I did nothing to him
Oh
I'm a bit confused
Sorry, I need to change out my weapons because they're all empty. So I can't the nail gun sure
It's already full me and there's no point me getting flamethrowers or
Um machine gun
I don't know I can I can oh this one's different
Okay, nail gun again
I healed again
I don't know if I'm supposed to call upon awa to do something
The utility looks like I've left literally sneaking on I guess he's just a damage on
Wait, just go to the glowing thing
I think back here
No
Sorry, I'm brain
I'm both brain dead. I'm bling bling thing
I'm looking
But yeah, I'm starting to think I'm needing to like call upon awa to like end him because
I'm literally like swimming right now. Excuse me. I just wanted to go for a wee swim before I ended you
I'm just going to go like up on awa. Oops. Sorry. I'm gonna drop
Glowing
Not here. No, I'm definitely not to climb awa right now glowing
I thought that stick I mean that stick is glowing what the fuck it is
I
Morning de synchronization imminent honestly, can you bring him to the ledge?
I feel like I'm supposed to do something here
I think it's broke. Okay, so I watched a quick video and the guy
Eases a green angel. Oh greening greening launcher. Okay
Is this a grenade launcher? I only have 20 on the grenade
Oh
Oh, wow, really? Okay after all of that, bro
I'm starting to think this shit wasn't playtested at all past this point
Are we the baddies?
Oh
Yeah, let's see where the baddies all right
Rider you there colonel quarch
Panelists is going like a baseball stadium. What the hell did you do? I'm not sure
Whatever you did it worked the navi are making a quick retreat. I'm getting reports. They lost control of their band sheets
That makes sense to you. Yeah
It actually does
Congrats rider. You're gonna be a hero for this
I'll get your butt down here and that dragon better be spotless. You had damage on the dragon
Eat
I heard we lost Kendra, but you need to know you did the right thing
I hope it was all right
This better bring peace. You've stopped a catastrophe, but this isn't over
We can't keep control available for long nor should we and we've got more shit
of humans do to arrive
More is inevitable. So what was this all for?
A we needed to see what we're taking over. Not there being part two spoilers from the movie in the video game
Next time she'll be ready
Am I here?
Development team should be ashamed of yourself for the rda side
Development team should be proud of yourselves from the navi side. Don't ever make me do that again. That's awful
Oh my god
I have no idea how hard I reached because I can't remember in the moment
But oh my god
Am I going mental or was that terrible?
I think I must have I think I should have been using the grenade launcher clearly from that last fight
And and because I didn't use the grenade launcher
and
It just got from like bad to worse or
You blacked out when you raised. I don't remember really what I just remember like I did get angry
But I don't remember anything that actually happened like
One minute I was like getting annoyed and then the next minute the fight was over and I got stuck on a rock and I was trying to get down
I think grenade launcher is op. Okay, I guess that's probably you're showing quite a bit
I'm cheeky gang bang
She literally saw red. Honestly. It was beautiful. Monka is you're rage is hot, but the mission was bad
Angry girl, you were fuming at the man. I was frothing for a moment. I clipped it. So show up one stream and it's Monka
I don't even know am I going to be embarrassed if I look back on it like I don't feel that bad right now
So kind of been that bad
The game got dunked on hard and forgotten pretty quickly, but for the general community for a lot of good reasons
At least you finished it. You deserve a good rest. Good girl. I'm proud of you for not giving up
The rage has talked to your content. Well, that is literally why I do not play rage games like mercies unironically so brave
For playing that game. Like I couldn't I'd just be scurriman
It may be a bit embarrassing, but at least it seems to have been for a good reason. I felt that rage. It's so funny
Also, you might want to make more tea before sleeping or after waking up or for my voice
I mean, it felt like a justifiable rage or he just won't make us class. The rage was justified. Okay
Congrats. You did good job thing
So now you need more than an app. You may need to fill it. Oh, I hope I can get like a full eight hours
I've been needing it for a while
You didn't give up. So you did a good job at least. Heck yeah
Mad cause bad. Lamar true. Literally all I had to do was pull out the grenade launcher
apparently
Lucky me
Lucky me. All I had to do was pull out
Take these head pads
I would have went insane. You're amazing
Well, then I feel like you guys probably would have figured out to swap to the weapon way before I did so
Sending hugs if they're welcome. Otherwise you did so good. I'll take those hugs
Are you the first person to finish this campaign on stream?
Stop imagine if I was like the first vtuber to play this game. That would be hilarious
And and the pov is like isn't the navi side amazing and then the rd side is me just screaming
Sorry for forcing you to play that. I feel bad now. Nah, come on. I can stop at any time
I just say stilettos and then I would stop don't worry
If you're the first that counts as a world record, I would have thrown my monitor before changing weapons
making vtuber history
Oh, so when an angry scot rages. Oh, so wins the angry scotch rages somewhere, honestly
I'm pretty sure you are though. Oh, no, I'm what sorry. I've already I've already forgotten what I'm probably would overgrinding did
Before and killed it with a bigger number. You're probably the only one that ever will you can be the avatar vtuber
The way of the water the way of the scot
You did great powering through that heck. Yeah
Think about it. You used the worst weapon to beat the game. Honestly
I actually think you are the first vtuber to do on straight vtuber history
Not even a weekend after debut. I'm already making history
But see fully the rda was a lot more fun than the navi. Why because of the rage apparently everyone's got
You know half masked at the moment because they liked my rage
The way of the scot the cut fish the way school and
You have a full monopoly on this game now. Okay. Okay. I'll take it. I'll take it
I'm the type to pause the game and watch a video spin feeding me on what to do
Honestly small streamer did two years ago, but for both campaigns. Yes
half half
Now I'm going to get the game to relieve or to relive the pain
You can't me
Yeah, let's say half only half wait, there's no way I need to make a rage ASMR if that's okay
I don't mean suffering like that
Like honestly, I feel fine now, but I guess in the moment. I was like scary region
Sorry if I scared anyone. I apologize
Got some ancestral rage built up in me, I guess
Me just skipping 60 percent past all the enemies honestly
60 percent probably like 100 percent of the optional fights I skipped like I'm not even kidding
Now you scare us more. No, you didn't scare
You could do it more. You're like, well, I do have a
Donut lawn reward potentially being that rage, but yeah
Stormy rage air should be like you call that. Oh, I willy. That's just prophetic, you know
That was uh, that wasn't scary. It was the opposite. Oh the fabled scotch rage
I mean, I was scared and felt something else at the same time. I'm not gonna explain. That's actually hilarious
I didn't know that had that effect. It makes me remember the banshee scream. Oh
I'm not sure I can even banshee scream like I can do it like my screams very loud
But I'm not gonna scream because I I think after the rage
I don't know if one of the neighbors are probably trying to listen in on me right now and be like what is going on
Angry hypnosis ASMR
Get hypnotized. Get hypnotized. Get hypnotized. I still prefer subspace
Just yelling get up
Right, um, they're gonna call the police on you. I've actually wondered if it's a possibility
I did speak to my neighbors at one point
And I explained to them that I'm a voice actress
So if they hear anything at night, don't be too worried. It's just me
So my voice acting's a bit different
Um, can you make a reward that you just scream scottland forever scottland forever
Passive aggressive ASMR. They're like, is she okay in there? Does she need help?
If someone clip that moment the clip will give but we'll get pretty
Oh the toothbrushing I'm gonna go get my toothbrush. Okay
I'll be right back. We're gonna if you want to get your toothbrush and brush your teeth
I
Got one out of 21 days to brush our teeth
Wait, let me put my headset on so I can listen to the
Thingy right. I got my toothbrush. It could be a sound pack from morning alarms. Just full bag pouch
I have toothpaste because I salivate a lot. I don't know about you
But whenever something enters my mouth, it starts to salivate like crazy
We're gonna brush our teeth and then we'll read into
Yeah, mercy. I was gonna call her mousy for a second. What's she eating a mouse?
Are you ready?
Are you ready to brush your teethies?
With me
I'm gonna do it for two minutes. Okay. That's how long you brush your teeth
So just start with the front of your teeth, right?
I see you. I do you want me to mute the game so you can like really hear the brushy brush
Yeah
I don't think you're gonna hear it over the thing. No, I will start a two minute counter now
Uh
Oh, yeah, sorry. Let me mute the game
I was probably gonna break now that I'm out and it's tabbed out of the game. There we go
Do you have a chanting? I do have chanting. Hold on
Uh, whoa, that's a lot of words to speed up one. Hold on
Uh, I got sorry. I've got toothpaste on my mouth right now. Pardon me. One second one second
I will do that and I do this
Okay, we're brushing our teethies
Um
Okay, two minutes of teeth brushing is a lot
Oh, no, you can hear my background music shift back my music you're ruining it. Uh
Wait two minutes so um 39 minutes left
Wait make sure you do the outside first
Oh my god, I'm out of chocolate right already. Um, I don't think this is enough product
Okay, now the bit that most people miss I'm spitting everywhere. Hold on. I need more
Does that have a pillow in this room? I don't
I have so much saliva coming out of my mouth
Do the back of your front teeth and the back of your front bottom teeth
That's the most forgotten place when you brush your teeth, okay?
Oh
We get no cavities over here we get no how you call them, uh
What what are you called haemorrhoids? No haemorrhoids. No cavities
We are good with things
And we go that
Don't brush too hard on your gum drool receipt. I don't
No root canals. We don't believe in root canals in this house
Root canal blood
Haemorrhoids, yeah, we don't have haemorrhoids in this community
Uh, I can't pull off because I don't know about the foster but it's just gonna brush my teeth in general
And we're gonna do it for a quite one day in a row
and then
Everyone's gonna have a teeth brush and have it okay, and life is nice and easy. Oh my god the spit is going over to the paper towel
not on a toilet roll but
Get the back of your wisdom tooth for you still gum
No, not mouth haemorrhoids booty haemorrhoids
Okay, and make sure you do circular motions. That's how you get all the the peas and poos off your teeth
Okay, I think I'm almost done
Is there a toothbrush out for a reason? No, no, it's just brushing our teeth
Yeah, we're getting the because we didn't know
The reason why hold on I need to spit I'm gonna spit into my little mcdonald
Uh tracing. Are you ready to hear this?
Yeah
Yeah, that's so much spit. I didn't need to generate that much, but I did
What?
Yeah, yeah
So minty
We did it we have established day one of a 21 day habit of brushing our teeth
Thank you for the drink. No, not my used toothpaste spit
The only thing I don't like about toothpaste is that it keeps sitting
Like it keeps in your you're not to you're not to rinse that way, but if you need to spit it out like
Okay
Did it we played the world's most annoying
Right, I'm going to make triple sure I am redirecting into mercy
Oh, I just minimized the tab by accident
No, that's mercy omari stream
Thanks for the stream. You're most welcome. Thanks for hanging. Sorry for scared anyone. I do apologize about that
Sorry about that old chap didn't really mean to scare you did I oh, but it just kind of came out
Kind of just came out
I said what everyone was thinking and said
But uh, yeah that game needs a hot patch for a weapon drill. So I'm saying
It won't let me open the redirect thing. Why not?
YouTube you're so stinky sometimes it won't let me load so I can redirect into mercy
I need to wait for it to load. Okay. I did it now
Oh, tomorrow we have old school runesgate. Oh, I need to make my account
But what do I call my account is the question?
Customization redirect add
A difficulty right into mercy say
mercy
The better work
Right my little reeflings I honestly didn't think we were gonna I honestly thought we're gonna end out four hours
But what made it to almost 10 hours should look us go
You guys have so much stamina
Wait, wait, can I try this out? Hold on. I don't know if I can try this out right now
Is this gonna work or is this gonna break?
Oh
You did so well you make me so proud
Such long unending stamina for me
Did it work?
Did it work? Did I have a reverb effect when I did that?
I don't know if that worked or not or did I mess it up?
What do you mean looking at school? You're the crazy one who took bail
So if I'm feeling like it is yeah, the reverb was like yes, I work. I'm so happy
If my voice wasn't so burst I'd do a bit more but it's burst right now
Big burst big burst
All hail the glowfish
It looks good when my like eyes and my little shells you can kind of see the transparency of my shells a bit by our like this
Maybe
You can see my reflectives
thing going on
It works though
Wait talk a bit
Okay, I'm glad it worked. Right. I am going to end it there without a fantastic endurance room
Tomorrow is old school runescape. So just so you know the plan the plan is
that
We what I'm going to make a new fresh account. You don't have to
but
My idea was that we do some questing to level up and then we basically
Just have fun leveling up cooking and see what where it goes
um
But I'm a bit rubbish at like
Quest so it would be nice to try them together like cooks assistant. Um
I'm sure there's like a vam that haunted house quest. I can't remember its name right now
But we're going to do like those kind of questings
and then
We can do some fishing together and we'll cook the fish
outside of the barbarian village because that's free
um
And we can cook crayfish for free. I'm pretty sure you just need to get in it
Are you doing members? I think so. That's my only issue
I'm gonna buy membership, but I'll play like I'll go into a free-to-play lobby
And we can do the free-to-play quests and take it from there
Because I'm not entirely sure what the plan is after that
I joined you on old school
uh runescape sheebie
I hate to break it to you. My name's Trony
I
Tags level dream hypnosis
Uh, yes runescape membership
Time to make my account tonight too. He yes, I'll share whatever we're on and we can all go questing together
We can see all the reefling gang gang. I'm tired. It's fine. I know. I know what you meant
I need to go sleep. The fangs are so much easier to admire this course. Yeah
Yeah
Some people thought they were vampire fangs, but they're not that's jack. You can't really see my ears, but they're slightly pointed
No pointy
I haven't played in ages. I need to learn. Yeah, we can all get like the same level we can all like
Hack the same u-tree when we're trying to level up her uh woodcraft
Are you planning on playing something at follow 76?
I think that's multiplayer, but I don't know how to get you in my lobby
Like how do I get reeflings in lobby or is it like can we make a lobby code?
And it's like a server like they host
I'm not sure how 76 works
Get bit by the fish you want to buy
Would you let me bite you reefling?
That's terrible
You should let me do it
I love your choice of games so far makes me safe to see what else you got play
Well, I'm glad you like the game so far. I'm literally just picking childhood stuff and stuff that makes me happy
So I'm glad
But yes old-school RuneScape definitely
might be a reoccurring multiplayer for a little bit
um
I'm not really gonna
I'm not sure what happens when membership what membership streams are planned
I think we'll also do
I think three membership streams a week possibly
One for react movie one for membership
Multiplayer I'll decide like I wouldn't do like progression
on old-school RuneScape multiplayer
Behind a membership stream because that's not fair for those invested
So maybe
Maybe maybe um
I first I first played again yesterday for the first time used old-school RuneScape and a goblin got you
You got done at goblin village a dead by daylight member stream. Yeah
I'm open to these kind of things, but yeah one I want to consistently have a member stream
When memberships open
Uh
I react and they like we'll watch a movie together and then I might also do a script writing
Scream
Or maybe show you some behind the scenes stuff like maybe we write shorts
I don't know
I'm trying to think of like stuff you guys want to see and then of course we could just like maybe smaller games that aren't
Necessarily stream worthy on main
So for those of you who are unable to membership, please don't worry
I always have free content coming out and I
For days like so, you know how we played needy streamer overload yesterday
Because that was only two hours long like that's a short game
I would then come back online after maybe like a 30 minute rest and then do a membership stream
So you still get like content that day and then like I'll raid into whoever's online
um
And like keep going so yeah, don't worry. She streams eight days a week
Yeah, don't ever worry and like obviously the ace mark comes out as well. That's like free on youtube. You can watch on youtube anytime
and
Script writing stream or submit scripts. Yes, it would be a bit hard to review
Scripts live because I would need to use euphemism
That's nice as long as you're not overworking yourself. I will make what I can handle and
We can take it from there
Yeah
Get that Hermione to
Rewind time and overlap herself streaming honestly
True true
I'll need to see eventually be able to close your eyes and see her for a moment. You don't watch
Always online
There are always rooms so yes, please never worry if you don't have the money for membership
Because I stream every day and you can come see me every day. Um
and
Yeah, I'll make sure everyone gets their money's worth either way because I don't like when streamers don't get their money's worth
All right, sorry. I don't I don't like when streamers don't get their money's worth. That's just me. So yeah, um
Strony's a stream and beast. I'm sure she'll have something for you. Yeah, I've got something for everyone or that's the plan anyway
Hopefully I got something for everyone
So you're saying is I should never become a member only if you are financially capable and
If you're only financially capable to support one person, I recommend doing my daughters over me. Okay
Um because I always have free accessible content
a always coming out so yeah
Yeah, we love you strong. Please don't try my blood. Yes
You're such a good girl. It's insane. Yeah
I will skip meals to members. Stop. No, we're not doing these jokes. I don't actually don't like these
There was like one joke that was like, oh, I'm I'm like in a homeless shelter
And then I've given you like membership or whatever. I don't know
It's actually probably one I am like so goofy and non-series all the time. Those kind of jokes are like
I don't like them
I sold my kidney. Yes. I was like
No, I don't like
You definitely have a few streams that I need to rewatch. I love it though. Oh, they're long streams
You'll be rewatching for a while, but I'm good for putting on in the background for a rambling if you ever like
I need I want to listen to something in the background, but I don't want to actually focus in
Yeah, just put the avatar stream on and then when it comes to the rda part when I start screaming my head off
my
my scarier, but
I'm looking forward to your first ace round stream. Hope youtube doesn't do anything. Um, I'm a bit worried
But I'm not going to be doing earlicking or anything like that. I don't know what the heck youtube's been playing at recently
It's making me nervous to even upload my like
1,000 rewards and there's literally nothing wrong with that freaking audios
Well, I just made a brand new school roadscape. It's been years and I look forward to it. Yay
I will tell everyone the server when we get on tomorrow
Like I'll put it on screen and I'll say like this is the world that we're in
Um, and we'll start outside Lumbridge castle where the starting point is. Um, I'm literally gonna make an account put membership on it and then
I get online for stream and we'll take it from there. I don't know what to name myself. So I need to name myself something
Mildly humorous, but I haven't decided yet. Maybe skullfish. That'd be nice. Oh, no someone someone. Ah, well, if you take my name
It's fine. I don't know. I'll need to think of something
Do you have a place where you'll upload?
Money's for veggie might
No, I don't have to try vegemite
I'll get vegemite then for the hand cam stream. Thank you reluctantly saying I'll get vegemite in freaking toast
I don't even buy bread. I don't even get buy bread
Skullfish is a good one. Thanks. I stole it from a reefling
Thank you for giving me that. Um, wait, do we need a membership on old school runescape to
Not necessarily for what we're gonna do
But I think if we I don't know yet like I don't know we're gonna do some quests
But I'm pretty sure like everything's behind a freaking lock and it's so expensive for old school runescape membership
I don't know. Maybe there's a rich reefling that's willing to buy bonds and gift it to reeflings
But that's not like my place to ask for
It's a bit. Hmm. I don't know if we have any
try hard reeflings on old school runescape like
I think I have about 12,000 coins in old
So I can't buy anyone a bond. Sorry
And I'm starting on a fresh account. I don't know. Maybe we can like pull our money together to buy bonds to like share to reeflings
Will there be you're looking on patreon? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you're looking on patreon. It's not problem for me
Um, do what we want on patreon
The other place we upload wards
You asked that and I read that out and then I didn't even reply to you
No, well, um, the girls have been using twitter and like putting a go like a download link out
um, I don't think any of my content's gonna get taken down because
I know the rules
I know how to
Um, so I don't think we're gonna any any oilers in chat literally any old school runescape oilers. Uh, we summon you
I'd like to call upon you
My membership is still six dollars because I've had an active substance. Wait
You lock in the same subscription price because you did it all the way back then
But then you do that you're looking anyway
I can look this way
She knows the cheese
Never touch runescape. Unfortunately. It's like a really, um, it's not a hard game
It's literally point and click if you wanted to try it for the first time you can always
Start up with us. Um, but if it's not for you, you don't have to play along. It's okay. Please don't worry
I know you've been going for nine hours. That's crazy. Look, I'm just gonna yapping. Okay
I mean, I could check out marshmallow and we can make it to 10 hours if you want
Like I could put my little marshmallow link in the chat
He he he
Oh my marshmallows in the descriptions. Hold on. I even have I can't even see my screen right now
My my stream not my screen. I can't see my screen because it's right in front of me
Um, but hold on. How did I do this? How did I put it in chat?
I am about to sneeze
Boom, oh no
Oh, no, it'd be such a shame if you guys asked me questions to round this up to a 10 hour stream. Stop
Stop it
We're right on the verge of 10 hours. Oh
A little countdown to 10 hours, shall we?
Well, my four minutes left
Oh, I have a lot of marshmallows. Whoops
Someone says I'd love to spread your cheeks and lick every perfect. Oh
I wasn't supposed to read that part out loud. Hey, I'm glad you do
Uh, god, your salty gamer rage makes me want to have hard sweaty angry
I can't can't read that one either. Um
Um
Hi, scrawny, hopefully you're well. This is my first time using marshmallow glad I could pop your marshmallow cherry
I don't know if you
Read any of these. Oh, I read all my marshmallows
Hmm. I have a few questions
You stream so much that I'm wondering if you'll be taking a break from ASMR. No, I'm streaming ASMR in two days
No break from ASMR. I've got ASMR cards coming out as well. I just need to write the scripts and send them off
but it's gonna be good
Yeah, I've got time for ASMR all the time because yeah, I also got loads of managers in place
The only thing I need to do really is be the messenger owl that sends clips to editors now and
Upload stuff on behalf of the girls like Mercy just wakes up and she's like got new shorts on her channel. She has no idea
That's me doing it. Actually Emmy has another
Is that short? Yeah, Emmy has a short and she's like she's just gonna wake up and it's gonna be on her channel
Already tagged up and everything for
Yeah
Unless I didn't read that right
Yeah, I know I know how my ASMR is gonna be
I can also upload full videos to Twitter as well if anything ever did become an issue
Like if I did like a little ASMR video, so it's not a problem
The level organization is ascending as so the girls aren't stressed if the girls had to stream
And they had to run around and worry about trying to get clips out and shorts out
Not good combo. Not nice. Not nice. Um
Oh
No, wait, what hi strong you feel a bit embarrassed. We are not supposed to be there
Oh, no, it's okay someone says they feel embarrassed because they messed up in chat at some point
Don't be silly. You're allowed to mess up and chat all you want. I can't even I can't even write in English
I like don't worry like emmy emmy had to a script where she had to see a putty cat and I accidentally typed pssy
Like don't be afraid. I'm making embarrassment mistakes. They're not embarrassing at all
Actually, you only feel embarrassment if you let yourself feel embarrassment or something like that
It's something about psychology. Like if if you make mistakes
Yeah
View the girls trying to find a non-lid marshmallow read on stream and possible is honestly not that bad
I don't get that many. I honestly don't get that many like the girls show me what they get and I don't seem to get
But I haven't been using the other twitter. I think once I start using it properly them
Yeah
Question for you the other day we talked with casted greek brother hood about how you're the mother of the girls
And the reeflings are the father. Does that make emmy your daughter or sister or a daughter or sister?
If you're a reefling then technically daughter sister, but if you're not a reefling then it's just a little sister
Boom
New audio idea angry scots women mounts and rides you after being all day as a fellow scotton
I just were hotter than here and so on
So I listened to the assassin's creed stream and I was happy that you remembered me and give her the yeah
You're like the the main clipper
I actually didn't ask that question. I think there was someone else who made a few clips as well
I thought about making clips and posting them, but I wasn't too sure if I could use that
Oh, no, you can go brah. That's your channel. You own it
You make you make custom content. You you have made new creative content. Then guess what copyright is in your favor
Don't worry about copyright. Okay. You don't have to worry about copyright or are you joking me?
Clip the girls away. Have fun. Have that ye
I'm friends with the guy who's already itching to draw the fan art
Fan art of who what door what door is getting fan art? Please tell me I want to know
I love seeing them get fan art
They sound good
I like with the olympians better better not think about the family
Uh, what type of hypnotism is your favorite?
That's too hard to answer honestly
I like hypno loss
I really like hypno loss
Where I'm supposed to hypnotize you, but then backfires and I do as you say
So good
Any chance of a spiral? Let's play. Oh, I've never played spiral like that before. I would like to try it
I'm pretty sure they remastered them and they're like nice cam friendly casual
Seems like something that's like cameo-esque where it's like nice and simple to get through so I think yeah
You like fraction
I would say yes overall
It's the one where you go into like a difference or am I I'm I'm messing up for subspace. I might messing up for subspace. Hold on
I am
Hey, story. I'm probably being a dumb dumb and I haven't found them yet
But I was wondering if you could get reference sheets for all the girls chat mask. Oh, yes
Amy's chat mascot is in her debut stream you are
The light in my dark you are the beating in my heart. I showed you yesterday
I should get a reference sheet from them all put together. Maybe I'll get a tweet from the the bail on
mmm
I can't because Amy's is in a different art style
Hmm
I know what you're asking for. I don't know the best way to do it. Maybe the discord can post them
Maybe maybe the discord should have a reference sheet for all cart all the girls and their mascots
That might be the solution that we can come to
Would you like to come together on a solution?
Or would you like to come together?
I'm a little late but congrats on the debuts can't wait to see you and the rest of the girls have in store
And it was nice hearing her scorch moment again. Glad you're back
Sincerely a h little reddish boy. Oh, yeah, it's good to be back terrorizing you
He he he he he I cannot wait I cannot wait for days for us to even
Thanks for being so funny amazing and cute you make my day better and all its aspects
I wish for you and the girls eternal success. Thank you for such kind words
That's so nice. I'm glad you somehow find me funny
Um
because
Yeah, literally
Yeah, it's not good. It's it's hard to make jokes. Okay, my first one
Oh, yeah, there's an official discord that has notification only none of the girls are in it. So
So remember remember what I said in debut 2.0
You don't groom us
We groom you
So none of us are in it, but if you want notifications for when we go live and all that
What does it say I need to push you against the wall holding both your hands above your head
Uh, I'm I supposed to say this that way
I don't know
By the way along with the zinc supplements I've started eating celery for you
Oh celery is minging though. Thanks for your sacrifice
They taste between boring and bitter and I don't like them by all parts are very
Are you sure you even I even I draw the line at celery. Sorry. It's so tasteless. I don't understand how it was even
And that celery has been genetically selected to produce like that
The only way celery is redeemable is in a soup because it's got stock and completely covers the taste of celery
Your dedication is appreciated because celery sucks
Celery is a peanut butter delivery device. Oh, like a spoon
Celials worse though. Mmm
That I'm gonna zail them up form down. That's what I remember about
That's it. Hold on. I'm just grabbing some water
I I I need some hydrate
I have been hydrated
Oh, no, it's 2 p.m. Already. Oh, it's my bedtime soon
Oh, no, wait. No, actually it's good that it's my bedtime soon because that means I get to be on old school rinse
game with you even
Wait, actually, I just realized we're doing a first freaking stream state game tomorrow
Oh
Oh my god, why did that not register? We've literally been talking about old school rinse game
We get to play our first freaking stream today, but I get to see you all
Oh my god. Okay. I'm an idiot. I'm an idiot. I'm an idiot. Oh my god. It's tomorrow. I want to go to sleep, right?
I'm not I'm not gonna be able to sleep. It's like christmas
It's like christmas
I'm gonna be too excited
Are we all gonna like have code name? I don't know. Should we have theme names or we're all just gonna name our names like how we are
Five
I'm just gonna say this right now. Someone says hopefully you'll play five hours five hours
No, we're doing 12 hours. Okay 12 hours or go home
So I'm going to give everyone as much of a chance as possible to show up in old school rinse game
I will put the world we are on in the top corner or something
So you can see it any minute. What is runescape?
Runescape is an old
Web game. Is that a web game? I don't know if it's a web game now
um
Beget if you have trouble falling asleep just look at a mirror and hypnotize yourself true
I'm aware that's below your average
The most runescape players average on the game
Oh, do they they had enough after five hours me just like right. Let's do a fashion show
Everyone go to the grand exchange and get some pretty clothes on. I'm gonna write who has the best
Oh, wait, there's houses and can I bring you to my house and runescape? I'm right. I don't know
How membership works, but I'm pretty sure you can get house and runescape
um
Because I remember watching someone play hide and seek in runescape
And he was like chasing around like the people in stream. We can play hide and seek and taking runescape
Oh my god
Yeah, and it has this one's go. Oh my god
Oh my god, can we play hide and seek?
I want to be the seeker and I get to touch you all and if you're touched you have to like go in the corner
Until the winner is crowned
Really are getting screwed
I've never played runescape. Well, everything you're describing it sounds very close to ojicob penguin
Oh my god, I want to play tag
And I'll be like right run away from didi didi didi. Oh, no, who's that? Oh, no, but we won't be able to know who's that
So we can all play hide and seek. Okay
Shawnee if you phrase it like that everyone will like touch them
No, no, you're not wanting to get caught
What if we use our runescape beds next to each other ha ha jk
I sadly can't start a new game. I already have three games that take full time and one of them I play
Well world of warcraft someone was like, well, I say so
They were like, I'm no longer doing wow reads to watch your streams
I'm like, no, your girl's gonna be so annoyed at you. Like I've had the chance to play world of war. Ah, what was the expansion called?
It was like the second last expansion of wow
Um, I had a chance to play it and apparently people role play in this place called goldheim
And I'm like, should we play wow and just like be like really weird roleplayers that
I'd like
Shadowlands, I think it's shadowlands is why I played
um
No, not the battle not the battle of adedroff. Oh, okay brain needs to catch up. Hold on. Hold on brain needs to catch up
Not the battle of azaroth
Gold chart and something like that. Yeah, the gold chart and we should all go role play there
I would like make like make people really uncomfortable and we're all just like role playing
Wow ascension is a thing. I don't know what that is
The the elf and her dwarves. Oh
Wait, what would we be
Can I be can I be a cute night elf and then you guys could all be worgens for some unwritten reason
Mm-hmm
Pop tropica is still a thing too pop tropica
Hmm
Guild wars to role plays where it's ah unknown wink wonk
Really wink wink. Hey, oh
Oh wait, wait, wait do that again wink wonk
Really wink wink
Did that did that work
Oh, no, it doesn't work. Wait for some reason the sound works on my freaking game. Hold on. We're like wink wink
There we go, wait that played twice. I don't know why it doesn't do it on the screen. That's strange
It's the same instance. Oh, well
Sorry that took me so long to do
We should be orcs and you should be an elf for no reason at all
Oh gee, I sure wouldn't love to be overpowered
I take a drink of hydration of water to hydrate
Hi good morrow dear silly cuttlefish. I'm very sleepy. So I'ma be brief
I absolutely don't watch in here. That's okay. Shame and today
And it's been so unreal to watch you be all silly again. I absolutely adore you and hope all of you are girls
And what sorry I absolutely adore you and your hopes for the vealer girls and everything and I hope you all make it happen
For your happiness is mine and I'm always kicking my feet blushing tapping and stuff. Thank you for making
Thank you for such kind words
Got you twirling your hair and stuff. Huh got you twirling your hair and stream
Are you and the girls ever gonna play minecraft together? Yes, July is when the group minecraft server goes up
Amy
Definitely the most minecraft day out of us all. I don't know how the scale goes
But i'ma confidently say i'm probably the lowest on the scale of like minecraft knowledge
All I know is that apparently the mob votes
Are
They vote people voted for the freaking stealth phantom things
If you don't sleep for more than two days, they attack you through walls and stuff
And I know that was the mob vote and apparently the mod vote is also rigged because
It doesn't make sense
I don't know but I don't know if it's rigged. I think it's because people don't understand
like
kids will vote and kids don't vote for
things that are like
Good they vote for what kids want and maybe that's why the votes are always so skewed
Yeah mob votes terrible. I tried and voted for the crab
Wasn't there not like an alternative?
I can't remember. I assume mercy and her motion sickness might be a bit of a struggle
Yes
mercy
I would love
It's hard. I don't know if minecraft would set it off although she can she can change the camera
So it might not affect her motion sickness
I'll need to ask a bit more about it because because I don't have it. I don't know what kind of like sets are off all the time
Kids running around. I can't believe it kids reeling the way that kids game isn't used terrible
I hydrate again. Oh my voice is feeling it mr. Krabs
I'm pretty sure you can move out your camera angle. Can you not on minecraft or am I just making that up?
They look cool never stuck them forever
Yeah, I will agree the design of it looked cool
But its actual thing in game
is rubbish
like rubbish
um
What does that mean what are you asking me?
Forgot to send this. Thank you mommy for all your girls. So cute. Oh, I wanted to mention that so many people are like thanking me for like
The girls being the girls. I'm like, no you thank the girls. I didn't do anything
If you're thanking me for picking them again, that's the girls that did that. It was through either
their
Introduction or their con their own content like it's the girls. It's the girls you should be thanking not me
Goobers
It's the girls
So thank the girl
The reason people say that the vote is rigged is because Compton created tell people to vote for a certain more of their four effects and vote
Compton Compton who's Compton sounds like a town in London somewhere
Or a bottle sorry a bottle in London
You picked an amazing bunch though. They're all awesome. Ah, I'm glad you agree
There'd be nothing short of perfect
As in they are perfect. That's how that's how you say they're perfect, right?
They're nothing they're they have been nothing but perfect. Yeah, that's how you say it. Yeah, okay. Man of heat angles
Wait, oh no, right you guys are welcome to laugh. I think this is terminology. I'm not familiar with
if I see a
pace tripper
What's a hololive homo? Oh, what's a knee-gee male? What?
What's that? Am I being dumb? I don't know what that is
They're asking
Do I have am I able to shadow ban them?
All right, maybe maybe this no maybe this no, I don't quite understand it. Sorry
Hmm
Why is someone sending me
a detailed no
Is this is this far and on is this toilet bowl far and on
Oh ye gods how I wish for that most delightful of noise to curl into mine deprived ears with such intensity
I yearn to experience the sound of
straw knees
splutter gutter as it
Flaps a flutter the noise like a walrus burping up butter
the parps
and
It's like a chorus of
angels
unleashing their art
the pungent
Bay bass bass that can only be played alongside golden harps to shepherd the dead who has come and died
When hearing straw knees fart that is so toilet. There's no way you're not toilet bowl and on
Just for very quick lore
Someone ages ago sent me a thing and it's like I really want to hear you fart
On the toilet and I'm like what you want it to be amplified by echoing off the rim of the toilet
And from then he was crowned freaking toilet as bowl and on
I don't want to miss what cursed filth at the eye brought upon at the how brought upon these lands
Hi my love, I want to hmm and me right in front of you while you hold her hand
You may careful what you wish for you may be getting it
You may be getting it with all the girls actually possibly
There's
Hmm. Yes, I need to I need to see
He wants to hear the reverb full acoustics literally
What they wanted to hear that?
You're only allowed to hold hands
I have a plan for my own a song
But it requires a team effort and it's quite a lot to ask the girls like
Oh Dota songs are like you need to help each other out type them, but I'm gonna try my best to make it as easy as possible
but I would like to release a certain audio and
basically
In it, I give you a pill that negates any need for a
pause champ if you will
And then I take you daughter by daughter
It's so messed up saying out loud
But yeah, and I tell you like all the good things and encourage
But I don't I I need to I need to let it cook. Okay. I need to let it cook
And I need a donut on in the first place to even start cooking up
But wait in there. Yeah, we ain't doing that. We weren't even on the apart
That's a very silly pill
Lord grant me strength. Would you please give us a heads up for when it comes out so we can see?
Oh my god, mon
Please do that
She kicked a whole six course dinner
I'm a gourmet chef
Well, if I get 99
Um cooking on runescape, then yes, I am a chef
confirmed
Any plans for haptic support? Ah, I keep I keep getting asked, but I don't know what it is
I don't know what I need to do to the audience to make that happen
I don't know if it's like I run it through a data thing or whoa. I don't know
I'm too dumb
Hold on. I'm gonna fix my calibration and I'm wiggling a bit too much
Okay calibration calibrate
Are we cooking an own school runescape something? Yes
I don't know how to make money in runescape, but we're gonna be buying lobster so we can level up
If not, we'll use barbarian village and we'll pick up all the salmon that all the bots drop
Shawnee, do you reply to marshmallows privately? No, um, I don't
I reply on stream or I put together a mosaic
A mosaic? Is that the correct word where I put all the pictures together
I'm posting
But I've only done that once I should maybe do it again sometime
And then I can talk about all the naughty things
Wow
Here's a funny story about three medieval kingdoms. I'm scared to click as a piece but
What?
Hey, story. I love your work. Any chance to do a belly button counting? No, you don't like to see my belly button
Why would you want to see my belly button? I don't like my belly button
belly button
Is that your choice?
Is that your choice of finishing location?
Hmm
Your choice interesting
Good night, Shawnee. Just thought you'd want to know I'm gonna jet. Oh
I can't read the end of that. Uh, enjoy your night time routine. Sleep well
Uh, oh my oh my
Uh, hi, Shawnee. I want to hold your body again
Oh
I can't read any of these
There's a free game called fantasy star online too. I haven't played it in years
But every weekend there's a hatsunimiku con that's so specific
Why is there a hatsunimiku concert in the middle of fantasy star online too?
I'm thinking
You air blue eyes hiding in your wi-fi
Shawnee just want to let you know for old school runescape being on a members world is almost a requirement for any skill training
You can quest together with people and free to play but the gameplay is limited. Oh, but it's so expensive
Oh
Stop reading them out loud
By like reading them
It's only me or is it me saying a lot more
Things than she do
Hey, are they both on? No, they're not online right now. You mean in the ASMRs?
I don't know
People are bored bold on marshmallow. Yeah, that's the best part
They tell me everything they want
And I give them everything they want
That's a good exchange
Can you please say
um
What are you gonna use it for if I say it?
And you didn't tell me what tone to say it in either
You didn't tell me what tone to say the sentence in either
Hmm, I need to think how would you want me to say it?
Hmm, I lost the game
This is that the tone you wanted it?
If you want me to say something you need to give me tone. You need to give me the emotion. I don't know
Wait, strong enough wait what?
Wait, is that that giffy game where if someone says you lost the game
You've lost us
Wait, is that what it
Rip game players wait, what does that mean?
It's a silly game right where people say I lost the game and then you lose it until you win it on your streak
If you think about the game you lost, okay
The only objective of the game is to not think about the game. Oh
Okay, oh, I'm sorry. Oh, I just made you all lose. I'm sorry. I wasn't thinking that
I'm sorry
I didn't think that forehead
Can I suggest something secret totally say so confession maros to read on stream?
Yeah, you can like you can literally type in the maros right now. Do I have
Can I can I send it like this?
Did that work it did?
Yeah, you can just put it in there and if you want me to say something just put the emotion and then like little quotation marks
I'll also take requests here in the ASMR stream as well
So if you ever wanted me to hear it kind of whispered a bit on on a different microphone because this is an asm b7. I'm using
At least we lost this drawing. I heard about this like 25 years ago an elementary
My discipline. I'm sorry. Okay. I distract you. I will say other things
Did you see the reefing zip-up hoodie design Mario? I send on their deer. What do we bear?
Oh, if you've got those if you've got those kind of pictures, please send on twitter
But I will say my twitter tags are freaking working
I'm trying to find
This freaking artwork on smuttle and it doesn't show up. I don't know why it doesn't show up
Uh, what's your favorite type of hypnotic induction to use?
um
I think
I like repeated pattern
Come to the ASMR stream and I'll show you what I like. Okay deal
Huh, are you gonna show up and I'll show you what I like
She went like and people are gonna judge me, but I like it
So I'll do what I like
Sometimes the stony is a good girl. Hell yeah
Yeah
You uh, I'm good at advertising. Okay. I'm in I'm in. Hey stony. Here's the soft safer work Mario. Do you have a throne?
I do but I've unlinked it because
I have everything I need now that I've got my reef links. I don't need a single thing else
Hmm and that's that
I
Don't need anything so I've unlinked my throne
I'm gonna say how many
Have you received so far? Um
Not a lot the girls are getting a lot more than me
I think the refunds are a little shy a little shy or a little scared
Well, you and the girls be able to mhm yourself and members streams. Uh, most likely yes
Stony doesn't make you happen people send you the spicy messages
Please let me please tell me all the scenarios you want to do to me
Are there any games where there's an alt path you haven't tried and would you consider them?
I can't think of any off the top of my head
I normally probably like game starts game ends. I never pick the bad team if there's a bad side
stinky
Unless you count the companions in Skyrim
Does anyone here like the companions in Skyrim?
Oh wait, I'm on the freaking wrong thing. Sorry. Hold on. Let me do that again. Does anyone here like the companions in Skyrim?
Yeah, exactly. That's what I thought that's what I thought no one likes them
Yeah, boo exactly
You think they're fine
I don't I never although the first time you play it. It's like wow really good, but
The freaking on xbox
The girl always glitches out and disappears in the middle of the map and she never comes back
Hi, just a time waster for cute fish
Someone says
So this is wife
husband
Have you heard a joke about afar it stinks
You know what you're done
Why do I hate you no work?
Oh
Right, I think that's all the marshmallows that I can I I refresh and it's just gone up like a bit
Um
Oh my god, I love you and the girls so much. I created a twitter account just to follow the six year
I hate I had to turn into I know. Thank you for going through it
It's such a pain my account keeps getting freaking locked and it keeps making me prove
I'm not bought over and over and over and over and over and over and over again
Look, I just want to look at small fish. I want to
And then I want to go to sleep, you know what I'm saying
Hi Johnny. Oh, sorry. I don't know why I gave you that voice. I'm so sorry. I apologize
Hi, strongy. I woke up in a Euro time zone and found out the party was still going 10 hours in the avatar stream
Yeah, I really admire your energy and autism as you call it. Thank you
If you want to play old school runescape tomorrow, we are going to be live for 12 hours
Cheeky endurance stream
What's that?
I stream more in one week than the average wee chipper does in a month
I'll wear that with pride
Hmm, so I I don't I don't have snot coming out my nose. I'm drinking water
Yeah, wishes
Hi strongy. Thanks for being a butt so
Okay, you can you can finish the rest
Strongy guess what you just took my marshmallow marshmallow of engineering get plapped get plapped get plapped
Looking forward to the old school runescape. I also recommend final fantasy if you want more mmo's also
Would you accept script ideas family scripts? Yes, I would I don't have a problem
Um, there may at a later date not now not in this month things need to settle where um
We can take official script submissions
However, if veal or where to take like subscriptions it submissions for audios
purposes
Sadly, you have to fully hand over the rights. So we have the right to monetize. We have ownership
We're happy to give credit. Um
I think I don't know if there's gonna be a problem given credit. I haven't thought that far ahead at the moment, but
There's a lot of issues and it's quite a shame
And it's really hard to iron out at this point in time
But once the dust settles and things get a bit better wait get plapped. What are you doing to this?
Do you still have love for the big boy reeflings out there I couldn't help but notice a line in your lore video
Yes
And there's just something I've got to say you're as beautiful as the day I lost you oh
Thank you
That's the how to train your dragon. That's one of the only books I read as a child
I think I read like three books as a childhood and one of them was how to train your dragon
I don't know how I read a book honestly, but I did it
Hmm
She's
dunking us in the water
The books were so good. Literally one of the only books I read as a child
I've read more books this year than I have in my entire life, which is crazy
crazy
I'd pretend that I can do a book review. So I'm not even smart enough for that
I'm currently trying to get through the handmaidens tale. I actually am enjoying the handmaidens tale
I'm like a few chapters in but I I don't know if people find this cheating
But I have to have the book read to me or I can't read it
I this sounds really bad, but it takes up too much brain power to read the words
manually, so I read along whilst being spoken to by tts voice
And no and I can speed it up like super fast. Oh, thank you for the raid
How did your stream go?
How did your stream go rain? Oh, you might be tired. So don't feel forced to talk. Don't feel forced to talk if you're a tired little barbie
Hey barbie, I should have said background music. It's like really quiet in the stream. I don't know if it's
Maybe nice. I hope your stream was good
Endurance streamer creative director and so has time. I've not read any books since debut. I can show you that much
But hi raiders. I'm strong and cut loose from violour. I'm really inappropriate
So I do apologize if I know your cup of tea and I'm also Scottish so I'm super hard to understand but thank for hanging out anyway
Which is I hope your stream went fantastic. Please rest up after your stream
I'm sure you're tired and last thing you want to do is get bombarded with loads of questions from the person
You have kindly rated into so I thank you kindly rain cloud
And I hope you have a fantastic rest after your
game
Game maybe that too
Never know may not be a game. She may not be has to um
Entry all in one breath. She's got lungs. Hey
Strongly looking to push 11 hours at this rate. Should we should we just yap and then make it another 12 hours?
Why is the raid message wait wait? I saw it as weight as well
Like I could hardly read but I had to scroll over. I mean if I make another cup of tea
We could in theory make it 12 hours again
And we just like and we can just talk and I can ask you questions
And then you ask me questions and then I'm going to ramble about something
And then you distract me
And then we're going to another ramble
Do you want that? Yes, please? Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Her favorite form of introduction is tying you until you can't help but fall asleep
They happen a
You feel yourself getting so asleep. They don't know what we're playing. Yeah
It's okay
Let's sleep and brace you slowly
Okay
And then here for 13 and then 14 I mark my words when and if youtube ever fixed vods
14 hour streams not even kidding. You can't I can't get enough of you
I can't I can't get enough of you
And when we do Elden Ring, I am incredibly
I'm incredibly tempted
to possibly
Figuratively do a 12 hour and then raid into a six hour afterwards. I don't know
It's plausible. I'll be a tired bean. I don't know
I wish we could get 14 hours 14 is the like perfect slot of like I can
Still get a full night's rest
Lord inject the scottish lass lord if you can hear me right now inject the scottish lass into my veins
This cult fish is too powerful. Thank god. It's daytime where I live. I don't have to sleep
Stop I can't be more addicted
Than I am you're too good strong
I'm coming for you
I'm trying to kill us. Thank you. Do rest if you need to rest never worry. Okay
Johnny I've got go to sleep. Can you please show us those pretty pink swirls? Oh
Now that I'm so close to you. I absolutely can
Uh, well I go and wow I'm reacting to myself. Please don't react there. Okay. That's more like me
Hold on. Let me put chat behind me just for a moment
Okay, let's see if I can do this problem. Hi. Sorry. I'm so close
Okay, let me move my water out of the way. So I can at least attempt to do something mildly professional for once in my life. Okay
Once in my life I did something a little bit or maybe a little bit
It's okay to be sleepy
It's been a while since
You've rested well reply. Okay
Slowly your phone
Slow slow slow
And your muscles relax slow slow slow
And your brain is quiet slow slow slow
Good night. That's what we've been waiting for. Until the morning
Did I do it did I do it right?
Slow slow slow
Into the slumber you fall
I don't know if I was too close because I'm like, oh
But I need to show up. Seems like you did
A little sleepy moment. Thank you so much. Good night
Slow slow slow. I just woke up. Can I put you to sleep again?
You did great good girl. Yeah
You can't catch me off guard. I've already been called good girl. Good luck. Get me in subspace. I'm in dumb space
When I do hypnosis, I feel very dumb
It's early in the morning. We need a bedtime ASMR. Absolutely. I am more than open to that. We can absolutely do bedtime ASMR
Um, am I allowed to go for a tinkle and a cup of tea as my voice is cooking like a frog?
Um, and then we'll just ramble until the 12 hours. Does that sound like a deal?
You made my boss fall asleep
Super lit. Hi strongy tenor is waiting me right now. Yeah, I'm getting a fraud for our good dom keep it up mama strongy
Hey, thank you very much for the tip. I'm glad you like that. Ah, no my elton my elton ring
My stream elements is gone. So I can't freaking shoot you. Stream elements stream elements are so finicky sometimes
Uh, I'm already logged in go to my dashboard right now
Let's try that again
Oh my fraud my fraud phone call. I can't believe it. They're not getting any not getting it from me
Thank you barrel for the tip. I appreciate it
I'm glad
is it
For our good dom keep it up mama
Yeah
Right, I'm gonna very quickly go make a cup of tea and do a quick tinkle. You are I'm actually gonna pin my
Um
Rain cloud, please rest well rain. Okay
And sleep well. I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna force you to talk. Okay. I think we should talk. Uh, I'm actually gonna pin my
any
Questions question mark
Did that work?
Yeah, it did work. I'm gonna pin it. So you're welcome
Uh, to thank you, but please rest well rain. You work so hard
And you're doing fantastic. Hi scrawny tenor's poke. Happy first week. This was my first rain
Oh my god. Thank you so much. That's so kind of you. Oh my gosh
I'm glad I could take your rate cherry. Am I allowed to say that? I'm sorry. I'm sorry if I'm not allowed to say that
I'm glad I could take it anyway
Okay, I've pinned that I'm gonna go make a cup of tea
I will be roughly three minutes because it takes three minutes for the kettle to boil
Take three minutes for the kettle to boil. Yeah, so you're welcome to ask me any questions of any variety
Okay, but please sleep well rain choir. Thank you for the raid. I really appreciate that
I need to add you on discord actually DM
Yeah, I need to DM the whole yumi plus squad actually and get everyone on discord
And then once I have access to you on discord
The possibility
Right I very quickly mute and I'll go and um
Make a cup of tea. Okay
Okay cup of tea time tea time. Oh wait, I'll do the I'll close my eyes first. Hmm. Oh wait close eyes
I'm not very smart whenever I do that
You
Remember that time we brushed our teeth and I was like fully ready to go bed
Yeah, yeah remember the time. Yeah, okay. I entered the room with a cup of tea. Oh my tongue's sticking out. I was like
You know what time? Yeah, I mean do we need brush up to twice now? I don't know. You're not really supposed to brush it like too much
um
Yeah, I just got caught up
Apparently shebe's alternative twitter is over 10k followers. So what the heck just happened whilst I was streaming
I don't know what I've missed but congrats girls. Oh my gosh
Um
Right shall we
Shall we get to the bottom of it?
She offered feet for okay
Shut up. My toes are out right now. Hold on. I'm putting gupp on my toes right now for the money shot and everything
She has lovely feet
Yeah, she left
The containment zone. Oh
Okay, she componds she componds
All right, let me refresh these marshmallows refresh these marshmallows. Oh, I got 20 more questions. Thank you for all the questions
Um
Some reason it shows marshmallows from like a week ago at the top. I don't know what that means
Does that mean someone's verified is like put it up there on purpose? I don't know how it works
Oh, my stream disconnected. Why does obs do that? I said obs disconnected. I'm still here
Stream you give me a heart attack every time you freaking do that. Please don't do that
Oh
I just get notifications says obs doesn't you've disconnected. I'm like, please no
Please no. I'm trying to make it to the 12 hour mark. Please. Please. We're only one hour away
Someone say
Oh, yeah, you can request me to say stuff on my accent by the way. Someone says please. Can you say ravioli in a seductive tone?
Ravioli in a seductive
ravioli
That little sleep hypnosis thing you did was amazing and convinced you'd be amazing at a meditation type sleep audio
Yes, I want to do like bedtime hypnosis stuff as well like completely like fine
On the table
You haven't even started your hypo content yet and you're already I'm portraying my mind by turning my
internal monologue scoffs. I can't wait for you to turn my brain into your
Ben
Into your female doll. Oh my
Ever since you've debuted I've gone from a man lost in the desert drying of thirst to one drowning in a flood of non-stop good times
Yes
And all I want to do is just close my eyes and let the waves take me
Would you drag me into the depths? I want you to I'm glad you can have good times here
It was it was dry for a while, but I hope
I hope it's good times here good vibes
Yeah, we go swimming together, you know, I don't I playfully dunk your head under the water a little bit
Just playfully and no other reason
No other lower related reason
It was awfully cold in the depths, but now we're in warmer waters. I think you could say
Can you run from prime minister of Australia? So at least they're
If it's bad ideas, it sounds nice coming from me, but I've not even been granted rights into the country yet
There there is a timeline
Where I get rejected
And I can't I have to go back to Scotland and I can't run the business
Let's hope we're not on that timeline. That would be terrible
Could you imagine if I got kicked out? Oh my god
Oh
All right. Hi, scrawny. I don't know if it's been answered already. It's okay to ask something. You're not sure that's been answered
It's not possible for someone to be here all the time. So please don't ever be afraid to ask a question
You think that's already been answered. It's not possible for you to be here all the time. I know
I know it's terrible
Sorry if you did, but I just want to know if you're interested in the game lost planet too
It's on xbox and I think you'd like it could easily play the whole thing in one stream
Also, you play delton ring. Would you be open to playing armor core six armor core six has been popping up over
I've heard the name a few times now. I love your streams that I can't wait to bounce those hypnotic eyes back on you
Stinky
Armor core six, I don't know what it is but it keeps coming up
Lost planet too. I should actually write down game ideas because I I trust your guys's like
Suggestions over anything that I could possibly come up with
Um
AC six is phenomenal. It's great. It's really good
highly rated game
Oh my
every scrawny tone has
Instruct know my default like I feel like my default like I'm like that and I'm all monotone
Like you can't even understand lost planet two is an og xbox game. How did I never come across it then?
I don't know when it came out. Maybe it was still at the stage where like
So I used to get attached to one game and when Assassin's Creed brotherhood came out like I hardly got any new games
I've got skyrim. I got
Black ops ac brotherhood
The rate of like new games like went down astronomical
If it's probes of 2006 2008
And then armor core six
I'll definitely these these games keep coming up and I trust your guys's judgment. Hi, shawnee
I was curious if you they fall guys. Let's chat one day
Uh, yeah, of course, we're doing the jelly bean game. Are you silly? Are you being a silly sausage?
Of course, we're playing the jelly bean game again
I'm also you gonna touch me and grab me and hold me back
You guys wouldn't stop grabbing me you all grab me
You stinky stinkerton
Ah, my calibration's having a hard time today. Hold on. Let me recalibrate
Wow, hopefully my mouth stops wiggling
Okay, it's not wiggling anymore
Jelly bean game
We do what so in the jelly bean game you can like grab opponents and hold them back
To like stop them from jumping to the objective or whatever
And I used to have to beg I was so bad at the game
I would basically have to beg
To people would hold back to let me through the first level
Because I ended up losing it so many times that I wasn't playing the game
And I was spectating you guys play because I was that freaking bad at the game
That is so much fun
So yes, you will absolutely be playing that again. I will always do like a
A stream snip game every month
Um one that's like public and one
I do prioritize free to play games
Unfortunately, I've started off with runescoop
Which normally premium is the only way to play it. So I've picked a bit pearly
I do apologize, but I would like to get 99 cooking
And it would be fun to kind of like achieve goals along the way
Still going strong good old strongy strongy. What type of fan are you like the most?
Oh
Any like whatever inspires you like some people do like a meme funny moment like I uploaded a short
um
In like in the short
I was like and yes before you ask and I went back in the like the bagpipes and like the scottish flag appear behind me
And then someone liked it so much
They basically made a scottish beam come out of my mouth and like the first panel was me going
And then the second panel was like
I was like throwing this scottish beam out of my mouth and it reminded me
There's a trend in hatsu miko world and she goes miko no no this time
You've been waiting for c2 one miko miko beam and it reminded me of that
Um, it is so good like whatever you enjoy like if you enjoy me make a meme if you enjoy the other side of things
You're more than welcome to make the other side of things because I like that stuff too. Um
And yeah, like anything
10 hours deep. Let's go. Yeah, we're gonna make it a 12 hour stream
Uh, so I'm just ranting ranting rambling for the last uh, uh, I were I were last hour
I've got a little cup of tea. Don't know if you can hear my nails on it
I'm just waiting for it to cool down before I can sip it
Stroney any chance of you making a 2d platform video game in the food? That's so specific
Why are you wanting to bounce on me in 2d?
I'm I'm not making a video game. No
I have plans to make video game in the future, but that's the future future like now
What should a lad do if he makes a fan made album? What should uh, sorry
Make a fan made album. What should he send us general art?
Fan made album album
Like a music or
Am I being dumb?
I'm in it for the long haul today. I'm here. We're going. Oh, please don't stay up if it's going to be bad for your health
I don't want you to do anything bad for health
Okay
See me I can be up for 12 hours streaming because you know, roto's a neurona
Uh
A rap stuff. Oh my god, can you do a diss track on me strony cuttles more like strony can't make her mind up uttles
On her 15th persona mottles
Got tape on her
The only reason she's a vtuber is to give herself
Boobies because she ain't got any in real life. Yeah. Whoo. Distracts 20 distract
No, the distracts. Yeah, that's right. You're in distracts again. Oh, I just punched my knuckle against the desk by accident
Someone says I kneel you are too powerful so much kneeling. I like it do it again
It is humbling to know someone like you exist. I've never dumped so much
Ink before within a span of a week
And from it so happy from watching you and the girls. I hope for your success and it's one of the few I feel that is deserved
Oh, thank you so much. Thank you for spilling your ink
I do like hearing about ink spilling like why yes, maybe I am a v sucky after all
Maybe there is sucky by blood
The pause after hearing
Where I live it smells like freshly baked cookies because I'm near a cookie factory and I'm and I'm already awake for today
I'm still going strong. Oh, that's dangerous for your health
It's dangerous to be awake for more than like 16 hours. I think is when
It's bad like it's your brain function. Your cognitive function goes down like big big
I
Knew it. Well velar is going to be my oval
My version of meet the grams will be meet the indulgers
What did you think about the generation name indulge because if I told you technique if I told you a secret
This is a secret for only who watch the stream right now
um
Jen one's name indulge plays into gen two and three
Um, and if we do get to three gens
Oh, I'm gonna be so excited because to reveal the full names because they all play into each other
Uh
I'm so excited. I wonder if anyone could guess that I don't I think it's impossible to get there's too many variations like
Someone says is there a chance for a stream of a software game other than elden brain?
I don't think I can get any help in the other elden rings though. However, I think
She be as interested in blood-borne
But unfortunately, I'm not very good and the reason I like elden ring so much is because you guys can come in and help me
But I'm not good on my own
um
Three gens worth of tubers. I will become a husk
I'll become a husk honestly
Maybe we can guess after the second gen
Oh, no, you can't guess it because there's two secret words that aren't present
It it forms a sentence basically
All three gens perform a sentence that perfectly encapsulates won't be where it is
Indulge marionette and you're like nah
Yeah, you're no the secret words makes it impossible. Just wanted to drop one more
Mario I've watched all the velo girls and well, I like them a lot your mouse. Oh
Thank you. Are you sure? I'm your oh, she though like
I'm not gonna say anything but like emmy's teas and oof aces accent
And she sounds so fucking adorable in our accent. I wish I could copy it, but I can't why is she irish?
I see. Why are you irish?
I don't know
I just love the way she sounds
But I feel like I'm doing a terrible. That's terrible
You have your own accent power
power
Sure, well the sentence will look good, but what gen four? No, I am not. I am absolutely not doing any further
So there some people were like, are you doing a spin-off gen? Are you doing like a safer work variation? No
I've absolutely no interest. I am exhausted. I took so much hp damage getting gen one out
I am very thankful to say that if gen two and three do happen
The hp damage is reduced significantly because I learned so much. I learned so much
and
When you do the first time you do it, it's so hard, but anytime after it just gets easier
But I am I have no interest. I feel like absolutely no
Shade or anything to any other Vtuber agency
If you start throwing gen after gen it is very clear
You do not give an absolute rat's arse about the content for your girls
And it's just it's such a shame that those girls put faith in you as an agency
And your response is throw another gen out throw another. No, absolutely. No
No, very disappointing. I don't like that. That's just me
Uh, you like instantly became my Oshie. I don't have an endurance for long streamers
But I really enjoy stopping in on stream throughout the day. I'm glad I'm glad I can catch it
I'll see you tomorrow in old school runescape. Huh? Huh? You might you might not be in the game
But I'll I'll be online. I'll be online. Okay
55 hp on a player you keep talking
with her damage
Yeah
I keep taking damage with her with her damage
Human wave tactic based running strongy. Are there any ASMR stories based on your life?
Um, I have rambling ASMR coming out where I'm just kind of talking about stuff that's happening. No, that's me
If you mean the small peepee audio then
Uh, there's an anon that's very passionate about it and he sent me a prompt and
Well, he didn't he didn't actually even mean to make it into a script or anything
He just sent me a prompt of what he liked and I was like, you know what you know what I'll make it into something
So your guys are more than welcome to use marshmallows to put down your things because it unironically can inspire me to make like an entire script
Um, I am happy to take inspiration. I'll yank it. I like reading your deep dark fantasy
I want to hit them with a disc tracker. I know but also I don't want to go into them and be like public enemy number one in veilerland
I talk a lot of them
But I'm such a little teddy bear
No, it's all funny you
I have to admit something
I fall asleep to your voice during streams only for a little bit like 30 minutes to an hour
The volume doesn't matter your voice just knocks me out. I get so cozy from the yapping
Did I wake you up through the rage part?
against
Against the rda guy in section. I'm sorry if I woke you up with my screen
Hey, stroney, I'm glad to catch some of your lives. I've been recovering from
The unmentionable one and I'm finally feeling better. I hope to see
many more streams from you and the girls
I
Someone signed this with their name, sorry
I think this might be
um
I'm hope you're okay, and I'm glad you feel better. You're starting to feel more like yourself
Sorry, you've signed it and I don't know if I should see your name out. So for respect
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna think it but you guys are welcome to sign maros
But I won't see your name if you sign a marrow at the bomb. Okay
I'm glad you picked samwise the brave. I am so glad
You my refling gave me the courage seriously
Why the refling?
I don't know
Maybe it's because he gives me courage
Hi, stroney saying this is the scott
So when I say this, you know, it's not just because of the accent
I love your voice. Listen to you up on stream is my favorite part of your stream and when you talk
Gently it gives me tingles. I'm really looking forward to the ASMR. Wait, I can give you tingles
Just when I be a bit more gentler in the magic
That's interesting
Normally, I like I only happen in the the ting the tingy
Goodbye those who are sleeping
I gotta go finish up work. Have a good day. Yeah. Have a good day. Thanks for hanging
Uh
Thank you
Definitely not
Hmm. What are you saying?
Read at your own risk, but are you gonna do a hmm audio involving?
Oh
Let's call it joystick and we'll take the first three letters. Are you gonna do hypno joystick?
Uh, yes, it's one of the main things I'm interested in
I want to take full control
Hmm
The question is can I put you under though? I'm I'm a bit unskilled at the under part
It's scary to put you under because I'm not sure how good I am at it
And as well, I don't know if the accent is actually a debuff on putting you under a spell or the control type
Section of it. So I'm a bit worried
We'll see what happens. As I said, I'm learning and you guys have been fantastic and
Will be like you guys are always fantastic and give me like a lot of space
It'll take time to get
To get there. What am I doing? I'm good at pretending. Oh, I believe in you. Hey
I love that you're
I'm trying I woke up and so you're still streaming now come home and you're still at it. You're on another level
Yeah, we we finished up a cup maybe an hour ago
Um, I kind of leaked kind of who goes there identify yourself. Um about now. Oh my cold. My tea's getting cold
I'm sorry. I'm gonna drink my tea. I completely forgot I had a tea. Sorry
Oh
I'm getting cold
Someone says do not open on stream that makes me want to open it even more just for the hell of it
He
Will you ever do a stream with incur the viewers are encouraged to make it to the end? I don't
Wow
I would never do something like that five
No, no, no, not right now. Not right now. No right now
I couldn't be so dastard like it off. Oh, that's so bad
For no, no, I'm joking. Actually. I'm joking. I'm joking relax relax. No
Yeah, no
No
I take I take more drinks on my tea because I don't want to get the cold
What did did you see what emmy did 0.5 that little brat? Oh
He's punishment
Ah
0.5 is genius
I think I caught up on all the questions already
Uh, hopefully I don't miss too many. Oh, well, we just got another 15. So it's okay. We're not going anywhere
I've almost finished almost finished
Someone made a meme based on stream today, monkaS. I'm fast when you make a meme or is it just me screaming be honest
Hold on see if I can open it up
Okay, hold on. Let me see if I can put this on screen right now. Hold on. Let me kick. Let me kick
Add image someone made this
Engi I'm gonna call it Engi
And then if I go on desktop and then I can put it on stream
So this is the meme. This is the meme to victory
Strongly fighting for the navi freedom
Strongly fighting for the rda angry scottish noises
Good night to those who sleep which one of the girls do you think has um
Uh sheebie I want to say sheebie
um but
Yeah, sheebie. Sorry sheebie
He he
Uh
Yeah, sheebie
I'm I'll leave it that but thank you for the meme. I love it. I was very angry. I I'm scared to listen back to stream
Um
I remember you did small pp time. Um, but have you thought of ntr? I am so sorry
That I can't fulfill this fantasy
Unfortunately, it actually alienates people. Um, I am interested in the opposite though
Where I I help you to my daughters
I
Apologize but unfortunately it is a
Like a no no and it's it's basically career death and I'm so sorry
I really do apologize because I do like the idea of like everyone gets to hear their thing like my attempt at their thing
But unfortunately, I would never do anything that would risk the girls and stuff and I do apologize
Um
Yeah, our cami for real you made this happen through your determinant through my freaking brain deadness
Free but okay, I'll read it because you're actually being very kind to me and I'm just being harsh to myself
Our cami for real you made this happen through your determination innovation love kindness or meaningless take this w
You have deserved it and of course will still support the daughters. They are so wonderful. They are
I need to burp
Who goes there?
I don't know who keeps coming into my room and burping but I keep asking them who goes there and no one responds. It's really weird
Like I asked them to identify themselves
I asked them I say by the pope you have to respond to me
But just someone keeps coming in burping and then leaving it's bizarre
It's totally not me
No question just an old reddish happy to be back and swimming in the reef. Oh, do you like the reef?
Should I get you little armbands? Oh, no, you're well, you're a squid
We're both aquatic
Just wanted to say that I'm proud to call you my cami. Oh, I'll stop you can't call me comey. Oh, she yes
You dork you are my cami. Oh, she and I'm wishing you and the girls success and men may your achievement be many
And tributes plentiful now. Can I make a request for a wake-up alarm? Could you see your?
Best scottish battle cry
Odd can I do it now? I don't know if my voice is too fried to do it now. Hold on. I'll meet now
I'll see if we can do it
Right the sentence is rise warrior jar wake up and make it everyone's problem. You can do it
Oh, I think my voice is too fried, but we'll try it anyway. We'll try it anywhere
Rise warrior jar
Make make up. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Hold on. Hold on. I got stage fright. I got stage fright. I'm sorry
Rise warrior jar wake up and make it everyone's problem. You can do it
Yeah
Sorry, I messed it up
I apologize
How does it feel to know that you have me addicted to women of scottish accents? It's over for you
It's over for you
You crave the rolling ours. You crave the in lock
and most of all
You crave the smell of iron brew
On the breath of the woman you've just kissed
You're you've been scott piled
And there's no turning back
The peak calls me. Oh shit. She's still going
We've got another t-minus
40 minutes. Uh, is mercy gonna be online in 40 minutes?
I never thought about that
I already had a taste for the scottish accent
It's uh vetish. I'm sure no one
But found out when I have mine scott piled. Oh, yeah. Yeah, she's still online. Okay
Before I go offline, please remind me to make sure that mercy's like still actually going to be online
If not, I'm probably going to redirect you into one of her songs
I'll make you listen to aces furry
cover thing
Extinous of passes on you. Oh, you're so warm. Oh
I
Love emmy's emmy aces frx wait
Wait, the reason why I get ac and emmy mixed up all the time
Is it because they both begin with I is because I used to call them the twins in development
They were called the twins in development. I know they're not twins
They I just called them twins. It just happened. Okay. So emmy and ac always get referred to each other by accident
Now this few propositions were a question
If you had a chance to change your oh
I changed
Forget changing fate. I put it into my own hands and I am strontic cuttles
The cuttlefish of
The war
Sending them out to say that you and emmers are my favorites
It means incredibly talented and really entertaining and she's an absolute sucky mom
But there's something about you that makes you so easy to listen to
It's probably because you can tell how low IQ I am. So I make you feel safe
See mersey's a dork
So you lure your guard around her but me because I'm brain dead. Yeah, you can't help that. You can't help that
Thank you for the kind words kind kind of remark
Warning for stream. Let's see how far I can read into this before we can
As you stare into your reeflings eyes to hypnotize them
You get a little too close to one and catch your reflection in the eyes
You suddenly feel tired and a desire to bend to their
Oh
Good girl cuttles you want to give everything to your little reeflings stop. Oh my god
No, I can't read that
Mmm
I need to finish reading it though
No, I can't read that. No, I can't read that. That's going to change my brain thinking right now. I can't read that. Oh my god
Excuse me, mom. I am sure you're my oh, yes. Thank you
Ever said that Mario has made the seal up, bro. I'm not being funny. I felt it flower
My favorite pokemon. Oh, you can't make me pick. Oh, there's so many
I like creepy pokemon. I like when they look cute and creepy
Uh, who wrote that? And you know, no, no subspace stop it. We're not going into subspace another another time
But not not no subspace
No subspace. All right
I bite it
Because if no the problem is if I go into subspace, I can't talk. I literally can't talk. How am I supposed to entertain if I can't talk
If I'm just here squealing like a little
Subspace emissary reference subspace emissary reference. No
subspace is a thinking a type
And it makes it really hard for me to freaking talk
Through it. It's really freaking hard
And I can't talk
And I need to be able to talk
You can't just stare at my face while I go
I'm so happy that I saw you on my Twitter feed. Oh, is that how you found me on Twitter? Oh, maybe I should actually start using Twitter then
Oh, I don't like using Twitter
All the girls have been so fantastic like I'm streaming in one hour. I'm doing this. I'm doing that
I literally have put nothing on Twitter. I can't
like
I
I've used Twitter to make ASMR
Collapse that's it. I can't do it. Okay. Please. Please. I can't do it. Twitter please. It's so
Can't could stare at your face for an age less you underestimate what you do at karaoke stream with the girls
I think latency is too much for me with the girls
However, the girls might be able to do it with one another because latency wouldn't be an issue
Um, I have to put your stream schedule on my desk to make sure I remember. I'm so bad
I apologize if people use twitter for notifications. I I just
I don't like it
I don't like it. I actually don't like it. I'm sorry. Well, I'm off to work. Good night. And don't for
Forget to wash you to brush my teeth. Yes. I won't forget
Uh, if it's been 30 minutes since I last drank. Yes, it will be. Okay. We'll brush your teeth right before you end
Twitter recently uh, officially allowed the content
And it's signal boosting the words mentioning
Is it I'ma make a a certain video then I've been needing to make a video as a thank you for ages
I'm stalling. I'm scared because maybe I should do it now
Maybe
Yeah
Shimmy shimmy. Yeah, shimmy. Yeah, shimmy. Yeah
I wonder what I could be playing
And I really strongly mean may have a good sleep schedule because I wake up early to watch
Oh
I'm glad. Ah, yes, the bits get upside down when they go to Australia. So it takes places long for computer
Uh, it's a bit squid me right now by the pope
Wow, you really are still online
Good morning. Good morning
Thank you, paginga. Yes
Um, we finished the game around the nine hour mark and then ended up rambling so much
We got to the 10 hour mark
And then I made a cup of tea and it just made sense that we're just gonna ramble until the 12 hour mark
Just because we can
Yeah, yeah, no, no, we're just having a good time. We just done our thing. But good morning
And I hope you're all ready for it happening again tomorrow because I'll be online all day
Hey, let me hear about these things. Why am I going so much?
I think I got everything
But yeah, I couldn't I couldn't pick a pokemon. I like creepy we pokemon. Oh, no
All right, I've refreshed again
And there's quite a few more questions. So hopefully I can get to
Stream warning. This is meant to me
Am I supposed to read it then or not?
Yeah, well, I didn't work it right it didn't work
He said kneel and submit
who bad
You're not getting me today
I've done see when I do a little bit of the a little bit of the
Gnosis when I do the noses
I get very
You know
So good luck
another another day, baby
Good girls are entertaining what even stop right?
Scrolling past that stop it
You and the rest of the viewer are the first I ran into to lean
Into the other side of content
I wasn't sure how to take it at first because it's not my cup of tea
But you love being genuinely entertaining regardless wishing on but but thank you so much. Yes
There is a lot of information on the website
And like a lot of people didn't realize what the heck we were doing and it was like bro
We're self-beach over so we'll be playing games like of course
I'm still going to talk about satan creep brotherhood tune and stream snake and all that, you know
It just means we offer the goods on the other side and we're not a blue ball in you
I think because there's quite a lot of v-tubers that like to do the blue ball part and it's like well
If you if you want the goods then yeah
They're for free you can go on all twitters or if you if you want to support uh, then with your with your manis
Then you can just do it
Patreon or membership if youtube updates it stats tomorrow
Hmm you almost went into stuff. I'm not I'm not
But yeah, but you occasionally different at the thingy like in preview
That was to paint you all up though
I think everyone did a good job. We all we all collectively were like, you know that meme that's like
Let me hold on maybe I can find it
I
Put it on string. Oh, yeah, this was literally it
Basically this meme if I can see the image
This one
This was the meme so it was like chaos behind the scene setting up for debut
But like we all came together to discuss how we're like absolutely going to destroy
Everyone unanimously and like do all these like things to like get everyone pent up
I'm not even pretending. Otherwise like literally chaos
Is the top one all of us preparing for debut. But when it came to discussing like, okay, let's release the alt twitters
That was right now
By the pope. I admire your work strongy. You are fantastic. Oh, thank you so much. Thank you so much
Why senior in your title? Do I give you an accent? Thank you for the tip though
senior
I appreciate it. And yeah, I'm glad you enjoyed my work. It doesn't really feel like work. I just feel like I'm
You know a rainbow
Eight
I'm stressing out over nothing my butt said a marshmallow. No, I'm doom spiral. What?
Do you need a is it I think it's called a set or if you if you don't
Um, if you partake, I think it's called a Sarah like oh
You're evil
I know you gave us the most wholesome girl in existence
I've got a lot of those comments where people are like
The whole agency was based around like this alternative thing
And then like everyone's just like memeing along and having a good time and all that and it's like yeah surprise
Like we're we're here for enjoy ourselves
I think it can get quite tiresome of every breath in second. It's
you know
Are you squiddin me right now identify yourself
High strongly and reeflings from euro time zone. Good morning. Good morning. Oh, did you enjoy your sleep? Thank you, alessandro
I did enjoy your sleep. We made it. We made it
You girls are amazing at getting people in credit with first day
My girl's so first day. She a Lamborghini. That's not that song. Oh, what's that song my girl's so thirsty
Yellow lumber purple Lamborghini. I have absolutely not clue what that song supposed to be. Thank you for the tip, alessandro
Yeah, it could be everything but it makes a nice thing a bit of a male
Just curious. But are there any creators you would like to collaborate with outside the group?
sadly, I um, uh very
I don't know what the word is
If people reach out to me, I am more than happy to but I feel like if I reach out then
I'm
Bothering so like the yumi plus girls will be nothing but receptive to me. I absolutely adore them. So I'm I'm gonna try and
Get a collab going with them or something or ASMR or anything like that
Um, but like anyone basically the sentence if you f with me. I f with you, but because like
Oh strong ease from
um
Vila or like I don't want anyone feeling forced and I'm also quite
I'm appropriate with certain jokes and I don't want to make anyone uncomfortable during a collab. So I only
I don't know. I'm just shy like I really like Finn
But I would never ask for a collab because I just I I know for a fact like I would just make her uncomfortable
So I'm just gonna be like thumbs up from afar. Love your stuff. You know can't wait for the next song cover
Stop singing I'm trying to get secret tunnel on my head. Oh my god. That was like so fun
I've been a pie
Sadly most potential clubs speak English instead of scottish. Oh, they'll never understand me. Well, there was actually something really funny. Um
What's that azura in debut called me a fish and when we were doing the mock
I was with the girls like um
We were doing the mock so five of us were in the voice call and whoever was doing the mock went and did it
Um and azura called me a fish
And I was like a fish in my accent and the girls were like laughing up a storm over it
And I was like, oh, yeah, I freaking love it here
Like they're just so amazing and they they just get it
But like I feel like if I collabed with someone outside of viola like they're afraid to make fun of my accent
I'm like, no make fun of it. Are you joking me? I say words funny
Someone was saying like the way I say joe wheel there earlier in that like come on
Why is my freaking mouth wiggling?
I know
I see you doing that
I see you doing that iphone. Don't make him a mouth wiggle
I don't know if it's it's not that dark in this room joe wheeled. I joe wheeled
I